Oh, lass uns keine Sendung brauchen. Der von uns beiden ist eigentlich fertiger. Du hast dich doch auch gestern irgendwie ins Nirwana gesoffen, oder?
Ja, ich war gestern mit Hörern trinken.
Mit Hörern?
Keine Schulddiskussion, ne?
Ja, ich höre mich doch ganz schnell so.
Ich höre mich jetzt auch, ja Tatsache.
Wenn du nämlich erstmal die ganzen Intros vorbeisehst, dann kannst du dich auch wieder an den Hörern bewegen. Dann wird's ernst. Tja, so ist das. Hier ist MobileMax. Tja, wir sind heute eingestellt auf ein Dauer-Podcast, ne?
Die 6-Stunden-Sendung.
Also ich hätte schon gedacht, dass 4 Stunden irgendwas nicht geht, aber...
Ah, ne, 5 Stunden ist glaub ich so das physikalische...
Also ihr könnt ja locker 10 Stunden machen. Muckl ist nicht da, der muss arbeiten.
Ja, das ist ein Podcast, Leute.
Ah, wir müssen doch wieder mehr über Mac reden.
Genau.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es neue iMacs und die Neuigkeiten sind eigentlich schnell zusammengefasst.
Stimmt das?
Alles gleich, Sandy Bridge und Double Thunderbolt bei dem Dicken.
Schön zusammengefasst.
Bei dem Dicken aber nur.
Ist das ein Thema für uns? Ich weiß nicht. Ich bin da jetzt gerade, ich bin überhaupt nicht informiert.
Ich bin auch überhaupt nicht informiert.
Ich bin heute auch ein bisschen durch, ich muss mich echt entschuldigen. Ich habe heute auch schon eine Sendung gemacht und gestern habe ich zu viel gesoffen.
Ja, aber was will man machen?
Also nach 5 Stunden Kippi um.
Also ich könnte schon noch ein paar Stunden mehr machen.
Wir haben irgendwie genug Wind. Okay, bevor wir Gefahr laufen, dass diese Sendung noch länger wird, das ist nämlich schon wieder jetzt schon viel zu lang, ich sag mal, machen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen Schluss, wa?
Herzlich Willkommen bei BUMZACK RETURN.
Moba Max, Nummer 65.
Wir brauchen längere Intros.
Ich hab jetzt auch mit Huckel geschafft. Jetzt auch mit Huckel.
Sag mal was, Huckel.
Dass auch alle glauben, dass du's bist.
Guten Abend.
Ich hab dann eine Woche programmiert an der Huckel-Simulation.
Dein Mikrofon zeigt in die falsche Richtung.
Guten Abend, liebe Hörer.
Hat noch ein bisschen Scheißlatenz.
Du hast mir den Pizza-Funk nicht eingeschaltet.
Bist ein bisschen leise, ne? Wieso bist du nur so leise?
Du hast mich da runtergeriegelt und dich zu hoch.
Denis, das ist sehr interessant.
Wieso hab ich ihn heute hier?
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
So ein weiteres Mikrofon.
Wir feintunen da noch ein bisschen an dir.
Diese Stimmen in Lien werden immer besser, oder?
Ja, Max, das hast du richtig erkannt.
Wir heilen es noch zu sehr. Ich mache noch mal hier den Dingsbums zu. Sag mal was Intelligentes.
Ich bin ja schon mit dem Sagen überfordert.
Also intelligent war das aber jetzt nicht.
Nee, nee. Das ist alles nur Futter für das nächste Intro. Da kann sich David dann wieder voll ausspielen. Ein Intro, wie immer, von David mit einer Nummer dahinter. 1701 war das doch.
Was?
Die 1701 war das doch, glaube ich, oder? Diese Enterprise.
Äh, ja, 1701.
Klar, 1701.
Stimmt, du meinst, er ist ein Trekkie vielleicht, ja?
Ich hab das sogar irgendwie gelesen in seiner Timeline. Dass das damit was zu tun habe. Aber irgendwie kling ich. Kann das sein, dass ich mal wieder kaum zu hören bin oder so?
Du hast ein anderes Mikrofon als wir.
Nämlich gar keins.
Ich hab so den Verdacht, dass ich irgendwas falsch gemacht hab.
Also du bist immer wieder beschissen vorbereitet, die Sendung läuft und dann sowas.
Es hat sich in meiner Abwesenheit also nichts geändert. Schön wieder da zu sein.
Ich hab's schon vermisst.
Ich muss nur erst mal drauf kommen, also ich finde, ich klinge eigentlich okay.
Ja klar, du drehst dich ja auch immer hoch.
Du klingst wieder ganz toll, Tim.
Irgendwie klingst du ein bisschen wie in die Klochüssel gesprochen.
Ach grüßen soll ich.
Von der Klochüssel?
Wen denn, wen denn, wen soll ich grüßen?
Von Dings, wo ich grad war.
Von Dings?
Von Dings, wo du gerade warst.
Darfst aber nicht verraten.
Das ist ja ein bisschen... Kryptisch. Ja, das ist ein bisschen ungerichtet. Insofern passt das hier ganz wunderbar ins Programm. Ja, hier bei dieser Sendung, in der immer alles etwas ungerichtet ist. Nicht, dass uns irgendeiner vorwirft, das wäre hierzu eingefahren. So, wir sind auf jeden Fall, man merkt es schon, wir haben gut gegessen und haben jetzt eigentlich alle Kraft, aber die Mate wirkt noch nicht. Das ist das Problem.
Ich habe ja heute alternativ Mate importiert.
Und dann fangen wir gleich erst mal mit dem Spam an.
Genau.
Flora Power. Achso, ich wollte ja noch was sagen hier. Ich weiß nicht, war das letzte Mal schon so oder ist das jetzt gerade das Neue? Man kann ja jetzt auch Leute flattern, wenn sie nur einen Twitter-Account haben. Das gilt dann auch für David.
Ich wurde auch schon geflattert. Ich auch. Ich hatte schon irgendwie 400 oder so. Wann war das? Eine Woche geguckt oder an sieben?
Schauen wir mal. Jetzt können wir die individuelle Performance der Sendung. Nicht nur die Sendung insgesamt. Jetzt kann man auch sehen, wer...
Aber ich hab nicht gerafft, wo man...
Ich wusste gerade noch nicht, dass das geht.
Du kannst dein Mikrofon-Performance dadurch ein bisschen verbessern, indem du das ein bisschen genau...
Ich probiere bloß immer das Schmatzen zu vermeiden.
Das ist auch gut so.
Aber was ich ja noch nicht gerafft hab dabei, also erstens dachte ich mir, was ist denn das jetzt hier, macht das Sinn? Und dann wurde ich gleich direkt auch geflattert. Und jetzt weiß ich aber gar nicht, wo ich überhaupt sehe, wer über Twitter mich geflattert hat.
Nein, nirgendwo sieht man das.
Wer dich flattert, das sieht man auch nicht.
Das gab's, sonst hätt ich ja nicht gucken können. Irgendwer hat mich gedingst und da war so ein Link, hab ich geklickt und dann kam das Zeug.
Genau, das ist glaube ich, solange die Dinger noch nicht claimed sind, tauchen sie in der Suche nicht auf, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe. Aber wenn man da so auf unclaimed klickt, dann kriegt man die zum Beispiel.
Erst drei? Das waren aber schon mal mehr.
Tja Huckel, wobei du musst...
Habt schon einer abkassiert.
Was in dem Zusammenhang etwas verwirrend ist, ist, dass man manchmal, es gibt dann einen Button für seinen Twitter-Account, den man claimen kann. Und in dem Moment, wo man auch einen Flatter-Account selbst eingerichtet hat, du hast ja wahrscheinlich schon einen, dann gibt es jetzt bei Default auch einen Button für das Flatter-Profil selbst. Das heißt, manchmal sind es sowieso Ad-Flatter und Twitter, das ist noch etwas verwirrend. Auf jeden Fall gibt es keinen Mangel an Buttons mittlerweile.
Ich dachte ja auch am Anfang, ob das jetzt so Sinn macht, aber dann habe ich tatsächlich auch instantan, nachdem ich geflattert wurde, gedacht, ja geil, jetzt kann ich endlich mal die Leute, die sich bisher geweigert haben, einen Account zu machen. Einfach trotzdem flattern.
Das hat schon einen gewissen viralen Charakter.
Das war schon so GPL-mäßig. Ansteckend auf Deutsch.
Es hat aber auch vor allen Dingen funktioniert. Habt ihr vielleicht in meinem Twitter auch gelesen, dieser David Flanagan, der Autofon.
Du bist ja sogar bei im FlatterBlog explizitiert worden. Ist das überhaupt aufgefallen? Dein Tweet, wenn du auf blogflatter.net gehst. Oder nee, warte mal. Entschuldigung, das stimmt nicht. Es ist auf FlatterChat. Und genau, dann ist das nämlich der Post, der zweite derzeit hier. Weekly Review, mention us.
Ach, hier schick einfach irgendwo mal den Link rein.
Ich kann das ja hier mal ganz kurz.
Auf jeden Fall hab ich den einfach so angetrackt und dann hat er sich irgendwie den auch tatsächlich gleich geclaimed, hat über den Twitter-Account ein paar gekriegt und dann hat er auch tatsächlich gleich als nächstes auf seiner davidflanagan.com Seite irgendwie einen Button drauf gemacht. Sind jetzt magere 22, aber an dieser Stelle ja.
Ja, du musst das mal erläutern, wer das ist.
David Flanagan ist halt so ein... Der hat JavaScript The Definitive Guide, also die JavaScript-Bibel seit eh und je, also jetzt schon in der sechsten Edition 1100 noch was Seiten geschrieben. Und darüber hinaus das beste Ruby-Buch, meiner Meinung nach, The Ruby Programming Language. Und der ist einfach ein ganz cooler Hacker. Der schreibt auch noch ein paar andere Bücher, die habe ich allerdings nicht gelesen. Aber so für dieses JavaScript The Definitive Guide, was mir damals auf jeden Fall den Einstieg in JavaScript so ermöglicht hat, und für dieses Ruby Programming Language Buch, da würde ich ihn jetzt, glaube ich, fast sogar mal monatlich subscriben.
Der junge Mann hat sich ja neulich darüber beschwert, dass er mit Büchern kein Geld mehr verdient, und das wurde er dann auch bei Daring Fireball aufgegriffen wegen der bösen Rob-Kopierer. Wobei die These, weiß ich nicht so richtig...
Aber sein Argument war ja, dass hier auch Google da was machen könnte und ich dachte, ach, das ist bestimmt nicht so schlimm, und dann saß ich neben Kollegen oder so und hab irgendein O'Reilly-Buch erwähnt, was irgendwie gerade rauskam und er meinte, ja hab ich, war bei Google ganz oben, gratis Download, okay, das stimmt vielleicht doch. Also ich kaufe ja Bücher.
Hatte er diesen gratis Download dann auch, also ich meine, hat er nur gesehen, dass da einer bei Google die Searchliste als erschienen ist, oder hat er es dort auch gratis downloaden können?
Also er hatte das E-Book in PDF und so direkt gratis von Google, erster Hit. Also ich kaufe ja tatsächlich Bücher, die ich cool finde, auch so bewusst, aber wahrscheinlich machen das einfach zu weniger. Ich meine, ich lad mir halt auch ein paar Bücher, um rein zu gucken, ob sie es wert sind zu kaufen. Aber ganz oft sind sie es nicht und dann lass ich es auch, aber bei denen, die mir richtig was gebracht haben, mach ich das auf jeden Fall. Naja, und dann dachte ich so, ach, der Flanagan, der soll jetzt mal nicht aufhören, Bücher zu schreiben, ne? Darum flattern wir den jetzt alle mal.
Das war nicht eine gute Idee.
Aber haben halt erst 22 gemacht, davon kann er wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht sein Lebensunterhalt bestreiten.
Nein, ein Anfang ist gemacht. Das ist halt dieses generelle Hunei-Problem so auf dem Internet. Wenn man erstmal so eine gute Idee verankern will, braucht man einfach die kritische Masse.
Das ist schwierig.
Naja, und dann ist es eben immer noch so, dass viele, also dass es immer noch so ein deutsch-europäisches Phänomen halt auch noch ist. Also ich weiß halt nicht, ob David Flanagan jetzt auch Geld mal in seinen Flatter-Account gesteckt hat und dann selber flattert. Weil es gibt halt nach wie vor immer auf vielen US-basierten Dingen einfach das nicht. Und viele Amerikaner sind da glaube ich auch nicht unterwegs.
Es gibt da noch so eine mentale Hürde für Amerikaner.
Vielleicht sollten wir mal den Gruber flattern.
Den Gruber flattern.
Also Jungs, ihr habt ja jetzt gehört, hier 5000 Follower, 20.000 Zuhörer flattert einfach den Gruber.
Nicht, dass der es nötig hätte, aber...
Ja, wenn der Gruber mal über Flatter was schreiben würde, das hätte sicherlich Impact. Wobei, ein Problem ist halt noch, dass bei Flatter eben alles mit Euro läuft. Ja, aber... Amerikaner verstehen halt nicht, dass es sich um Geld handelt, wenn da kein Dollar-Zeichen ist. Eure sagt denen nichts.
Das ist das Geld, mit dem auch die Griechen nicht bezahlen können.
Aber es gibt ja jetzt das nächste Konzept.
So sieht's aus.
Die Bitcoins sind jetzt gerade der nächste Hype und...
Willst du darüber reden? Weißt du da was drüber? Ich hab bisher nur schlimme Sachen gehört. Nee, sag mal, ich hab noch nicht wirklich eine gebildete Meinung. Ich hab bloß bisher noch nicht verstanden. Ich hab's einfach noch nicht verstanden. Alles, was ich bisher verstanden habe, ist, dass es irgendwie Luninism ist. Aber vielleicht hab ich ja auch irgendein Argument nicht mitbekommen.
Naja, also es geht halt los, um mal den Abriss zu machen, den historischen, mit dem man ja gerne anfängt, ne? Dass halt einer von den Cypher-Punks vor... Vor 13 Jahren schon mal so ein kleines Manifesto geschrieben hat über eine Kryptowährung, eine, ich glaub sogar schon, distributed Kryptowährung, wo er im Prinzip die Prinzipien von Bitcoin schon mal so verfasst hat und gesagt hat, das wär ja eigentlich mal der Weg, um an Banken und allen möglichen Leuten, die immer so ein paar Prozent abhaben wollen und so weiter und das verfolgen können und so vorbei zu operieren. So und jetzt gibt's halt die Implementation davon. Ich glaube, es gab auch schon mal ein, zwei andere Versuche, aber das jetzt so die richtig ernsthafte. Bitcoin. So und der Clou dabei ist eben, dass es komplett distributed und anonym ist im Wesentlichen. Also das sind so die zwei Key Aspekte. Und jetzt gibt's da so ein paar Prinzipien, die das Ganze tragen. Die sind halt echt wirr zu verstehen und ich empfehle auch jedem nochmal in der Wikipedia vielleicht nochmal drüber zu lesen. Auf die Gefahren, dass ich jetzt vielleicht noch was Falsches erzähle. Aber prinzipiell ist es so, die haben halt angefangen, so ein Tool rauszubringen, das Bitcoin-Tool. Das entspricht sozusagen deinem Bitcoin-Portemonnaie. Das gibt's für Linux, Windows und Mac. Das startest du und hast dann erstmal deine Bitcoin-Brieftasche. Und jetzt gibt's aber keinen direkten Weg, echtes Geld in Bitcoins umzuwandeln. Sondern es ist so, dass jeder, der da mitmacht an diesem Bitcoinsystem, sich sozusagen kryptographische Bitcoins errechnen kann. Also, so wie bei Seti at Home, jeder hat so einen Client und alle rechnen fleißig Keys aus und generieren überhaupt erstmal die Währung. Von diesen Bitcoins gibt es maximal 21 Millionen und es wird prognostiziert, dass es 2016 geschafft ist, alle zu generieren. Oder noch später, was auch immer. Okay, das heißt, am Anfang haben sich die Leute hingesetzt, ihren Bitcoin klein gestartet. Am Anfang war es auch sehr einfach, die ersten Keys zu errechnen. Das ging halt recht schnell und damit wurde sozusagen die Dezentrale Zentralbank gegründet. Das heißt, jeder, der da Bitcoins errechnet hat, hat auch zu einem gesamten Währungssystem beigetragen. Und jetzt gibt es dann halt... Ja, erstmal so den groben Abriss. Jetzt bringt er mich wieder raus.
Der Huckel macht das schon super.
So, okay, haben also die Leute so Bitcoins und jetzt ist der Weg wieder sozusagen mit Dienstleistung und Bezahlen korreliert halt. Du kannst jetzt einen Service halt aufmachen und Bitcoins verlangen für deine Services. Das ist sozusagen ein weiterer Weg, um an Bitcoins zu gelangen. Und dann kannst du halt Bitcoins zu Geld machen, indem du halt deine Bitcoins, die du auf entweder errechneten oder erhaltenen Wege für Dienstleistung verkaufst. An sogenannten Exchange Markets oder Traders. Das heißt, du kannst dann sagen, ich hab jetzt hier 10 Bitcoins und ich will 5 Dollar pro Bitcoin haben. Und dann gibt es halt Leute, die sagen, ja okay, nehm ich. Und so wird sozusagen dieses Währungssystem erstmal so grob aufgebaut.
Also jeder druckt sich erstmal sein eigenes Geld.
Könnte man so sagen. Aber bei einer echten Währung ist ja das klassische, so wie es früher war, ob sie das immer noch so machen, das weiß ich nicht genau, die schummeln ja alle. Aber ist ja so, dass eine Währung irgendwie, die drucken Geldnoten, dafür packen sie aber Gold irgendwo hin. Also dass sie schon sozusagen den Wert vorbestimmt irgendwie zur Seite packen. Das geht natürlich.
Das ist schon ewig nicht mehr so?
Das sag ich ja. Klassisch war es früher so, inzwischen nicht mehr. Aber so, dass es halt durch irgendwas gebackt wird, durch einen realen Wert. So bei Bitcoin, die haben natürlich nicht... Das Bitcoin hatte noch keinen Wert. Und sie haben natürlich auch nicht der Typ, der damit anfängt, hat natürlich kein Gold, um irgendwie das schon mal alles zur Seite zu legen, um die 21 Millionen Bitcoins, die es irgendwann mal geben wird, irgendwie zu finanzieren. Deswegen hat er sich gedacht, okay, ich generiere die, das ist auch beschränkt, glaube ich, auf 1 oder 50 Bitcoins alle 10 Minuten, die gerade entstehen. Das wird dann ein bisschen schneller werden und irgendwann so einen Maximalpunkt erreichen und bis 2033 oder so, oder irgendwann noch immer, sind alle erstellt. Jedenfalls werden die generiert. Und damit Leute die bekommen, müssen die komplizierte Sachen berechnen. Ich glaube auch, dass es inzwischen schon das ist, was diese Transaktionen checkt, dass man das schon rechnet, weil das muss man ja später auch machen. Kommen wir vielleicht später nochmal drauf. Jedenfalls, dass man vollfett rumrechnen muss, um diese Bitcoins zu bekommen. Umso mehr du rumrechnest, umso höher ist die Chance, dass du sie kriegst. Damit einfach niemand alle für sich claimt. Sondern du musst halt Arbeit reinstecken. Die Arbeit ist natürlich verpufft, weil die wird erstmal nicht benötigt. Aber es lohnt nicht, dir die Bitcoins zu holen, indem du hunderttausende Rechner in den Start bringst. Dann kriegst du zwar viele Bitcoins, aber du hast auch viel Strom dafür verschwendet.
Und Hardware und alles.
Dann hast du auch wirklich was dafür geleistet. Das heißt, das, was früher Gold war, ist jetzt sozusagen Rechenzeit. Die ist zwar danach weg, aber wenigstens für die Leute ist es kein Gewinn, sich unendlich viele Bitcoins irgendwie durchrechnen zu erstellen, weil sie es ja in Strom bezahlen oder in Rechenpower. Aber das ist jetzt der Jumpstart für diese Bitcoin-Währung, dass die so langsam entstehen. Somit füllt sich gerade die Bitcoin-Menge langsam auf, ohne dass, klar könnte man sagen, die Early Adopters, die haben jetzt ein bisschen Vorteil gehabt, wahrscheinlich gerade vor einem Jahr, als sie angefangen haben. Vielleicht hat der Owner sich gleich in den ersten 50 Tagen, als es noch voll easy war, eine Menge Bitcoins gemacht. Das hab ich keine Ahnung, müsste man mal nachforschen. Aber jetzt sozusagen, die Währung startet langsam los. Und dass die ersten jetzt mehr haben, das kannst du bei dem Klondike auch so sehen, dass die ersten kriegen halt mehr Gold, als die, die dann später kommen. Das ist halt einfach so. Aber die Währung, die wird sozusagen jetzt gerade so losgetreten. Und dann gibt es schon halt schon so Money-Transfers, wie irgendwie MT-Gox oder MN-Gox, oder wie die heißen. Da kannst du richtig sehen, wie viel gerade ein Bitcoin wert ist. Das sind nämlich gerade 7,90 Dollar oder so. MN-Gox, wie heißen die genau?
Es gibt Börsen, die das handeln.
Genau, es gibt so Umwandlungsbörsen. Da kannst du hingehen und sagen, du möchtest jetzt für 1000 Dollar Bitcoins kaufen. Dann geben dir die. Und andersrum, in beide Richtungen. Und das sieht aus wie Aktienmarkt, richtig mit Charts und wie der Verlauf ist, Angebot und Nachfrage und so weiter und so fort.
Also, na ja, das gab es auch schon mal für Second Life, aber da war es halt...
Die Schulen sind wahrscheinlich immer die gleichen.
Aber da steckt ja eine Firma dahinter, die die einfach drucken konnte nach Belieben und jetzt bei diesen Bitcoins.
Theoretisch werden die ja auch gedruckt, aber nicht nach Belieben, sondern du musst halt dafür mitrechnen.
Das ist wie mit dem Gold. Ich finde die Gold-Analogie eigentlich schon super passend, weil für Gold musst du auch Arbeit investieren. Die ist danach genauso verpufft wie bei den Bitcoins. Und der Wert so eines Bitcoins liegt nicht darin, dass da viel Arbeit drinne steckt, sondern dass sie selten sind. Genau wie beim Gold. Gold ist auch der Wert daran, dass sie selten ist.
Zur Zeit, man muss irgendwie so Blöcke rechnen. Wenn man ein Block berechnet hat, kriegt man, glaube ich, gerade 50 Bitcoins. Aber man müsste da irgendwie, hat so ein Typ mal irgendwas geschrieben. Ich weiß nicht, was er für ein Rechner hat, aber er meint, er müsste 3.000 Tage rechnen. Das sind ja 10 Jahre. So, das heißt, bei 50 Bitcoins, A8 Dollar, sind wir bei 400 Dollar, die das Wert wären. Das heißt, in den 10 Jahren würde er wahrscheinlich auch 400 Dollar oder eher noch mehr irgendwie an Stromkosten rausholen.
Muss man ein paar Mal probieren mit dem Reloden. Das ist halt dieser Bitcoin-Market, diese Börse, wo du die Charts siehst.
Gestern oder vorgestern war Bitcoin auf Slashdot und die sind eh geslashdottet.
Mit einem Imaging-Server sind sie schon irgendwie drei.
Na das ist halt irgendein Tool, das ist einfach nur Monitort.
Hätten sie das mal lieber in Erlang gemacht.
Das ist wirklich nur eine GUI. Das System selbst ist ja ganz anders. Der Clou ist halt, wie gesagt, dass alle Bitcoins, die es gibt, die sind in einer Distributed Hashtable drin. Das heißt, jeder, der mitmacht, der hat auch Wissen darüber, was es überhaupt für Bitcoins gibt. Das heißt, du kannst keinen einzelnen Punkt killen oder kein einziges Land und damit irgendwie das System runterbringen, sondern die Bitcoins...
Aber was hält mich denn davon ab, jetzt dieselbe Münze, die jemand anderes hat, auch zu erzeugen?
Dafür ist ja diese kryptographische Becker, der das irgendwie regelt.
Also es gibt schon eine zentrale Distanz. Ja, aber wenn ich diese Distributed Hashtable ignoriere, was ist dann?
Also guck, ich hab hier jetzt...
Also geht das nicht?
Na, weil die Clients, glaube ich, auch Mittel haben, dass, oder wie das genau funktioniert, weiß ich nicht.
Die Leute denken, Flatter wäre kompliziert.
Das ist wirklich relativ kompliziert, aber es ist halt auch extrem cool. Also erstens dadurch, dass es halt, wie gesagt, kein einzelner Provider ist, sondern die Peer Group sozusagen komplett das regelt. Also du kannst es halt nicht kaputt kriegen technisch. Und das ist halt anonym, ne?
Wie sicher kannst du dir da jetzt sein, in dieser Aussage, dass das nicht kaputt zu finden ist?
Klar gibt es immer noch bestimmt irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken, aber zumindest so die Kryptonerds, die sich das schon mal angeguckt haben, meinten, das sieht schon relativ wasserdicht erst mal aus, so vom Ansatz, um kryptografisch zu sein.
Also da gibt es so eine Art Blockchain, da sind ganz viele Signierungen hintereinander weg. Und wenn du unterschreibst, dass du mir Geld gegeben hast, also das Geld sind sozusagen immer so Signierungen oder Blöcke. Du unterschreibst es und hängst es bei ganz vielen Leuten an diese Blockchain ran. Und die kriegen all diese Information und bestätigen, dass du unterschrieben hast, dass ich das Geld bekommen hab. Und ich hab jetzt zum Beispiel vor zwei Tagen mir Geld schenken lassen, 0,02 Bitpoints. Kann man sich von so einem Typen schenken lassen, der das auch beim Jumpstarten helfen will.
Ach, man kann sich da, es gibt nicht nur einzelne, komplette Bitcoins?
Nee, die kann nur runtergeteilt werden, weil wahrscheinlich, die gehen davon aus, dass es eine sehr hohe Deflation gibt, bis alle Bitcoins entstanden sind. Und danach noch mehr, weil dann gibt's ja keine neuen mehr. Das heißt, da wird immer mehr an Wert bekommen und deswegen ist ein Bitcoin dann irgendwann vielleicht mal 1000 Dollar wert. Und deswegen kann man in der Zukunft, wahrscheinlich wird in Milli-Bitcoins gerechnet oder irgendwie so.
Und wie klein kann man die machen? Also was ist die kleinste Einheit, die es da gibt?
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher. Ich hatte irgendwas mit ein Zehn hoch Achtel oder ein Achtel kann es ja nicht sein. Also muss es noch sehr viel kleiner sein.
Wir sehen jetzt also dieses Bitcoin-Chart und du siehst ganz oben MT Gox. Das ist der größte Exchange-Trader. Und beim 30-Day-Volume siehst du, dass er 4 Millionen US-Dollar in diesem Monat gechanged hat. Also von Bitcoins nach Dollar oder von Dollar nach Bitcoins. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht genau. Und das Daily-Volume ist 127.000 US-Dollar. Und das gesamte Kapital, was sozusagen jetzt da in Bitcoins existiert, wird so auf grob 50 Millionen US-Dollar bereits geschätzt. Und vor einem halben Jahr war halt eine Bitcoin 20 Cent wert. Jetzt ist sie bei 8 Dollar oder 5 Euro.
Hätte man damals gut anlegen sollen, oder?
Das heißt, genau. Also die Leute, die am Anfang sich Bitcoins gemacht haben, die könnten jetzt auch so ein Hedge-Fund...
Könnte man da mal in tausende Bitcoins investieren und gucken, was passiert? Also, einen Hunderter würde ich sofort machen.
Irgendjemand hat hier noch sein GSM-Telefon dran.
Ich nicht. So, naja, und wie ich eigentlich drauf gekommen bin...
Bist du es mit deinem iPad? Oder ich bin es mit meinem iPad. Mein Gott, heutzutage hat man immer alle SIM-Karten drin. Stecken, das ist auch echt furchtbar.
Aber wie ich da drauf gekommen bin, war halt, dass eben Andreas erzählt hat, dass es als Tor-in-Service einen Drogendealer gibt, der als Bezahlung Bitcoins akzeptiert.
Und dann hast du gleich mal gebestellt und die kamen auch prompt.
Und das ist halt schon eine krasse Nummer.
Noch mal kurze Theorie. Also wenn ich das irgendwie richtig verstanden habe, es gibt jetzt so eine mit... Also ich hab noch nicht begriffen, wie die sicherstellen, dass eine Bitcoin unik ist. Das hab ich noch nicht verstanden.
Aber nehmen wir mal an, dass wir so...
Nee, jetzt sehen wir erst mal so an, das ist so. Das heißt, es gibt eine endliche Zahl an Geldscheinen. Und das heißt, wenn dann irgendwann mal alle existieren und man bewegt sich in diesem Währungssystem, versteh nicht, wie sich da jetzt so ein Wert mit assoziiert. Ich meine, woher soll ich wissen, wie viele Bitcoins ich für irgendwas berechne, wenn ich gar nicht weiß...
Was die Wert sind?
Was die Wert...
Woher weißt du es denn bei deinem Euro?
Woher weißt du, was ein Dollar wert ist?
Ein Euro ist ja meine Währung, nicht wahr?
Woher weißt du, wie viel ein Euro wert ist?
Aber der Euro steht nicht in Konkurrenz einer anderen Währung, sondern das ist die Fault-Währung. Ich bezahle alles in Euro.
Ich bezahle alles in Bitcoins, könnte ich jetzt sagen.
Ist aber nicht so.
Könntest du aber... Das ist eine andere Währung.
Ich könnte dir das sagen, aber dadurch ist es halt nicht gleich so.
Du könntest es jetzt ja mal voraus... Also so theoretisch annehmen. Du weißt doch nur, dass dein Euro irgendwie, dass deine Miete hier einigermaßen okay ist, weil du weißt, dass du für dein Euro auch 3 Äpfel kriegst und dass deine Miete irgendwie 300 Äpfel wert ist im Monat. Oder irgendwie so, dass du einen Bezug hast. Das gesamte System musst du ja betrachten. So ist es doch bei Bitcoin auch irgendwie einigermaßen. Und ich meine, da würde keiner 7,98 Dollar oder 7,1 Dollar von mir aus für ein Bitcoin ausgeben, wenn es viel weniger oder viel mehr wert wäre. Viel mehr schon. Aber der Markt regelt sich doch von selber. So wie der Euro mal fällt und mal steigt. Im Gegensatz zum Dollar zum Beispiel. Und dann die Apple-Preise zum Beispiel sich anpassen. Also ist doch alles sehr dynamisch. Und bei Bitcoin ist es noch gerade sehr doll dynamisch. Also es kann auch innerhalb eines Tages zwischen 5 und 8 Dollar schwanken. Und vor wohl drei Monaten war es noch irgendwie 2, 3 Dollar wert. Und letztes Jahr war Bitcoin noch 1 Dollar wert. Also er steigt gerade.
Extrem.
Also durch das Slash dort wahrscheinlich auch.
Also es herrscht Inflation sozusagen.
Nee, Deflation.
Was ja wieder schlecht ist, weil alle Leute dann nur Bitcoin sammeln und die nicht ausgeben wollen, weil sie denken, dass morgen mehr wert. Deswegen ist ja Deflation theoretisch schlecht.
Das killt die Wirtschaft.
Ja, weil alle nur sparen und nicht ausgeben wollen.
Also das ist halt auf jeden Fall schon auch eine Art Testballon. Also zum einen gehen die selber davon aus, dass sie in 12 bis 18 Monaten einfach verboten werden, weil es halt total anonym ist und dezentral und an allem vorbeigeht, was sonst immer irgendwelche Beträge abnimmt und sonstigem. So, also Parallelwährungen finden ja die meisten nicht so cool. Und es ist halt auf jeden Fall so in dem Sinne schon eine Testrakete, um mal zu gucken, wie weit kann man es mit dem Internet treiben, sich von der, von den alten Strukturen sozusagen.
Okay, ich frage jetzt noch mal ganz doof. Also angenommen, ich würde jetzt aus irgendwelchen Gründen... Na gut, es gibt zwei Fälle. Entweder ich würde einfach sagen, schenk mir doch mal Bitcoins, dann hätte ich die. Ich müsste halt mal überlegen, wie ich daraus einen Wert ziehe.
Klick mal auf Bitmarket Euro.
Und diesen Wert könnte ich sozusagen dadurch bekommen, dass ich entweder Dienstleistungen, die ich haben will, in Bitcoins selber bezahlen kann. Aber ich hab zu Recht erstmal keine Vorstellung davon, von was eigentlich irgendwas gelöst ist.
Du würdest mir jetzt Geld zukommen lassen wollen, anonym. Dann würdest du da hingehen, würdest dir sagen, 100 Euro. Würdest du hingehen, würdest sagen, kauf dir Bitcoins im Wert von 100 Euro, gib die mir und ich wandle sie wiederum in Euro. Dann haben wir eine Transaktion gemacht, die, wenn dieses System tatsächlich funktioniert, komplett anonym war, obwohl sie total digital war.
Und wie gebe ich dir diese Bitcoins?
Entklick mir die Datei zu, schickst.
Du musst keine Dateien schicken. Da gibt es hier so einen kleinen Tool, da sagst du hier, kannst hier sagen, du willst, hier oben ist es Send Coins, kannst hier sagen, an welche ID du das schicken willst und den amount und dann sagst du senden. Das geht dann raus ins Netz. Das kriegen dann ganz viele Leute, also die Kleinen, die auch gerade alle laufen, sehen, dass du unterschrieben hast, dass der das kriegen soll, die hängen das alle an eine sogenannte Blockchain ran, immer die längste Blockchain gewinnt. Und wenn das ganz, ganz viele bestätigt haben, dann ist diese Überweisung durch. Also bei meiner Überweisung, die ich bekomme, steht auch, dass ich jetzt schon 560 Confirmations habe. Unendlich viele Leute, also 560, haben schon bestätigt, dass der Typ, der mir das überwiesen hat, wirklich mir das überwiesen hat. Das heißt, es ist jetzt sehr schwer, gegen diese Cloud anzukämpfen, um irgendwie doch das anders hinzudrehen.
Man muss halt sagen, dass alle Transaktionen transparent sind. Man sieht die Transaktionen durch das Netz wabern, aber man weiß halt nicht, wer wer ist sozusagen. Das heißt, das Netz sieht halt, ok Bitcoin A ist jetzt von...
Aber ich hab schon so eine ID.
Du kannst auch hier immer wieder eine neue nehmen. Das ist ja total egal. Die ID ist eigentlich nur die Adresse, damit man dich irgendwie findet, damit die Coins halt bei dir ankommen gerade.
So wie bei Torhidden Services, du auch irgendeine Domain in dem Tor-Netzwerk hast, aber wo diese Domain terminiert, ist halt nicht klar. Ich versteh das überhaupt nicht.
Diese Bitcoins kann man sich vorstellen als irgendwie, ich sag jetzt einfach mal so, kleine Files auf deinem Rechner. Du hast nicht irgendwo ein Konto in dieser Cloud oder so, sondern es sind wirklich Files unterschrieben, dass sie jetzt deine sind, also du hast die halt.
Aber ich hab noch nicht begriffen, wie ich damit jetzt wirklich bezahle.
Du hast halt dieses Programm, deine Wallet sozusagen mit den Bitcoins drin und du siehst jetzt, Frank hat auf seinem Blog irgendwie akzeptiert jetzt Bitcoins, hat seine ID dahingeschrieben, dann gibst du in deiner Wallet ein Franks ID, 5 Bitcoins, peng.
Und dann?
Dann kommen die bei ihm irgendwann an, so innerhalb von 10 Minuten.
Ja, aber wie kommen sie an?
Du unterschreibst, schickst diese Netz in die Cloud rein. Was unterschreibe ich?
Die Bitcoins.
Meine Dateien signiere ich kryptographisch.
Deine Bitcoins, dass du die dem Frank gegeben hast. Schickst du das raus ins Netz, dass es alle kriegen, die hängen es alle überall ran.
Womit signiere ich das?
Mann, das ist doch Krypto.
Willst du jetzt bis aufs Bit runtergehen?
Nein, du sagst das anonym, aber ich muss Dinge signieren, das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen.
Du hast halt keinerlei personenbezogene Daten an diesem Kino und du kannst sie nicht jederzeit wechseln.
Aber was ist denn diese Signatur wert, wenn ich...
Zur kryptographischen Verifikation.
Das ist eine Währung, die kein Mensch versteht.
Muss man auch nicht verstehen.
Ich verstehe doch normal, wie man keinen Mensch...
Du weißt exakt, wie PAP SSL funktioniert, und zwar bis runter aufs Bit.
Nö, aber ich weiß nicht, wie ich dir 10 Euro gebe.
Ja, bei SSL und PGP machst du ja auch.
Ja, das ist ja auch...
Guck mal, sag mal ein anderes Beispiel. Bei deinem Telefon wird ja angeblich auch verschlüsselt.
Ich verstehe nicht die Implikation.
Du benutzt es einfach und benutzt dieses Wallet auch einfach. Und gehst davon aus, dass es schon alles stimmen wird.
Ich gehe einfach davon aus, dass es schon seine Richtigkeit hat. Und dann bin ich irgendwann mal total pleite.
Du musst doch keine Millionen Dollar da reinlegen. Du brauchst doch nur 100 Euro reinpacken.
Der Punkt ist, du willst zum Beispiel WikiLeaks Kohle geben. Und irgendwie alle Payment Provider dieser Erde geben WikiLeaks keine Kohle. WikiLeaks kann sich aber halt irgendwie eine beliebige Bitcoin-ID aussuchen. Und du kannst total anonym und nicht verhinderbar WikiLeaks Kohle geben und sie können...
Woher weiß ich, dass hinter dieser WikiLeaks-ID auch wirklich WikiLeaks steckt?
Na ja, wenn sie das auf ihre Seite schreiben. Oder keine Ahnung was.
Ja, indem dir irgendjemand die Kontonummer gibt. Weißt du bei einer Kontonummer auch nicht, ob da WikiLeaks steckt?
Ja gut, dann unterschreibe ich mit einem von mir selbst erfundenen ID meine eigenen Bitcoins. Und dann schicke ich die, wem sage ich da Bescheid.
Na wie es ganz genau innen drin geht.
Einerseits heißt es irgendwie dezentralisiert und dann gibt es wieder aber irgendwie...
Tim, wir haben nicht den Anspruch dir das jetzt zu erklären.
Das ist halt ein Kratzerwappen. Das ist eine Dezentrale, das heißt alle, die da bei Bitcoin mitmachen, sorgen dafür, dass deine Überweisung bei wem auch immer ankommt. Und das heißt, das kann niemand kaputt machen, weil man müsste alle tausenden Bitcoin-Clients, die da draußen laufen, irgendwie zerstören. Und das geht halt nicht. Das ist fast ein bisschen so wie DHT bei BitTorrent.
Oder andere Distributed...
Hast du es verstanden, Max?
Es gibt einfach irgendwo... Du hast einen Key, der relativ selten ist.
Ich habe eine Frage, ob du es verstanden hast.
Garantiert nicht hundertprozentig.
Hundertprozentig habe ich das garantiert auch nicht verstanden. Irgendwelche, die meisten wahrscheinlich nicht, würde ich grad mal behaupten. Aber es ist doch bei vielen Dingen so. Außer muss man ja am Anfang... Na warte, wenn man sich mit irgendwas beschäftigt, dann kann man ja auch nicht gleich am ersten Tag davon ausgehen, dass man alles komplett verstanden hat. Wenn das so wäre, dann werden wir ja alle einsteigen.
Und gibt es da eine Backetosh-Applikation für... Das ist jetzt ein bisschen zu einfach, ja?
bitcoin.org.
Ich glaube, du wirst uns schön über das User-Interface meckern.
Total, weil es nicht mit dem Java geschrieben oder Flash... Nee, schlimmer.
Noch schlimmer, GTK.
Irgendwie so ein Widgets-Schnick-Schnack. Ja, schick sieht es nicht aus, aber...
Schreibt mal jemand ein schönes iPhone-App für Tim, dann ist er total begeistert von dir.
Wurde abgelehnt von Apple.
Wurde abgelehnt? Mit welcher Begründung?
Da kaufen Leute Kinderfondos und Drogen mit.
Ja, das alternative Zahlungssystem, das nicht den iTunes-Store benutzt.
Sollen sie es halt unterstützen, ist doch kein Problem.
30 Prozent Bitcoins an Apple.
Genau, sie haben einfach ihren Anteil nicht bekommen. Dann konnte man dann per In-App-Purchase Bitcoins kaufen.
Guten Tag, unterstützen Sie mein Währungssystem, was in hohem Verdacht steht, in ein paar Monaten weltweit verboten zu werden?
Ihr Bitmarket EU könnt da auch nochmal anklicken. Da gibt es sozusagen so einen europäischen Trader und da kann man dann bei Market klicken und sieht dann sozusagen die Angebote und die Nachfrage, was soll die Leute für ihre Bitcoins und so weiter haben wollen.
Woran sehe ich ihn jetzt, ob ich hier nochmal die Uhr sage?
Was war das, Bitcoin Market?
Habe ich hier in den Chat, bitmarket.eu.
Boah, bist du mich wohl verklickt?
Die Seite lädt auch sehr langsam.
Webseiten mit viel Charts fand ich schon immer...
Ey, das sind halt einfach viele Metaseiten. Das ist keine offizielle Bitcoin-Seite. Das ist einfach nur einer, der gesagt hat, ich beobachte jetzt alle Trader.
Das ist ja alles dauernd. Wie soll denn das stabil funktionieren hier?
Das sind ja nur die Handlungswebseiten.
Es skaliert ja voll gut.
Wenn du eine neue Sendung raushaust, bricht auch alles zusammen. Das skaliert auch nichts.
Genau.
Du bist echt eine Meckerfresse heute.
Nur weil es nicht Flatter drauf hat.
Ich würde dir mal vorgeworfen in den Kommentaren, ich wäre nicht unkritisch genug.
Ach so, ach so, heute bist du...
Du hast es falsch verstanden. Du bist bei Apple nicht unkritisch genug. Bei allen anderen bist du schon sehr, sehr kritisch. Ich sage nur Microsoft und Nokia.
Aber klick mal auf Market oben, dann kannst du das auch noch mal kurz dir vor Augen führen. Wie da so die Angebotsunnah-Frage aussieht.
Aber eigentlich ist die Idee doch... Also es ist ein alternatives Handlungssystem, das mal im Netz funktioniert.
Na, es hat aber auch schon ein paar Nachteile. Also zum Beispiel, wenn Hucke mir hier seine Adresse gibt, seine aktuelle, die er gerade benutzt, und ich überweise ihm was und ich mach da irgendwie einen Copy-Paste-Fehler und irgendwie hat irgendjemand zufällig diese falsche Adresse, die ich dann reingepastet hab und ich schiebe ihm irgendwie 1000 Dollar rüber, dann sind die weg, weil man kann dann nie rausfinden, wer das nun genau gewesen ist. Und die ist auch nicht unumkehrt, also man kann die nicht umkehren, so eine Überweisung. Man kann die nicht rückgängig machen. Es ist einfach unterschrieben, ist unterschrieben, ist es weg. Das ist schon mal eine Sache. Aber das ist bei dem Konto nicht so. Da kannst du dich schon kümmern und machen und tun und versuchen, deine Kohle wiederzukriegen. Und man weiß auch, wo die gelandet ist und so weiter.
Und wenn du deine Bitcoins verwummelt hast, sind sie auch weg.
Da muss man sich halt wirklich...
Also es hat auch die wesentlichen Vorteile von Bargeld. Es ist nicht nachvollziehbar.
Und Überweisung kostet halt nichts. Also man kann eintragen, dass man für eine Überweisung 0,01 Bitcoin ausgibt. Dann geht die wohl ein bisschen schneller, weil die Leute sich dann eher drauf stürzen, um zu überprüfen, dass es stimmt. Weil es müssen ja möglichst viele Leute überprüfen. Weil es ist ja so ein Cloud-Ding. Aber zurzeit eigentlich kriegt man Überweisung durch, ohne dass man irgendwas bezahlt. Dann dauert es halt aber 10 Minuten oder eine Viertelstunde. Und dann kann man sehen, wie diese Confirmations-Counter hier so steigt. Am Anfang hat es halt nur einer bestätigt. Das nützt natürlich gar nichts, weil das kann der Überweiser selbst sein. Der kann dich ja beschummeln. Aber irgendwann hast du dann ab 5 oder ab 7 wird das dann als bestätigt angesehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob der Wert sich auch wechselt, je nachdem, wie groß die Cloud irgendwie ist.
Naja, also ich finde es auf jeden Fall schon mal lohnenswert, sich zumindest mal das Konzept nochmal auf der Wikipedia oder auf der Bitcoin-Seite durchzulesen. Weil es ist schon irgendwie alles ganz smart. Und so der Versuch, eine Distributed Notenbank zu machen und eine Währung aufzuziehen an allen Kontrollgremien vorbei. So richtig Internet-Hacker-Spirit wie am Anfang.
Tja, der CIE zur Währung, der hat irgendwie noch nicht stattgefunden.
Ja, und was es noch gibt, also weil die Bitcoins ja gerade immer noch generiert und man kann ja versuchen, welche davon abzubekommen. Wie gesagt, selber berechnen bringt es. Weil man würde mit einem Standardrechner irgendwie zehn Jahre brauchen. Man kann da jetzt schon mit Grafikkarten-Power einsteigen, aber es kostet halt auch eine Menge Strom. Was man aber machen kann, ist, man kann sich bei sogenannten Bitcoin-Pools irgendwie beteiligen. Die rechnen wohl gerade mit ihrem riesen Power alle zehn Minuten ihre 50 Bitcoins, oder wie schnell auch immer, und man kriegt dann einfach immer nur den Anteil der Menge, die man mitgerechnet hat. Also das kriegst du dann natürlich nicht die gesamte Menge, aber du kriegst wenigstens immer deinen Anteil.
Aber wenn man eine Platte stirbt, ist die Kohle weg sozusagen.
Ja, ist wie mit deinem Portemonnaie. Wenn der Portemonnaie verliert, ist die Kohle auch weg.
Hier gibt es Bitcoin Pool, da kann man sich dann für... Hier ist in bitcoinpool.com Genau, da kann man sich mal spontan irgendwie zu Pools und so zusammen... Das ist ein Pool, ich hab's...
Na, es ist wohl immer die gleiche Software, aber es gibt verschiedene Leute, die da Pools irgendwie starten.
Naja, so viel also zur Bitcoin.
Okay, mal schauen. Das muss mir irgendwie nochmal vergegenwärtigen.
Aber mir hat immer noch keiner was überwiesen.
Die Coin ist noch nicht gefallen. Wie heißt denn da der Cent dann irgendwie? Es gibt nur Coin, gibt keinen Zwei, gibt keine Unterteilung.
Wie gesagt, das gibt's halt schon eine Weile, aber es hat jetzt durch so ein Slashdot und so ein paar Blogposts irgendwie auch von provinenter Stelle irgendwie. Was war der Titel? Bitcoin, the most dangerous thing like Bababa?
Hier von Kalanis.
Das warberte halt vor kurzem jetzt so richtig Babelmäßig komplett durchs Netz und deswegen fliegt die Kuh da gerade auch nochmal in eine ganz andere Richtung wahrscheinlich.
Also ich finde, ich bin mal sehr, ich glaub nicht dran, dass dieses System hier so überleben wird. Also das wird entweder verboten werden, oder was ich ja glaube, das wird sich eine Schwachstelle zeigen, das wird einfach gehackt werden. Und dann hat irgendjemand alle Bitcoins und das wird dann so so rumgehen, aber irgendwann wird das schon nochmal ganz spannend werden. Nicht im zweiten oder dritten Anlauf wird das dann gehen.
Ich paste hier, achso, da ist ja genau dieser Artikel genau dieser Artikel. Dieser Artikel im Chat. Bitcoin, the P2P currency, the most dangerous project we've ever seen. Das ist eine gute Zusammenfassung zumindest. Insert more Mate. Wir haben nicht Mugebubu gefaselt mit der Bitcoin.
Wo wir gerade bei komplexen und schwierig zu verstehenden Dingen sind. Es gab ein paar Probleme mit dem Feed von Mobamex. Leute haben sich beschwert. Immer gut, wenn sowas auf Twitter hochkommt, dann merkt man das auch. Podpress hat es mal wieder irgendwie. Also ich weiß nicht, dieses ganze WordPress ist ja immer noch...
Das ganze Internet.
Das ganze Internet und insbesondere das von WordPress getriebene Internet, das ist sehr irre. Wie in dieser ganzen PHP-Welt so mit Zeichen-Encoding umgegangen wird und Escaping, das ist wirklich... Man wundert sich überhaupt nicht, dass es da so viele Sicherheitsprobleme gibt.
Lass mich raten, was der Fehler war. Sie haben abgekürzt den Exerpt und haben das nicht nach Zeichen getrennt, sondern nach Byte getrennt und haben es geschafft, ein UTF-8-Zeichen genau in der Mitte zu zerstellen.
Ja, oder so Ampersands, die nicht escaped sind und so ein Kram. Irgendwie sowas völlig Diffuses, Unklares. Dieses ganze Zeichenhandling befindet sich immer auf der falschen Ebene.
Das hab ich schon mal geschafft. Dann hab ich einfach noch, weil ich keinen Bock hatte, WordPress umzubauen, hab ich dann einfach in dem vorderen Text noch irgendwo ein Wort eingebaut, ein Füllwort, sodass dann der Umlaut nicht mehr genau am Ende des Strings war bzw. eine Hälfte kaputt gemacht worden ist. Damit hat sich das Problem erledigt.
Ja, es ist dramatisch und irgendwelche Updates eingespielt. Das hat es dann zwar verändert, aber nicht wirklich behoben. Dann hab ich auch angefangen in irgendwelchen iTunes-Subtiteln usw., wo auch immer der Feed-Validator meinte, dass das irgendwie ein Problem ist, diffus irgendwelche Änderungen zu machen, in der Hoffnung, dass das dann endlich weggeht. Mittlerweile kann man wohl das auch wieder ziehen. Es ist aber auch dann erstaunlich, dass so viele Programme, die so Feeds lesen, auch so unterschiedliche Probleme damit haben. Also ein unterschiedliches Maß an Federtoleranz aufweisen und so. Ja, das ist sozusagen der Grund, wo wir gerade noch so bei, was so seit der letzten Sendung passiert ist. Ich hab auch mal ein bisschen durch die Kommentare gegangen. Feedback zur letzten Sendung. Außer Denis sind alle zu naiv im Umgang mit Apple. Mussten wir uns vorwerfen lassen. Denis. Wie siehst du das denn? Sind wir zu naiv?
Ein bisschen.
Ich auch?
Bisschen weniger.
Und Max?
Max ist ja unser Android-Fanboy. Der ist eigentlich noch schlimmer als ich. Also besser, so.
Also mit anderen Worten, ich bin zu naiv und der Rest ist eigentlich ganz okay.
So ein bisschen kritischer bei manchen Sachen könnte man schon sein. Was war jetzt letztens wieder für ein Fall? Damn, mein Gehirn.
Mit dem Location Gate.
Nee, nee, danach noch so eine Geschichte. Was war es? Fuck, wo irgendwie der Gruber was geschrieben hat und dieser Mark Armend auch noch. Da gab es doch gerade wieder eine Geschichte. Noch nach dem Location Gate. Die sagen ja, das ist jetzt wieder wo. Die sehen das nicht naiv, sondern die sagen, alles was Apple macht ist irgendwie heilig. Und wenn die meinen, mit den Festplatten, das ist schon so okay und das geht nicht anders und da hat sowieso kein User dran zu fummeln und dann kann man nur alles so machen. Keine Ahnung, ich würde mich schon ganz schön ärgern, wenn ich jetzt nicht aufgepasst hätte. Irgendwann ist mir meine 500 Gig oder 1 Terabyte-Platte in ein, zwei Jahren irgendwie zu klein und dann will ich eine andere einbauen und dann geht das irgendwie alles nicht.
Das ist nicht so, dass es nicht geht.
Doch, du musst aber eine von Apple holen.
Nein, nein, du musst es den Service machen lassen. Ja. Aber es ist jetzt auch schon so.
Du brauchst eine Apple-Firmware halt auf der Platte. Die benutzen ja eine andere Firmware, eine Custom. Das heißt, du kannst nicht in den Laden gehen und dir eine Platte kaufen und...
Ja, aber du kannst in den Service gehen und sagen, bauen wir mal eine größere Platte ein.
Siehst du, das meine ich.
Aber wer will das schon? Wer will seinen fucking Rechner da irgendwo in irgendeinem Kack-Store zum Festplattentausch fahren? Niemand.
Und dann kostet die Platte bei Apple...
Warum sollte ich das jetzt nicht wollen würden? Also ehrlich gesagt will ich das nicht selber machen.
Mit einem Fahrrad oder Uber...
Du nicht vielleicht, aber andere vielleicht.
Ja, aber warum kaufen die sich dann einen iMac?
Wieso nicht, wenn der cool ist?
Ja, aber es ist ein voll integriertes System, deswegen...
Ist aber nicht technisch unmöglich, den so zu bauen, dass man die Festplatte einfach bauen kann.
Nein, es ist auch nicht technisch unmöglich, den so zu bauen, dass du all möglichen Scheiß da austauschen kannst, aber das ist das Ding wahrscheinlich doppelt so groß und doppelt so teuer.
Das glaub ich nicht.
Das glaub ich schon.
Wenn Steve sagt, das muss so, dann ist das doch so.
Ja, aber das ist mir einfach zu billig. Weißt du, immer so mit diesem... Und heute sagen, konnte ich noch jedes Bauteil in meinem PC austauschen. Und weil das jetzt... Weil es jetzt hier eine Designentscheidung gab...
Jedes Bauteil ist mir egal, aber solange es da bewegte Teile in der... Also so Festplatten gibt, die halt nun echt nicht irgendwie langlebig sind, im Vergleich zu so einem Computer.
Mir ist noch nie eine Festplatte gestorben, aber vielleicht bin ich da auch die Ausnahme.
Definitiv.
Also im iMac ist mir jetzt auch noch keine gestorben, aber ich hab jetzt auch noch nicht so lange das Teil.
Aber der iMac ist...
Die sterben bestimmt auch.
Natürlich sterben Festplatten, genauso wie der Rest von der Kiste auch irgendwann mal stirbt. Ich finde gerade beim iMac, das ist ein Gerät, was muss man da mit irgendwelchen Plöppeln an Monitor ran und überhaupt an die Festplatte ranzukommen? Ich würde nicht mal auf die Idee kommen, da irgendwas selber auswechseln zu wollen. Wenn ich ein Gerät haben möchte, wo ich fünf Festplatten reinpacken kann und alle Festplatten selber austauschen und Prozessor nachrüsten und weiß der Teufel was, dann hol ich mir einen Mac Pro. Und dann hab ich eine geil upgradbare Kiste, an der ich selber rumschrauben kann.
Also ihr meint, das ist alles gar nicht so schlimm, weil niemand baut an seinem iMac rum?
Nein, geht ja jetzt mittlerweile auch sowieso nicht mehr.
Ich sag nur, man soll sich einfach darüber im Klaren sein, was man da kauft. Ich meine, das ist doch die alte Regel. Wenn du selber deine Festplatte upgraden willst und der Computer kann das nicht, don't buy it.
Ja, steht ja jetzt nicht so vorne rein drauf.
Ist ja nicht so...
Ja, ich glaube, 98% der Kunden sind nicht die Bohne interessiert.
Das steht da drauf.
Das steht da drauf, du kannst den Rammen tauschen. Das steht da drauf.
Okay, aber dann gebe ich meinen Rechner zu Fuchs und sag dem, er soll mir eine neue Platte einkaufen und dann sagt der Fuchs auch, ja könnte ich schon machen, aber dann muss ich so eine ganz teure Platte bei Apple einkaufen. So und mal ehrlich, dass ihre Temperaturdaten über den Stromstecker da, über irgendwas, weiß ich nicht, für ein Voodoo-Zeugs irgendwie rüber schicken, ist bestimmt komplizierter gewesen, als wenn sie ein neues SATA-Command eingeführt hätten, wo sie die Platte mal fragen, wie warm sie denn gerade ist. Können wir nicht erzählen, das ist nicht leichter gewesen. Das heißt, meiner Meinung nach ist es absicht, dass sie es so machen, dass es genau nicht mehr geht.
Aber diese Verschwörungstheorien, daran glaube ich einfach nicht. Weil, wenn sie das verhindern wollen, dann machen sie da einfach eine Blombe drauf, fertig.
Wenn sie es verhindern wollen, dann würden sie es per Krypto machen.
Ja, oder was auch immer, da gibt es ganz andere Methoden.
Aber es wäre doch einfach gewesen, einfach ein weiteres SATA-Command zu machen.
Weißt du das, ob das einfach gewesen wäre? Dafür haben wir einfach zu wenig Informationen.
Strukturen und Commandzusenden ist schon da. Das heißt, sie brauchen nicht den Stromstecker an irgendwelche Pins, irgendwelche Voodoo-Daten anzulegen. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine größere Änderung.
Ich bin zu naiv.
Wenn das mal überhaupt so stimmt, vielleicht haben die sie auch vertanet. Das passiert schon längst über SATA-Commands.
Sie haben es so nicht gefunden.
Dass man jetzt die Temperatur der Festplatte, dass die Festplatte das noch nicht mitteilen können soll, das wundert mich jetzt auch ein bisschen, ehrlich gesagt.
Eine Festplatte ist einfach so was wie ein Akku.
Inzwischen wie ein Akku?
Ja, das ist auch so was wie ein Akku. Das ist sogar ein Akku.
Das ist ein Datenakku.
Findest du es auch okay, wenn bei den Druckern irgendwie so Tintenpatronen drin sind, die so digitale Signatur haben, dass man nicht von einem anderen Hersteller oder irgendwas ran machen kann? Ich finde das voll gut, weil wenn man eine andere Tinte reinmacht, dann weiß man nicht, ob die Nadeln verstopfen und alles. Also ich meine, das ist doch voll gerechtfertigt. Weil Tint ist echt was anderes als so eine Festplatte.
Also finde ich, es ist jetzt eine andere Diskussion mit dir. Findest du? Ja, finde ich.
Wieso?
Also ich kann abschließend sagen, ich hätte gerne einen Mac, wo man die Platte einfach tauschen könnte. Gibt es nicht, kaufe ich nicht. Peng.
Da ist es super einfach.
Will ich aber nicht.
Naja, das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Ja, gibt's halt jetzt zwei Desktop-Computer, die ich nicht will.
Mac mini auch nicht.
Du bist ja laut den Kommentaren sowieso die Stimme der Jugend.
Aber stell voll, ich meine... Was ist, wenn du die nächsten MacBook Pros dann irgendwie, wenn du die Platte auch nicht mehr tauschen kannst, um dir schnell mal deine eigene SSD einzubauen, sondern du musst dann auch immer die SSD von Apple nehmen, weil... Wird so kommen denn eines Tages?
Nee, das glaub ich nicht, dass das so kommen wird bald.
Warum nicht?
Doch, natürlich wird das so kommen.
Weil der Mac Pro genau das Gerät für User-Service-Apart ist...
MacBook Pro mein ich.
Dass da die Platte nicht mehr zu tauschen ist. Das wird nächstes Jahr so sein, ja.
Und, ist der dann auch egal?
Das ist jetzt bei mir schon jetzt so. Ist mir so egal.
Bis es dann kaputt geht und du dann zwei Wochen dein Ding beim Geschäfts-Service hast.
Ja, wenn da was kaputt ist an der Elektronik, dann ist da halt was kaputt an der Elektronik. Dafür hat man Garantie. So, dann kauft man Apple Care dazu und dann...
Hast du zwei Wochen keinen Rechner.
Ja, der Trend geht eh zum Backup-Computer. Na ist ja so. Ich hab einen Ersatzlaptop. Ich meine, wenn das wichtig ist für dich, dass du immer einen Computer hast, ja, dann hilft dir auch die tollste Schrauber-PC-Bastellösung nicht. Wenn das kaputt ist, ist es kaputt. Und wenn du keinen Ersatz hast, hast du keinen Ersatz.
Ich verstehe total das Consumer-Geräte. Also ich verstehe die Philosophie, aber ich so als Nerd, also mich spricht das halt weniger an einfach. Und es gibt Nerds und Nerds wollen ein bisschen basteln und Apple sagt halt Scheiß auf die Nerven.
Ja, dann müssen sie halt einen anderen Computer kaufen. Das ist halt nicht die Computer zum Basteln. Aber ich finde einfach diesen Vorwurf der Naivität an der Stelle, finde ich irgendwie so ein bisschen einfach.
Aber jetzt mal ein blöder Gefrag.
Ich reg mich da jetzt nicht gar nicht groß drüber auf, man. Das kann man jetzt gerne so sehen, dass ich jetzt naiv bin oder so. Aber ich finde, das ist keine schlüssige Argumentation.
Aber jetzt mal, Apple kauft von allen möglichen Herstellern Festplatten ein. Das heißt, jeder von diesen Herstellern kennt die Spezifikation, die Apple da drin hat. Wenn Apple die sich jetzt nicht patentieren lassen, dann haben die das jetzt in ihrer Firmware drin. Dann können die die Firmware auch auf andere Festplatten packen.
Nee, können sie nicht, weil Apple hat gesagt, laut Vertrag dürfte er die nur an uns verkaufen.
Zack, fertig.
Ja, da werden die ja schon ihre entsprechenden Agreements stellen.
War da irgendjemand in Reverse Engineering? Oder weißt du der Teufel was?
Oh ja, geil, eine Platte mit Reverse Engineering.
Hast du schon mal eine Platte mit einer Open Source Firmware gesehen? Oder mit einer veränderten Firmware?
Nein, ich meine, ich verstehe gar nicht, wie so überhaupt Rechner mit Festplatten kaufen. Aber das ist so...
Weil SSD ist nichts anderes als Festplatte. Lass es uns Festspeichermodul nennen.
Doch, SSD ist schon was anderes. Und SSD braucht keine Temperatursensoren. Doch, weil die nicht warm wird.
Klar wird die warm.
Überall, wo Strom durchgeht, wird sie warm.
Ja, weil es wird natürlich alles immer mal warm.
Die wird auch warm. Und der Kontrol auf so einer SSD hat echt zu tun.
Also warm wird das alles.
Ja, es wird vielleicht ein bisschen warm, aber nicht so schlimm wie bei so einer scheiß Festplatte.
Das würde ich nicht so pauschal sagen. Da gehen noch ganz andere Daten raten durch.
Am wärmsten sind immer die Chips.
Und selbst Speicher muss heutzutage gekühlt werden.
Auch bei einer Festplatte sind die Chips das Warme.
Pro Fläche, aber der Motor erzeugt doch mit Abstand die meiste Wärme, oder? Der verbraucht doch den meisten Strom, würde ich mal sagen. Weil er so oft wieder hochdreht und runterdreht.
Der braucht am meisten Strom und erzeugt am meisten Wärme, glaube ich.
Na doch, wenn jemand Strom verbraucht, dann muss der Motor am meisten Strom verbraucht.
Vielleicht sollten wir dann einfach das nächste Thema anfangen, wenn wir gar nichts darüber wissen.
Ich gehe ja nur aufs Feedback ein. Aber eigentlich wollte ich über die Stimme der Jugend reden.
Aber Huckel würde auch gerne ein bisschen mehr basteln können bei den Apples.
Was heißt das eigentlich, dass du die Stimme der Jugend bist? Bist du eigentlich der Jüngste?
Ich sag bestimmt irgendwie, ja oder? 28?
Bist du halt schon endlich, darfst du schon Führerschein machen jetzt?
Hab auch schon ein Seeferdchen gemacht.
Wegen Huckel dürfen wir aber keinen Alkohol trinken.
Scheiß Jugendkult.
Und ich muss hier immer, wenn ich mal in den Porn gucke, diesen Sichtschutz haben.
So, was hatten wir noch? Ach ja, da gab es ganz viele Nachfragen. Zu deinem Bluetooth-Dongle, den du da verwendet hast.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings. Viele denken, ich bin Dr. Sommerbär Twitter, aber Jungs, wenn ich mal keinen Bock habe zu antworten, weil es mir zu viele ist, dann antworte ich mal nicht. Oder wenn ich mal weg bin, wie letzte Woche, war ich nämlich wieder mal mit dem Radfahren. Also, noch mal zu dem Bluetooth-Dongle. Viele denken, dass das, was ich da erzählt habe...
Jetzt erzähl erst mal, was du erzählt hast.
Was habe ich erzählt?
Na ja, du hast doch da mit deinem Arduino-Board und deinem Mac...
Nein, das waren schon selbstgebasselte Boards. Aber ich hab halt so eine Atmel-Chips verbaut. Atmel-Chips haben eine serielle. Das sind einfach RX und TX-Pin, also Receive und Transmit. Und das ist halt eine serielle. Kann man einstellen, sagen wir mal 9600 baut. So ganz klassisch. So, diese serielle ist aber nicht das, was man als DB9-Serielle am Computer kennt, weil die DB9-Serielle am Computer, also das gleiche so wie dieser Joystick-Anschluss bei Matari früher, diese Form DB9 halt, funktioniert halt mit Plus und Minus 12 Volt. Was dieser Atmel hat, ist aber nicht Plus und Minus 12 Volt, sondern das sind halt einfach nur TTL-Signale, die immer 5 Volt haben oder 0. Das heißt, es ist nicht kompatibel, da müssen Adapter dazwischen ein. Ein berühmter davon ist so ein Max-232-Chip. Das heißt, dieser USB-Bluetooth-Adapter, den ich da hab, Dongel passt bei mir immer nur, wenn ich an Kopierschutz denke, ich sag immer nicht Dongel. So ein Schnupsi halt.
Was heißt das überhaupt richtig?
Keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls dieses Ding, was ich hab, dieser USB-Bluetooth-Adapter, also bei Sparkfun gibt's den unter Bluetooth-Made-Gold heißt er so, weil der kommt weiter, gibt's noch nen Silber, der ist ein bisschen billiger, kommt nicht so weit.
Kannst du dann auch mal die ganzen Links hier in den Dokumenten?
Haben wir doch letztens gemacht. Ich poste den gleich nochmal.
Du sollst den nicht posten, du sollst dir diese Scheißdokumente reinschreiben. Nein, danach. Nicht, dass du das wieder vergisst.
Jedenfalls, den, den ich hab, der wandelt nur zwischen den 5 Volt-Signalen von so einem Admin und halt zwischen dem Bluetooth-Adapter. Das heißt, der ist nicht für diese normale Serielle von so einem Computer gedacht. Zum Beispiel, sagen wir mal, das sind so Admins, die noch an so eine, obwohl Cisco hat doch eh jetzt Ethernet-Ports, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche anderen Geräte.
Cisco hat jetzt auch Ethernet-Ports.
Aber irgendwelche Geräte, die noch so eine DB9-Serielle haben, da geht dieser Bluetooth-Adapter nicht ran. Aber dafür gibt es natürlich auch Geräte, die haben wir letztens nicht verlinkt, weil ich hab ja von diesem 5V-Teil da gesprochen für Admins. Für diese normalen Seriellen gibt es auch Adapter, gibt sogar welche mit so Batterien drin, dass du den wirklich so ransteckst und der dann per Bluetooth irgendwie die Serielle zu deinem Rechner übermittelt. Und da weiß ich aber auch nicht was, also da hab ich halt keinen von, da gibt es aber so mehrere verschiedene. Manche beziehen sich den Strom irgendwie von der Seriellen, weil da kommt ja schließlich auch irgendwie ist da auch ein 5- oder 12-Volt-Anschluss an dieser Seriellen mit dran, weiß nicht so genau. Manche gibt es halt mit Batterie. Und Leute, die sowas machen wollen, müssen sich halt so ein Ding suchen. Da haben auch Leute im Chat schon irgendwie gesucht und auch teilweise was gefunden, welche davon aber wirklich cool sind, kann ich nicht sagen. Aber ich bin mit meinem Bluetooth-Teil für diese 5-Volt-Seriell von so einem Admin oder was auch immer man da hat, einen Arm oder keine Ahnung, bin ich voll irgendwie zufrieden. Das funktioniert voll super.
Wir haben eine ganz schöne hohe Pace irgendwie im Sprachfluss, ne?
Ja, weil hier der Adrenalinausschuss schon wieder ganz schön erhöht ist.
Wir reden schnell.
Naja, und viel. Und laut.
Ja, wir können ja auch mal wieder ein bisschen entspannter reden. Aber das ist das auf jeden Fall. Wer macht dir das Slow-Pace-Karten? So was ich noch zur letzten Sendung kurz mal einbringen will. Da haben auch ganz viele Leute gefragt zu meiner SSD. Also Leute, die kein neues MacBook Pro haben, sondern was älteres und sich eine SSD kaufen wollen. Die haben ja wahrscheinlich nur SATA 2. Und da nimmt man natürlich nicht diese Intel 510er-Reihe, weil die SATA 3 braucht, damit sie überhaupt zur Geldung kommt. Sondern dann nimmt man die neue 320er-Reihe oder halt irgendwie dieses, wie heißen die, Vertex 2, die älteren halt. Das reicht locker, weil die sind wahrscheinlich auch im Preis gefallen. Also nur Leute, die gerade so ein aktuelles MacBook Pro haben oder eine SATA 3 Schnittstelle, bei was auch immer demnächst rauskommt, sollten sich die allerneuesten und teuersten und schnellsten SSDs kaufen. Für die anderen lohnt es sich einfach gar nicht mehr. Das ist so raus, Timme.
Um da irgendwie SSD-Power zu bekommen.
Wollen Sie uns das nicht ins Service geben?
Nee, und jetzt muss ich mal ganz lobend den Timo von Bits und so erwähnen, der sozusagen das selbe Problem hat. Der hat halt auch so einen alten iMac, wobei eine Generation später aber auch noch mit ohne SSD, wie auch immer auf jeden Fall, auf die allereinfachste Methode gekommen ist, die es gibt. Es gibt ja auch noch Firewire 800. Genau, und der hat da einen super Tipp. Also ich hab dann parallel recherchiert, kam letztendlich zu den selben Ergebnissen wie er, nämlich genau hier auch diese 320er, die halt schon diesen, ich weiß nicht, ich kenne es noch andere, die dieses Feature haben mit dem Krypto, das alles verschlüsselt ist und dass man, wenn man die Daten löschen will, nur noch diesen Key vergessen lässt.
Das weiß ich nicht, ob die anderen neun das auch haben, aber ich glaube schon. Da muss man so ein Clicky-Rate machen und dann wird einfach der Key gelöscht, genau.
Aber welche Software muss man denn dafür nehmen, damit das Feature auch zuverlässig aktiviert wird? Okay, das wäre nochmal ganz interessant, das zu recherchieren, das weiß ich nicht. Wie auch immer. Dieser Firewall-800-Port, der so in einem iMac vor sich hingammelt. Gut, manche Leute schließen da vielleicht auch ein.
Aber ich muss noch kurz eingehen, das kannst du selber raushinden. Du machst auf dem Mac irgendwie so eine Art, also du lest die ersten 100 Megabyte mit DD ein, also so Low Level ohne File System. Dann machst du einen Quick Erase und liest die gleichen 100 MB nochmal ein. Und wenn die dann komplett völlig anders sind, und zwar innerhalb von ein paar Sekunden, wo du dieses Quick Erase gemacht hast, wenn die dann komplett anders sind, dann hat sich der Key geändert.
Woher weiß ich, dass er die selben Sektoren ausliest? Bei SSDs wird doch permanent alles umgemappt und...
Durchgewurstelt und...
Das ist doch alles vollkommen unklar.
Stimmt, der könnte auch seine Table da irgendwie...
Da kann sein, dass er immer was anderes...
Na ja, das stimmt allerdings.
Also, das ist mir noch ein bisschen unklar. Ich meine, es ist schön, dass dieses Feature da ist. Die Frage ist, ist das so sehr standardisiert, dass man das aktivieren kann auch über Firewire? Geht ja eigentlich gar nicht. Na ja, wenn ich jetzt diese Platte löschen will und die hat dieses Feature, vergesst ein Key, dann muss es ja auch irgendein Kommando geben, dass ich dieser Platte schicke... Ja, aber das ist ein SATA-Kommando.
Also auf Windows gibt es auf jeden Fall dieses Intel SSD Tool.
Über Firewire?
Du meinst, da geht es halt gar nicht.
Ich meine nur, ich weiß es nicht. Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie das gehen soll, direkt mit der Firewire, mit der Firmware zu reden und SATA-Kommandos zu geben, obwohl ich gar nicht mit SATA verbunden bin. Da müsste es ja schon irgendwas geben, was ich über Firewire rüberschicke, was dann lokal in einen SATA-Kommandos umgesetzt wird. Oder es müsste irgendwie 5 DIP-Schalter an der Platte, setzt sie unter Strom und dann...
Aber du steckst ja das Firewire nicht direkt an die Platte, sondern du hast ja natürlich noch einen SATA-Controller dazwischen.
Ja, aber du kannst über das Firewire, werden ja SCSI-Commands gesendet, wenn ich mich nicht recht erinnere. Und da drin kannst du ja wieder keinen SATA-Command reinpacken. Das heißt, das SCSI wird dann von dem Controller nach SATA gewandelt.
Also das ist für mich so das Grundrätsel ist, wenn ich jetzt eine SSD in der Enclosure habe und ich will die über USB oder über Firewire. Kann ja sein, dass da irgendeinen FU gibt mit USB, mit irgendwelchen Special-Commands, die man das Problem bestellen kann.
Aber dich betrifft das ja gar nicht, weil du ja eh nur Apple-SSDs hast, oder?
Wie Apple-SSDs?
Genau! Nein, du willst sie jetzt ja extern anwenden.
Ja, vielleicht sollte ich erstmal nochmal die eigentliche Lösung, die Timo vorgeschlagen hat, die total naheliegend ist. Ist einfach SSD-Kurven in so einem Firewire 800-Gehäuse. Da gibt es genau ein interessantes, ordentliches, wohl auf dem Markt derzeit. Und damit holst du zwar nicht die maximale Performance, die möglich wäre, raus, weil es einfach schneller ist als Firewire 800. Aber es ist ja vor allem so, dass du eben von der niedrigen Latenz und dem Random-Access profitierst.
Und von der Silence.
Von der Silence, aber auch so der Firewire 800, hundertprozentige Geschwindigkeit. Das ist ja jetzt auch nicht langsam. Das ist ja immer noch viel schneller als das, was du aus einer Festplatte rausschmeißt.
Hier hast du noch vor ein paar Monaten gesagt, der Denis meinte, ach nee, hier SSD und nee, brauche ich nicht. Ich bin erstmal ohne und so und jetzt ist er hier, sitzt da wie Bolle und sagt irgendwie 100 Megabyte.
So ist das.
Guck mal, ordentlich lange Anlauf genommen und dann richtig abgezogen. Okay, 100 MB kriegst du über Firewire 800 durch?
Ich glaube nicht.
Glaube ich auch nicht, weil das ist eher so das theoretische Maximum.
Ja, das ist jetzt das, ja gut, aber das theoretische Maximum ist bei Firewire durchaus auch das Denkbare. Ich meine, da hab ich jetzt noch keinen...
Aber hast du wirklich den praktischen Wert? Hast du noch nicht?
Ich hab noch keine Benchmarks gesehen.
Der Timo ist nicht hier bei uns im Chat. Würd mich echt mal interessieren, was da so theoretisch rübergehen würde mit so einer schnellen SSD, weil man sieht ja immer nicht so viel.
Theoretisch ist es so theoretisch, wenn wir mal bei theoretisch bleiben. Theoretisch ist Firewire ganz schön gut angebunden, weil es ja DMA macht über diesen Bus.
Ja, fairlicherweise.
Natürlich wirst du irgendwelche Latenzen durch die, gut die Platte selber nicht. Ist die Frage, wie gut der Firewire SATA-Controller performt, wie effizient er die Geschwindigkeit umsetzt. Ist die Frage, wie viel im Treiber verloren geht, etc. So, hier meint einer in RealTit, habe er noch nicht mehr als 75 MB pro Sekunde gesehen. Na gut, auch 75 MB pro Sekunde ist schnell. Und wir wissen alle, es ist vor allem der Search und der Random Access, der halt bremst. Und da hast du einfach bei SSD den Vorteil. Also ich hab mir jetzt so ein Ding bestellt, ich bin gespannt, ich werde dann berichten können. Aber ich brauche einfach hier ein bisschen SSD-Gefühl.
Okay, aber was du noch nicht gesagt hast, ich glaube, wir haben mal wieder böse irgendwie in deine Sätze gegrätscht. Du wolltest sagen, was jetzt der Timo gemacht hat, damit ihr Quick Erase hinbekommt.
Nein, nein, der Timo hat jetzt überhaupt erst mal diese Nale, ich hab gegrübelt, was, kaufe ich mir einen neuen iMac? Das war die eigentliche Frage, um SSD-Power zu haben. Das war mir dann aber einfach zu teuer. Also verkaufe ich meinen alten und kaufe ich mir einen neuen. Das ist sozusagen die eigentliche Frage. Mache ich einfach ein Upgrade auf das aktuelle Modell, aber dann ist ja wieder das Thunderbolt, alles anders und so, bin ich noch nicht für reif. Weil dann kann ich den wieder nicht als externen Bildschirm benutzen, bevor nicht alles andere als Thunderbolt ist, etc., Und bin einfach auf die naheliegendste Lösung, billig, so einem Gerät mal Beine zu machen, einfach nicht gekommen.
Also du willst einfach sozusagen deine SSD per Firewire anschließen und tschackach. Was hat das alles mit dem Quick Erase zu tun?
Gar nichts. Es hat insofern was damit zu tun, als dass ich mir natürlich darüber Gedanken gemacht habe, welche SSD kaufe ich? Weil wenn ich nur Firewire 800 Performance eh rüber kriege, dann hätte er auch noch so eine alte Krusche SSD, dann muss es nicht die Intel sein.
Aber überleg dran, die sollte nicht zu alt sein, die sollte schon ordentliche Garbage Collection können.
Genau, das war dann sozusagen genau jetzt meine Frage. Was ist denn für mich, quasi jetzt eigentlich so, wann ist denn eine SSD für mich modern genug? Und so eine SATA 3 SSD brauche ich halt nicht, weil es gibt eh kein Fire, also Firewire 800 gibt es nicht her, es gibt auch kein Gehäuse, was drei macht, also das ist einfach alles Quatsch. Das heißt, ich brauche jetzt nicht das aktuelle rechts unten Modell, sondern so eine Mittelklasse reicht. Und dann wollte ich halt wissen, okay, wie mittelslassig muss ich denn jetzt sein? Und dann fiel mir eben dieses Feature ein mit, hier gibt es theoretisch die Möglichkeit, dass die Platte den Key wegschmeißt. Und das war für mich dann so ein Ding, wo ich mir gedacht hab, ja genau, das ist jetzt so der Level, auf dem ich jetzt einsteige. Eine Platte, die das kann. Die nächste Frage ist natürlich, wie kann ich denn von diesem Feature auch profitieren? Was ist, wenn ich jetzt diese Platte verkaufen will, weil es mittlerweile 256, 512 Terabyte SSDs gibt und ich will das Ding irgendwie loswerden, dann will ich es halt auch zuverlässig löschen und einfach Nullen draufschreiben, wissen wir ja, ist bei SSD irgendwie ein trügerischer Sport.
Du machst einmal alles voll mit dem gleichen Movie, ne, nicht mit unterschiedlichen Movies und dann ist gut. Einmal alle deine Podcasts drauf als Geschenk kannst du noch in Euro extra nehmen.
Ja, aber ich fände so einen Killswitch auch geil. Also einfach so grundsätzlich als Feature einer Festplatte, dass man einfach sagt, du bist jetzt tot. Das ist geil, aber dann bräuchte man wahrscheinlich irgendein Tool. Und dann ist halt die Frage, kann man so ein Tool überhaupt schreiben, wenn das Ding über Fireware angeschlossen ist? Oder muss ich das innen, muss ich mir noch einen PC kaufen, um das irgendwie intern einzubauen?
Bei diesen USB-Sata-Adaptoren kann man damit smart und so...
Auch schon nicht. Geht ja smart schon nicht, wenn du die per USB anschließt.
Ja, dann können wir das Thema ja erstmal abschließen.
Habt ihr in meiner Abwesenheit denn auch hier das erwähnen, mit diesem DMA und dass das sowieso alles ganz bäh ist?
Welches DMA?
Na hier mit diesen Rechnerohren über alle Möglichkeiten.
Ist doch schon seit 10 Jahren bekannt oder seit wann? Oder wie lange? Dass Firewire halt direkt DMA-Zugriff aufs Rem gibt und dass es da schon...
Aber Thunderbolt ist dann nochmal ein schöner Unterschied, weil wenn du jetzt irgendwo hingehst, zum Beispiel gehst du auf eine Konferenz, hängst dich da ein Beamer dran, das ist ein Thunderbolt-Beamer, und schließt das dann an. Und dann weißt du nicht, kann theoretisch auch sein, dass da noch eine Instanz dazwischen geschaltet ist, die dir die Daten abzieht und auf deinen Rechner zugreift. Und normalerweise schließt man ja nicht einfach irgendwelche wildfremden Firewire-Geräte an.
Also es ist ein absolut berechtigtes Ding. Ich hab da mal ein informelles Gespräch geführt mit jemandem, der da Einblick hat. Haben wir noch nicht ausreichend erklärt, worum es geht?
Also Firewire und per Thunderbolt kann man per DMA direkt aufs RAM zugreifen, ohne Umweg übers OS oder wie auch immer.
Also jedes Thunderbolt-Gerät, was man an seinen Rechner anschließt, hat vollen Zugriff auf den Arbeitsspeicher. Das heißt, alle Sicherheitsmechanismen, die irgendwie drin stecken, das Gerät kommt dran vorbei. Und das ist bei USB zum Beispiel nicht so.
Bei Firewire aber schon.
Bei Firewire ist es aber schon und bei Thunderbolt.
Bei Thunderbolt ist es nochmal ein Level weiter, weil es halt ohne Umwege direkt auf den PCI-Bus geht. Da gibt es noch nicht mal mehr diese Firewire-to-PCI-Bridge.
Wo man es dann auch abschalten kann oder irgendwie so. Da gab es irgendwas, ne?
Aber bei diesem E-Sata wäre das zum Beispiel auch so. Also bei den PC-Linen gibt es ja hier diese E-Sata. Das hat wohl auch das Problem, boi.
Es ist ein generelles Problem. Also ich hab da mal nachgehakt in üblicherweise gut informierten Kreisen. Und mir wurde bedeutet, dass das Problem bekannt sei.
Ja, wäre auch besser, aber kann man halt nicht.
Und, dass es ein, dass die Auffassung existiert, dass es dafür eine sehr einfache Lösung gibt, die allerdings wohl zum Zeitpunkt dieses Gesprächs noch nicht real existierte. Ich muss mich da sehr zurückhaltend ausdrücken. Und keine Ahnung, was das Ergebnis davon sein wird. Aber ich hab das Gefühl, dass dieses Problem bekannt ist. Schauen wir mal, ob es zur Kenntnis genommen wird. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man das verhindern kann.
Das betrifft halt auch nicht nur Max. Das muss man noch dazu sagen. Das ist halt auch ein grundsätzliches Problem.
Das heißt, wenn man aber nach Sun... ach nee. Da muss halt irgendein DVI-Steckeradapter dazwischen schließen, oder? Dann geht's nicht mehr? Dass die nicht direkt an den Port kommen, sondern nur noch so ein DVI-Port kriegen. Gibt's da bestimmt Adapter, oder? Klar gibt's die Adapter. Du sagst, du hast keinen Zanderbeut, du hast nur einen DVI. Du machst immer den Stecker dazwischen, zack.
Dann rennst du mit einem Adapter rum. Man rennt eh mit einem Adapter rum.
Was ist dir wichtiger, deine Daten oder mit dem Adapter rumschleppen? Für Leute, denen ihre Daten wichtig sind, die müssen halt nur den Adapter rumschleppen.
Es ist einfach ein sehr konvient Einfallstor, um deine Daten abzugreifen. Also stell dir vor, du bist auch ein...
Schon klar, aber wie gesagt, der kleine Trick dagegen wäre so ein DVI-Adapter. Und Leute, denen ihre Daten wichtig sind, die werden den dann halt mitschleppen. Oder nicht zu der Konferenz gehen oder kein Apple kaufen.
Ja, aber viele Leute werden das auch schließlich mehr greifen, nicht wissen.
Ja, jetzt wissen wir es.
Also das könnte man mal schon...
Wie gesagt, Rechner mit ESAs, also ganzen PC-Büchsen, die haben das halt auch.
Ja, aber da gehst du nicht auf einer Konferenz und steckst irgendwie den ESA davon irgendwie rein, wo du nicht weißt, wo das Kabel und Pult irgendwie verschwindet. So, jetzt weiter. Genug Paranoia heute.
Wollen wir über Android reden, über dieses lustige Daten-Lag? Ist doch eigentlich dazu gerade passiert.
Hast du das schon in dieses Dokument eingetragen?
Nee, ich hab das noch nicht in die Formanlage.
Ihr wolltet ja immer Zugriff haben. Ich hab hier einen Aufnahmeantrag reingeschrieben. Du bist da eingeladen.
Ja, ich weiß, ich hab die auch bekommen. Ich hab die auch ignoriert.
Wo wir noch gerade über Festplatten und Daten reden. Heute wurde mir klar, warum mein Ableton Live bei längeren Sendungen auf einmal aufhörte, einen Track aufzunehmen. Das hat mich vollkommen wahnsinnig gemacht. Hier hatte ich das Problem weniger, weil wir hier nicht noch eine zusätzliche Audio-Spur mitrekorden. Aber bei Not Safe For Work hab ich ja immer so diesen ganzen Fu, der so aus dem Internet kommt. Und pünktlich nach drei Stunden hörte er einfach auf mit diesem Track. Alle anderen liefen weiter.
Ihr machte mittlerweile drei Stunden Sendung?
Hm, die letzte hatte vier. Na nichts gegen Mobamex, ne?
Die Marathon-Podcaste nur für die harten.
Das hier ist der längste.
Wenn du es dir mal richtig besorgen.
Wir machen die längsten. Wir haben die längsten. Naja, und der Grund ist natürlich der, dass es sich dabei, im Gegensatz zu den anderen Spuren, um eine Stereospur handelte, die doppelt so viel Daten weggenommen hat. Und natürlich war es die 2 GB AIFF-Grenze.
Ganz schön lame, weil AIFF habe ich ja auf einem Amiga schon Tools geschrieben, um so einen Scheiß zu parsen. Und das waren halt immer 4-Bytes Zeiger. Also 32-Int. Und wenn man scheinbar noch signiert, dann kommst du auf 2 GB. Und dann geht es einfach nicht länger, weil die Längenangabe steht bei AIFF oder bei IFF hieß es ja damals, steht ja immer vorne mit dran.
Ja, so.
Es muss aber eine Spezifikation geben für längere Dateien, denn man kann mit Meco S10 sowas erzeugen. Ja, habe ich nochmal ausprobiert. Ich habe diese lange Sendung als mp3 in den QuickTime Player 7 geladen, die also vier Stunden lang ist, und dann per Export nach IFF nach IFF stereo exportiert.
Und hast du mal reingeguckt in den Header? Das ist bestimmt voll spannend.
Ich bin jetzt nicht in der Lage, mit einem Texteditor IFF Header zu lesen.
Wie so Texteditor Hexdumpf? Das ist ganz einfach. IFF ist ein ganz einfaches Format. Da kommt immer vier Bytes Länge, dann kommt ein bisschen Description und dann kommt wieder der nächste Brobble, also die sind sehr ineinander verschachtelt. Am Anfang ist alles ganz easy. Also ich hab auf dem Amiga mal so ein IFF-Parse Tool in Assembler geschrieben. Das wollt ihr doch nicht jetzt machen, oder? Müsst ihr schon ein bisschen mit dem Hex-Taschenrechner ran, weil ihr müsst ja dann von Pointer zu Pointer springen. Ja, dann machen wir, aber wenn das mehrere Sprünge sind, hast du ein bisschen einzutippen immer. Aber es geht auf jeden Fall, man kann da schon mal reingucken, dann sieht man wahrscheinlich auch gleich, ob die vier oder acht Bytes lang ist. Also du brauchst nebenan schon noch ein bisschen den ASCII-Part.
Hier ist dein Hex-Taschenrechner.
Du brauchst noch den ASCII-Part, da sind auch immer so vier Byte, wie sagt man, also da steht, das erste vier Bytes werden halt A, E, F, F für unterstehen, als Erkennung. Minus groß C, hab ich doch gesagt.
Für was? Für OD oder für?
Minus, also Hexdump, Minus groß C.
Hexdump, ist das cool?
Minus groß C und dann die Datei, die du willst und dahinter noch Pipe More, damit er nicht gleich durchscrollt. Pipe, dein Editor halt.
Ah, ich hab, Entschuldigung, ich hab hier gerade mich auf den falschen Dingsbombs.
Genau, da siehst du, mit Form geht's immer los. Dann kommt die Länge, die siehst du da oben, dieses Punkt L Punkt Punkt, das sind 4 Bytes weiter und dann sagt er, dass es ein AIFF ist. Also das erste ist auf jeden Fall immer wieder nur 4 Bytes. Dann siehst du da schon Channel und Sound, was auch immer da heißt, und dann kannst du gucken, wie lang die Zeiger sind. Also den ersten, dieses A24CFD82, also dieses Punkt L Punkt Punkt, kannst du ja schon mal mit dem Taschenrechner hier, kannst du schon mal gucken, was es sagt, wie lang es wäre.
A24CFD82, das soll die Länge sein?
Die Länge von der Form erst mal, ja. Wahrscheinlich haben die das einfach bei der Größe als 2 GB Datei einfach kommt dann wahrscheinlich ein neuer Header oder so und die machen dann einfach weiter und von vorne.
Okay, das ist jetzt nicht, glaube ich, nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt, das zu analysieren.
Denke ich auch, aber es ist auf jeden Fall, ist gar nicht so schwer.
Wir lesen also den Tatsache ist, der QuickTime Player 7 ist in der Lage, IFF-Dateien zu erzeugen, die größer als 2 GB sind. Es gibt irgendeine Spezifikation. Die Jungs von Ableton meinen, das sei irgendwie aber alles total unklar definiert und es gäbe da nichts ordentliches und ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht, was jetzt eigentlich da wirklich der Stand der Dinge ist. Andererseits ist das natürlich eine Limitierung, die geht gar nicht. Also das verstehe ich nicht. Ich fühle mich jetzt mal wieder ermutigt, es doch nochmal mit Logic auszuprobieren. Vielleicht, wenn Apple im Betriebssystem in der Lage ist, so große Dateien zu schreiben, vielleicht ist auch ihr rechts unten ein Audioprogramm in der Lage das zu tun. Keine Ahnung, falls irgendjemand im Chat ist, der mit Logic Erfahrungen hat und mir sagen kann, ob das Ding in der Lage ist, mehr als 3 Stunden Stereo aufzunehmen am Stück.
Aber kann man nicht sagen...
Sie können ja zumindest mal eine neue Datei aufmachen oder sowas, aber sie hören einfach auf.
Schreib den mal in Buckleport.
Aber gibt es kein anderes Format? Gibt es da kein anderes?
Waffe ist bestimmt auch nicht besser.
Kannst du nicht in Apple Lossless aufnehmen? Oder so einen anderen Professional Codec? Du kannst mir doch nicht erzählen, dass jetzt alle irgendwie noch mit IVE aufnehmen. Oder Waffe?
Nein, die Recording-Software, die encoded nicht groß, die schreibt einfach raw weg. Das muss ja auch schnell passbar sein.
Ja, und da gibt es kein Format für...
Also nicht in Ableton Live. Da kannst du zwischen AIFF und Waffe wählen, was grob viel gesprungen ist. Letztendlich ist das selbe. Das eine hat Intel Byte Order, das andere hat Apple Byte Order.
Auch auf dem Intel Max. Und so.
Ja, Waffe ist AIFF in Microsoft herum. Das ist ja... Wie heißt das denn? RIF. Es gibt AIFF und es gibt RIF. RIF ist so die Basis von den ganzen Microsoft-Varianten, aber es basiert halt alles auf diesem Amiga-IFF. Das ist überhaupt interessant.
Ich glaub, das ist von Electronic Arts damals.
Ja genau, dieses Image-Fallformat von diesem, wie hieß der jetzt, Programm?
Deluxe Paint meinste?
Ja, ich glaub Deluxe Paint.
Nee, das gab's glaub ich auch schon noch.
Nee, nee, das war das glaub ich. Das ist eigentlich eine ganz interessante Geschichte, dass dieses eine Amiga-Programm quasi die Mutter aller Tagged-Fallformate ist.
Könnte sein, ja.
Bis hin zu MPEG-4, MP4-Container. Basiert letzten Endes... Ja, das basiert alles auf der ursprünglichen Texte.
Vielleicht ist mein Amiga-Tool dieses If-Pass mal wieder ausgeraubt. Das ist eigentlich ganz geil. Das hat ja so gleich baumäßig die ganzen Strukturen angezeigt. Immer mit Einrücken und so. Ob der mit zwei Gigabyte weiter jetzt klarkommt.
Aber jetzt wo es Linux im Browser gibt, also da gibt's bestimmt auch Amiga im Browser. Und wenn du dann acht Gigabyte RAM im Rechner hast, da geht auch einiges.
Es gibt Linux im Browser?
Nicht gesehen?
Nicht gesehen, der hat einen Emulator geschrieben.
Nee, Tim kann's natürlich nicht sehen, weil es läuft ja nur in Firefox. Ach, es läuft in einer alten Chrome-Version, irgendwie in Chrome 11 oder sowas.
Naja.
Naja. Also das ist auf jeden Fall sehr beunruhigend. Dann hab ich aber noch was sehr Beruhigendes festgestellt. Ein Tool, was ich hier schonmal erwähnt habe, Sapler. Das hab ich schonmal erwähnt und zwar aufgrund seiner Fähigkeiten, dass man damit so Tracks aus MKVs rausholen kann und in MP4 Container machen kann, ohne dass er dann halt die Tracks selber neu encoded oder schreibt, sondern dass quasi nur aus dem einen Container rausholst und in den neuen Container reinmacht. Und das ist ja so ein super einfaches Standard-MECO S10-Tool, auch noch Open Source. Einfach document oriented, kein Foo, kein Quatsch dazu, sondern einfach nur die reine Funktionalität. Und dann hab ich das Ding eine Weile nicht mehr so richtig benutzt und beachtet, außer dass da immer mal wieder so kleinere Updates kamen, die ich mir aber nicht groß angeschaut hab.
Also ich hab's auch mal probiert und es hat irgendwie so ein bisschen irgendwie Macken und hab's dann erstmal aber gelassen.
Ja, mag auch sein, also für diesen MKV-Zug so MP4-Ding, das hängt dann auch immer viel von diesen Tracks ab. Aber was ich festgestellt habe, jetzt unabhängig von diesem MKV-Kram, einfach als MP4-Container-Editor hat es ein echt cooles Feature. Es kann nämlich mittlerweile auch Kapitelmarken universeln. Das heißt, der Chapter-Track hat ein Editor da drin und du kannst einfach jedes beliebige MP4 in Sapler öffnen, ihm einen Chapter-Track hinzufügen und dann einfach links die Zeit und rechts die Kapiteltitel und sagst einfach save und er save dir in place in dieselbe MP4-Datei ohne großes Aufregen.
Ohne wie empfohlen, sondern einfach nur den neuen Track mit den Subtitles.
Genau, das heißt, du kannst jede MP4-Datei nehmen, jede und der Kapitelmarken hinzufügen interaktiv. Du kannst es auch nicht interaktiv machen. Du kannst einfach auch das Fallformat, was zum Beispiel dieses MP4-Chaps aus dem MP4-V2-Paket verwendet, nehmen. Das ist einfach ein Textformat, links Timecode, rechts Kapitel, ist auch nichts großes, aber immerhin alles UTF-8, alles mit Umlauten und so weiter. Und ja, es ist einfach eine schöne Ergänzung. Also ich bin gerade dabei, dieses ganze Thema, Tagging, Kapitel etc., nochmal neu zu evaluieren und versuche ja da so mal eine Toolchain zu machen, damit das mit dem Kapitel machen einfacher wird.
Und das haben wir dann demnächst auch. Und dann gibt es wieder Kapitelmarken, so wie schon mal.
Das ist meine Hoffnung. Ich will aber jetzt eine solche noch nicht verbreiten.
Wir brauchen ja schon irgendwann noch so ein Tontechniker, der so parallel sitzt und alles macht, oder?
Ja, wir brauchen auch sowas.
Gibt es einen Typ, der gesagt hat, er würde so umsonst Praktikant machen, aber er könnte nur freitags. Kann man das nicht in den O-Sourcen an die Hörer oder sowas?
Nein. Crowdsourcen? Nein, nein, nein, das ist, bitte fang ich gar nicht erst damit an. Das macht noch viel mehr Arbeit, jetzt eine Crowd dahin zu führen, eine Crowdsourcen dahin zu führen, bis sie das tut, was du willst. Das geht halt nur, wenn die Prozesse wirklich sehr einfach abbildbar sind. Aber das ist mir dann doch ein bisschen zu komplex. Also, darüber rede ich auch gar nicht. Das Ding ist einfach nur Sublar. Man kann einfach sehr einfach damit Kapitelmarken machen und das geht eben nachträglich und interaktiv vor allem, weil sowas gab es bisher halt nicht. Was es nicht kann, ist, muss gleich hinzuzufügen, es kann nicht diese Bilder trecks, weil man kann ja, also so ein iPhone und ein iPod kann ja auch Bilder anzeigen. Dazu braucht man glaube ich noch so eine JPEG-Spur und es kann auch keine Links, zumindest wüsste ich nie wie. Also vielleicht kann man da auch einfach ein Ding eintragen und wenn es aussieht wie ein Link, ist es einer, aber ich glaube nicht. Also das weiß ich halt nicht genau. Tatsache ist, die reine Zeiteinteilung, Kapitel und Titel des Kapitels ist easy peasy gemacht. Saplar, tolles Tool.
Richtig geil, um mal mit der Stimme der Jugend zu sprechen. Wobei hier, wie heißen sie nochmal? Ike und Er sind ja glaube ich auch schon eher Alternmusik, oder?
Tim hat es ja mal angeschleppt, das heißt ja schon einiges.
Eigentlich sind die schon tot.
Die Jugend von heute hört Rebecca Bleck.
Wie heißt denn deine Kids jetzt?
Geht eigentlich hier noch dieser Knopf mit dem Heil? Nee.
Der? Ich glaube die...
Ja, geht wieder, okay. Jetzt kann ich noch mal ein paar Minuten warten, bis ich den pointiert einsetzen kann.
Okay.
Das wird ein Spaß. Da freuen wir uns schon jetzt drauf.
Seid ihr schon ganz nervös?
So, jetzt machen wir weiter. Wir haben hier noch was abzuarbeiten.
Heise berichtete, es gibt da eine Apple-Sonderausstellung in Oldenburg.
In diesem Computermuseum, weil es ja morgen irgendwie zehn Jahre Apple Store ist oder warum auch immer die das machen.
Nee, es ist 35 Jahre Apple sowieso schon.
Auch noch, Mann.
Ja, wollen wir dann mal so eine Klassenfahrt hinmachen nach Oldenburg?
Wo ist denn überhaupt ein Laden?
Keine Ahnung.
Der Chat berichtet gerade Logic Pro kann auch nur 2 GB. Meine Güte.
Wo ist denn hier die Sitzung?
Wie säle ich sich das überhaupt vor? Wie soll man denn da Podcasts aufnehmen?
Gab es nicht diese Deutschlandkarte für Berliner? Deutschlandkarte für Berliner, da steht es bestimmt drauf.
Außerhalb von Brandenburg sogar.
Also in diesem Computermuseum, Ausstellung 76 bis 2011.
Was haben sie denn da? Apple 1-Clown?
Wir haben ja nicht mal ein Quadra 840 AV.
Ja, aber sie haben ein Apple Macintosh Portable. Da war ich etwas enttäuscht, weil ich hab nämlich auch noch einen und...
Und einen Apple...
Ich hab einen Apple Portable, ja.
Gab es noch diesen Apple Plus 030, oder wie der hieß?
Was war die Frage, Max?
Kriegst du den noch an? Läuft der noch?
Nee, leider nicht. Das Netzteil ist irgendwie...
Verstorben.
Nee, das ist gar nicht das Netzteil.
Oder irgendwas im Strom.
Der braucht nämlich Drehstrom. Wenn der Akku nicht geht, dann geht das ganze Ding nicht mehr. Also kannst du das nicht ohne Akku betreiben, ohne Funktion zu züchtigen. Das hab ich irgendwann mal gelernt. Und die Akkus stammen natürlich bei den Teilen als erstes.
Musst du die mal von Fidel ein paar Drähte löten lassen?
Genau.
Oder war das gar nicht so?
Aber was davon haben die denn da noch in Betrieb? Also so eine Apple-Liser-Werbung würde ich mich schon mal ganz gerne angucken.
Ansonsten? Ja, ansonsten ist ja eher dünner, ne? Gibt's den Anniversary-Mac?
Den hatten wir bei Pixel Park, zwei Stück davon.
Pixel Park hat auch 14 Millionen Mark für eine Internetpräsenz genommen. Da konnte man sich auch mal eine Anniversary-Mac shoppen.
Hackintosh hat die im Chat, liefert noch mehr interessante Informationen zum Thema Logic. Genau. Ach ja, genau. Da hab ich auch gleich noch einen Nachtrag. Lassen Sie uns noch mal kurz bei diesem Medienformat-Thema bleiben. Also, bei Logic 9 kann man einfach CAF auswählen, das Core Audio Fallformat. Das gibt es nämlich auch noch. Echo S10 hat ja ein internal Audio Fallformat und da gibt es da nicht diese Limitierung.
Aber das Core Audio Format ist mir ja ganz neu.
Ja, war mir vor kurzem auch neu, gibt es aber.
Können aber auch nur 13 Stunden.
Ja, warum es nur 13 Stunden sind, ist mir ein…
Also ehrlich gesagt versteht man das nicht. Man nimmt irgendwie stundenlang Audio auf. Das heißt, man geht davon aus, dass Leute, die so viel aufnehmen, dass ist alles irgendwie Gigabyte-weise groß und dann haben sie keinen Platz für ordentlich 64 Bitpointer. Was ist denn das?
Das ist völlig absurd. Aber dieses Ableton Live, das ist auch so ein bisschen… Das ist Cross-Plattform-Software. Ja, die haben keinen Mut, da irgendwas zu unterstützen, was sie nicht hinterwinden.
Na ja, aber warte, Apple Core Audio Format, denen könnte das ja mal egal sein mit Cross-Plattform.
Egal, mit 13 Stunden, 30 Minuten, das wäre für mich ja schon mal ein echter Schritt. Das wäre schon mal locker eine Ver-Vier-Fahrung.
Ja, aber das heißt, dass da schon immer noch irgendwie die Voodoo machen, um das irgendwie… Also, weißt schon, das ist jetzt nicht… Keine 64-Bit-Pointer.
Oh, 24-Stunden-Podcast? Die 24-Stunden-Podcast von Le Mans?
Irgendwann gibt's den Live-Podcast, da nimmst du einfach dein ganzes Leben, wie Microsoft schon mal vorhergesagt hat, irgendwann komplett alles auf, weil…
24 Stunden am Tag, Mobile Max.
Was mir dabei einfällt mit diesem Kaff, ist nämlich, ich hab neulich auch, wie schon erwähnt, ich evaluiere gerade so dieses ganze Feld, Encoding, Automatisierung und so weiter. Und unter anderem hab ich dann auch ein paar Klang-Tests gemacht, wo viele Leute immer beschweren, über die großen MP3-Dateien, und ich würde ja sowieso gerne mal AAC machen. Und wenn man aber AAC macht, dann kann man auch gleich B sagen und dieses High Efficiency AAC nehmen, mit dem du halt noch mal so richtig mega extra kleine Dateien bei guter Soundqualität hinbekommst. Und dann hab ich halt mal so geguckt, was kann denn überhaupt HI AAC erzeugen? Das geht mit iTunes. Also wenn man so diesen AAC-Encoder auswählt, dann kann man da noch mal anklicken, nimm aber High Efficiency und so weiter. Also damit kannst du es halt auch mal. Aber das Problem mit iTunes ist, das ist halt nicht die Bohne automatisierbar. Bleib mir vom Hals in diesem Automator.
Aber als du als Apple Fanboy, du müsstest doch jetzt sagen, irgendwie hat das schon alles seine Richtigkeit und das macht halt Sinn.
Wer will denn da schon fummeln?
Genau, Apple Script ist halt das Tool, was Apple da so ausgesucht hat.
Apple Script, das ist ein stinkendes Stück Scheiße.
Gib doch deine Dateien in den Service.
Apple Script ist ja mal eine schöne Idee gewesen von Apple, die aber leider, seit wieviel Jahren gibt es das schon, seit wieviel Jahren kommt das nicht aus dem Knick?
Das kam zu System 7.1 oder irgendwie sowas.
Also ich hatte es mir beim ersten Action dabei.
Das ist sowas von vergeigt und Scheiße. Also allein schon diese Design-Entscheidung, dass man sogar die Syntax lokalisieren kann. Davon haben die ja echt geträumt. So Apple Script in Deutsch und so ein Scheiß. Das haben sie nie wirklich implementiert.
Auf Spanisch gab es das.
Ja, aber das ist einfach viel zu soft. Okay, ich will jetzt gar nicht so sehr über Apple Script reden, das funktioniert mit iTunes ist nichts, womit man irgendetwas automatisieren kann. Das geht nicht. Dann habe ich mich ein bisschen herumgefragt und sehe da, es gibt auf der Kommandozeile von Mac OS X ein Tool, das heißt AF-Convert.
Commandline Tool der Woche.
Ein Commandline Tool der Woche, womit du einfach mal AAC erzeugen kannst. Der Legende nach gab es wohl in früheren OS-Versionen, sei das Teil tatsächlich in der Lage gewesen, auch MP3 zu machen. Das kann aber auch nur ein Gerücht und ein Oversight von demjenigen, der mir das erzählt hat, gewesen sein. Denn ich glaube das nicht so recht wegen dieser ganzen Lizenzproblematik und deswegen haben sie diesen MP3-Encoder nur so in iTunes und nicht im OS. Wenn dieses AF-Convert das gekonnt hätte und das benutzt ja an der Stelle nur das Core-Audio-Framework, dann hätten wir diese Funktionalität auch in anderen Programmen, wie zum Beispiel QuickTime Player auch gesehen. Haben wir aber nicht. Aber mit diesem AF-Convert kannst du einfach mal cool AAC erzeugen. Das heißt, während es ja genug Command Line Tools gibt, um MP3 zu machen, kann man auch dieses Problem AAC bzw. HE AAC machen, auf eine Mac zumindest mit AF-Convert lösen. Mit diesen ganzen anderen Tools, die es so gibt, kommt so ein bisschen alles zueinander, könnte sich noch mal interessant entwickeln.
Das singt voll langsam. Ich hab da nämlich gerade noch was reingeschrieben. Und das synchronisiert alle 10 Minuten oder was?
Ja, diese ganzen Simple Note Clients sind alle scheiße. Vor allem dieses Just Notes, was ich hier benutze, das scrollt dann immer wieder an den Anfang, wenn er irgendwie gesungen hat. Und dann sind ja manchmal auch Dateien doppelt und so.
Weil ich hab nämlich auch so ein kleines Tool für zwischendurch zum Einstreuen, was ich seit Kurzem benutze. Das ist wirklich sehr klein. Flux nennt es sich. Steht da jetzt auch. Nachdem es synchronisiert hat und Flux macht, das findet raus, wo deine Location halt ist so und dimmt dein Display nach Sonnenuntergang in so einem wärmeren, rötlicheren Ton. Mit der Ansage, dass es halt irgendwie angenehmer für die Augen ist oder weniger, die Augen ermüdet. Das haben im Club schon ein paar Leute so benutzt. Ich fand das immer so beim Nebendrangucken irgendwie ganz schön krass, weil es macht halt wirklich so von der Seite, guckst auch extrem rot teilweise, je nach deinen Präferenzen, die du erwählst. Und dann habe ich es aber doch nochmal ausprobiert, weil ich abends halt schon immer dieses Problem hab, dass dann irgendwie so die Augen so... Und ich muss sagen, es ist doch tatsächlich ganz angenehm. Also ich hab's auf der leichtesten Einstellung, dass das so runterdimmt ins Wärmere. Und das benutze ich jetzt tatsächlich.
Das machen wir jetzt abhängig von der Zeit, oder wie?
Genau, der guckt halt wo du bist und je nach Sonnenuntergang, wenn das Tageslicht halt weg ist, dann dimmt das so rötlich.
Und macht das so ein bisschen...
Also wie gesagt, ich war da auch erstmal ein bisschen skeptisch, aber hab's jetzt doch dauerhaft im Einsatz und freue mich eigentlich auch jedes Mal, wenn dann so diese Zeit gekommen ist und das Display dann so langsam und smooth runterdimmt und ich weiß, ja, jetzt sind die Abendstunden angebrochen. Und in der neuesten Version kann man das auch noch konfigurieren, wie es sich verhalten soll, aber es funktioniert out of the box eigentlich auch schon. Ja, das war mein, wie man so schön sagt, Pick.
Was hab ich jetzt? Ich hab jetzt hier dieses, das hat Grube auch noch nicht empfohlen, ein Kalender Fantastic, so ein Kalender für die Menüleiste.
Du klickst auch alles, was der Gruber verlinkt, wa?
Genau, ich bin so ein Gruber-Fanboy.
Gruber hat was Neues gepostet, du gleich mitglicken kannst.
Ihr Gruber-Boys.
Nee, ich mache auch Sachen, die der nicht...
Du klickst auch Sachen, die der nicht linkt.
Genau, du machst auch Sachen, die Marco Armen linkt.
Also ich glaube aber, die sind bezahlt von Apple.
Auch ja.
Okay, diese Fantastical, das lebt aber nur im Menübar, deswegen habe ich das jetzt gar nicht benutzt. Ich dachte, das wäre so ein richtiger iCal-Client, aber das ist ja gar nicht.
Ich finde es wäre ganz praktisch, dass das nur in einem Menübar ist. Also mir wären das da auch zu viele Sachen mittlerweile an der Menüleiste, aber ich finde das...
Da muss auch mal was her, ne? Also wenn ich jetzt nicht so ein 1920er-Display hätte, das würde dann irgendwann hier doch wieder die Einträge und so...
Ich brauche langsam auch eine zweite Menübarleiste.
Du machst einen Bulleste auf deinem kleinsten Computer.
Vielleicht ist das mal ein guter Hälterzweck für Screensharing, wenn man so für diese ganzen Menübar-Items...
Nee, du nimmst dann dein iPad für die...
Beim iMac hilft es nicht, dass der Bild schon größer ist, weil ich da mehr CPU-Cores anzeigen muss.
Ja, aber du kannst jetzt dein iPad oder iPhone daneben legen und dann die ganzen Menü-Icons...
Stimmt, mit Air Display und dann so... Ja, Fantastical ist ganz großartig. Zeigt so einen schönen kleinen Kalender an. Man kann oben durch eintippen von dem Termin und dann leider bisher nur auf Englisch formatiert sagen Tomorrow 13.00 und dann macht er auch den Termineintrag schön und...
Du schreibst nicht wirklich deine Daten in Englisch?
Ich schreibe dann Friday 13.00.
Weißt du, warum ich so eine Angst habe, wenn solche Kall-Programme kommen aus Amerika? Das Erste ist, du machst diese Dinger auf und dann sagen sie dir, dass die aktuelle Uhrzeit so etwas ist wie 3.32 Uhr nach dem Punkt.
Ja, macht er nicht.
Macht er nicht?
Gut.
Irgendwie muss man diesen Amerikanern mal erklären, wie man die Uhr schreibt und wie man das mit den Abständen macht.
Ja, und mit den Gewichten auch und so. Schon klar. Ja. Und man kann das auch oben dann mit 13 Uhr, man muss da nicht 3 PM, was ich vor euch auch ein bisschen Schiss hatte, eingeben. Und das fliegt alles so, also man fängt an zu tippen und ich kann ja hier mal die nächste Mobile-Max-Sendung quasi eintragen und die wäre dann wahrscheinlich in zwei Wochen.
Und wir gucken jetzt alle.
Erster, Sechster. Und dann, Mist, funktioniert natürlich prompt. Erster, Sechster. Und dann fliegt das hier immer so schön rum. Upsa. Man sieht hier, was er daraus interpretiert hat. Also man ist da jetzt auch nicht komplett blöd, dass er jetzt 1978 den Termin einträgt.
Man sieht hier, du kannst dir das nicht erklären in einem Audio-Podcast. Du musst das in Blumenlandschaften jetzt machen mit deiner Stimme.
Ach die Blumenlandschaften mit meiner Stimme. Was hast du schön gesagt?...
mach ein Instagram und shares mit all deinen Freunden.
So, wartest du gerade das Thema?
Also man sieht, man hat so eine Liste mit den Werten, die da stehen können. Uhrzeit, Datum, Enduhrzeit, Location, Gäste. Und dann werden die vorausgefüllt, sodass man dann auch weiß, wenn man Return drückt, ja stimmt wirklich alles. Jaja, du magst es nicht, schon klar.
Das Ding ist, keiner versteht das.
Voll schlimm, mein Motorrad hat es auch, geht mir voll auf den Sack.
Das ist auch so unlogisch, dieses AM, PM. Habt ihr euch schon mal so vergegenwärtigt, wie man da zählt mit AM und PM?
Ja, die 12 gehörte mich noch zu AM mittags. Das heißt, der Tag ist eigentlich die Hälfte schon rum, weil es ja um Punkt 12 beginnt ja die zweite Hälfte, aber 12.59 Uhr ist glaube ich noch AM, oder?
Nee, das ist PM.
Sicher? Das ist nämlich genau das Bekloppte. Das ist so doppelt bekloppt. Niemand weiß, was 12 PM ist.
Doch, es gibt Leute, die wissen das.
Ja, Amerikaner. Außerhalb, also der Rest der Welt, diese Welt, kann damit nicht umgehen.
Vielleicht machen es ja manche auch falsch, weil die wissen es nämlich auch nicht. Deswegen lernen das manche Leute nämlich falsch. Wer weiß, wie mein Motorrad das macht. Das kommt stets aus Japan. Das ist eh verstrahlt.
Das ist völlig absurd. Vor allem, wie du zählst, morgens ist dann so 1 AM. So 1 Uhr Nacht 1 AM. Das kriegt man irgendwie noch hin. So 2 AM, 3 AM und so weiter. Und dann kommt 12. Also es zählt von 11 auf 12 hoch, aber ist dann schon PM. Also von 11 auf 12 ändert sich sozusagen das, was dahinter ist. Von AM auf PM. Und dann kommt die 1. Dann bleibt das PM. Aber es ist halt 1. Also es zählt von 12 auf 1 runter.
Von 11 auf 12 kommt die AM-PM-Änderung und von 12 auf 1 kommt die Zahlen. Genau.
Wollen wir jetzt mal festhalten, Tim kann die Zeit nicht. Und hat so trotzdem probiert, einen Podcast zu erklären.
Kein Europäer hat das wirklich verstanden, wie das eigentlich wirklich funktioniert.
Aber seit der Wende haben wir ganz andere Probleme.
Wollen wir mal wieder über Max reden?
Da müssen wir so Sachen wie Viertel-Sieben verstehen.
Klickt mal den Link da von dem E-Piraten. Übrigens, warum? Für den Screen solltest du Linkinos benutzen, weil Linkinos zeigt so eingebettete oder verlinkte Medien gleich inline an. Das ist total praktisch.
Was soll ich benutzen?
Na hier, mein Irrk-Klein Linkinos, der zeigt hier, wie heißt der? Linkinos. Der zeigt inline gleich die verlinkten Sachen an. Da braucht man gar nicht klicken.
Linkinos, es gibt einen neuen Irrk-Klein?
Nee, der ist nicht neu. Den gibt's schon eine Weile. Den haben wir auch, glaube ich, schon mal hier erwähnt.
Ich nutze den auch schon seit Ewigkeiten.
Ja, ja, ja. Das ist jetzt hier so eine Masche von euch. Wahrscheinlich letzte Woche rausgekommen oder so.
Ich war auch schon bei den Beta-Testern Ende letzten Jahres.
Das stellt jetzt übrigens auch Telefone her.
Linkinos, warte mal, den muss ich jetzt mal hinterherfegen.
Kostet aber Geld.
Ja? Geil. Endlich.
Ich weiß nicht, den gibt's auch im App Store sogar.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich liebe Software, für die man Geld bezahlen darf.
Du darfst sogar viel Geld für bezahlen. Nee, das ist nicht mehr Dollar. Siehst du, das ist nämlich Euro. Du bist nämlich selber einer von diesen anderen Kalern, die da nicht klarkommen.
Ja, also der ist schon, ich find den so als, ich hab schon viele Irk-Channels aufgenommen.
Im App Store kostet er übrigens nur 8 Euro.
Auf in den App Store, das gelobte Land, wo noch echte Schnöpfchen warten.
8 Euro?
Du sagst, der ist super?
Also ich... Ich hab seitdem nie wieder anderen benutzt.
Geschoppt.
Hättest du auch ruhig mal die Trial downloaden? Ich mein, der hat auch 4,5 Sterne, also 17 mal 5 Sterne und die restlichen sind im einstelligen Bereich.
Ich brauch einfach mehr Irk-Alternativen. Das ist schon mal gut, wenn da ein bisschen Innovation ist.
Den kann man auch konfigurieren, ganz nach seiner Fasson.
Das kann man mit diesen ganzen anderen Irrkleinen ja nie.
Die haben es halt vor allen Dingen geschafft, irgendwie das so in eine Cocoa-Gui zu gießen. Da bin ich schon sehr dankbar.
Wir haben heute viele Tipps übrigens. Das ist eine Sendung mit vielen Tipps. Wer sich schon immer darüber aufgeregt hat, dass wir die ganze Zeit nur über Web-M und H264 reden und streiten.
Über Nokia redest du ja nicht mehr, die gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Die sind völlig vom Radar runter schon. Ja, sind sie ja auch eigentlich. Gab es jetzt kein Announcement mehr, nichts, keine Funkstille.
Doch, doch, die haben jetzt Ovi gekillt und das Ome dann neu. Es ist jetzt Nokia Services.
Und QT5 gibt es irgendwann bald.
Ich sag nur eins. Es ist alles so gekommen, wie ich das schon immer gesagt habe.
Gut, und damit schließen wir dieses Video.
Wie lange gibt es Microsoft noch?
Noch eine Weile. So lange wie IBM.
Länger. Also IBM gibt es länger, meine ich.
Wollen wir über Microsoft reden?
Nee, gibt's, gibt's, gibt's.
Ich hab's eh auf der Liste.
Na dann später. Ist ja noch nicht so weit.
Als Rausschmeißer dann.
So, was ist denn an dem Cursor? Ich sehe da keinen Text.
Nein.
iPhone-Tausch und der Wert von Apple Care.
Ich hab ein neues iPhone.
Das war alles?
Hast du das iPhone 5?
Apple hat's mir getauscht.
Warum? Warum?
Weil es zerkratzt war.
Was hast du gemacht? Hast du wieder auf dem Spielplatz irgendwie...
Ich hab den Original Apple Bumper angebracht. Du weißt schon, dieser Plastering.
Hast du das schon mal tauschen lassen?
Also nicht mein iPhone 4.
Achso, du hast damals gesagt, das ist schon voll zerkratzt, weil du Sand aus dem Sandkasten deiner Kinder in zwischen deinem Bumper und deinem Telefon hattest. Aber damals bist du noch nicht zum Store gegangen. Und jetzt bist du mal hingegangen und jetzt haben sie es getauscht.
Genau.
Nicht schlecht, du Fuchs.
Ja, fand ich auch cool. Welcher Spielplatz war das? Was brauch ich vom Sand? Es war schon so ein bisschen gezählt, da war schon da, aber hat stattgefunden. Und war dann halt auch mal wieder, wie eigentlich immer, wieder mal so eine solide Service-Aktion. Also meine Experience in den Apple-Stores ist ja nicht die schlechteste.
Mal ehrlich, Timme, du hast da bei dir bestimmt so einen Fleck irgendwie, der macht den Mega-Apple-Fanboy-Podcast so. Wenn wir den jetzt verärgern, dann lässert er wieder zwei Stunden lang in seiner Sendung ab. Unsere Mitarbeiter hören diese Sendung, sind danach eine Woche schlecht drauf und unsere Produkte leiden. Und dann haben die dir einfach schnell Neues gegeben.
Ich kann das nicht ausschließen, aber ich kann das auch nicht bestätigen. Ich weiß es nicht, ob das so ist.
Die haben da so interne Datenmarken, auch wenn sie nicht dürfen.
Ich hab bloß einfach nur wieder gemerkt, was es irgendwie sinnvoll ist, entweder noch Garantie zu haben bzw. diese verlängerte Garantie.
Ich hab schon mal sehr, sehr positive Erfahrungen.
Das bezicht sich ja auch auf mein 3GS. Das ist ja auch niegelnagelneu, weil da war ja auch alles durch. Das war ein anderthalb Jahr alt oder so, oder zwei schon fast. Zwei kann es ja noch gar nicht sein, ein anderthalb Jahr. Da hat sich der Akku aufgebläht.
Ah, okay.
Also das Ding war so richtig im Arsch.
Da sind sie immer ganz fix dabei. Das kennt der Huckel ja auch.
Ja, nee, zuletzt jetzt nicht mehr. Bei meinem einen MacBook Pro sind mir jetzt so viele Akkus schon aufgebläht und zuletzt hat sich das überhaupt nicht mehr interessiert.
War es Apple Care auf dem Teil, das hat dich nicht interessiert?
Also ist halt außerhalb der Garantie jetzt.
Darauf wollte ich eigentlich hinaus, dass es sich schon lohnt, so ein Safety-Netz zu haben.
Das hätte drei Jahre und deswegen...
Ja gut, nach drei Jahren ist dann irgendwie auch vorbei.
Ja, aber so aufgeblähte Akkus finde ich schon ein bisschen unsportlich.
Und sieht dein Phone jetzt so schick aus wie meins? Das sieht doch noch ganz gut aus, oder? Für ein Dreivierteljahr alt.
Ein Kollege von mir, der hat jetzt... .ging neulich durch das Gebäude, der raucht und stellte sich in die Raucherpause mit einem weißen iPhone. Und der hat mir dann die Geschichte erzählt, dass der hat damals, als das iPhone 4 kam, hat er ein weißes iPhone 4 bestellt bei der Telekom. Und dann haben sie irgendwann gesagt, ne, das können wir zurzeit nicht liefern. Und dann hat er, okay, können sie halt nicht liefern. Verzichte ich halt drauf, nehme ich halt keins. Und hat er das total vergessen und plötzlich, einen Tag nachdem es angekündigt war, hat er plötzlich so ein weißes iPhone im Briefkasten. Ja, ihre Lieferung ist da.
Obwohl er eigentlich gecancelt hatte.
Na, ich glaube, er hat es nie gecancelt. Er dachte, es wäre gecancelt, wenn ich halt sage, ja, da gibt es noch ein bisschen Lieferverzögerung, dann auf unbestimmte Zeit, dass es dann einem cancel gleich kommt.
Und da hat er in der Zwischenzeit sich auch nichts anderes besorgt und war dann noch happy, dass er ein Weißes bekommen hat.
Ja, ja, da war er auch happy drüber und sie sind sehr kulant gewesen, haben irgendwie ein halbes Jahr Grundgebühr erlassen bei der Telekom, weil er so ewig lange warten musste. Der meinte, er ist damit sehr zufrieden. Na, ich hätte ja auch schon gedacht, naja.
Hast du das auch gesehen, das weiße Ding? Sieht es nicht ganz komisch aus irgendwie?
Das sieht aus wie ein weißes iPhone. Also ich fand das eigentlich sehr schick. Weil es es nicht alles gibt. Die Leute!
Weiße iPads sah auch cool aus.
Schwarz ist das neue Weiß.
Ich hab mir natürlich auch gleich noch zwei neue Kopfhörer geholt, weil die waren nicht so schlecht. Diesmal wollten sie das sogar wissen. Ich sollte doch zumindest mal eins rübergeben und dann wollte man selber mal hören, ob es dann auch wirklich scheppert.
Und?
Na, schepperte. Ich weiß nicht, warum, wie, keine Ahnung.
Ich verstehe es nicht. Ich hab mir Kopfhörer gekauft. Ich hatte ja immer die Sony EX71. Das waren ja meine Stammkopfhörer. Die habe ich mir nur zweimal gekauft und die haben insgesamt bestimmt 10 Jahre gehalten.
Sony EX71?
Ich glaube, so hießen die. Die gibt es jetzt aber nicht mehr. Und dann habe ich geguckt, es waren noch nicht die besten, aber die haben einfach lange gehalten, haben ihren Dienst getan. Jetzt habe ich mir von Klipsch welche gekauft. Klipsch In-Ohr-Teile?
KLIPSCH Das die so mit angepassten In-Ohr?
Nee, die sind ohne. Ich sage gleich nochmal die Modellnummer, die habe ich jetzt aber gerade nicht im Kopf. Und das Schöne ist, warum ich mir die gekauft habe, erstens haben die ein paar Tests ganz gut vom Sound abgeschnitten. Zum anderen haben die eine Remote.
Also nicht remote, sondern ist schon mit am Kabel.
Und hat auch ein Mikro, funktioniert also auch als Headset.
Ok, also genauso wie die normalen iPhone-Kopfhörer auch, von der Funktionalität her.
Und das funktioniert eben auch am Mac, das fand ich auch ganz geil.
In ihr.
Da steht der Tim ja nicht drauf.
Aber ich bin mit denen echt ganz zufrieden. Die sind vom Sound, von der Abstimmung her, sind die ein bisschen heller als die EX71. Also ein bisschen weniger tiefenlastig. Aber der Sound ist echt brillant. Also ich hab da immer so ein paar Test-Tracks, die ich dann so anspiele bei neuen Kopfhörern. Und da hab ich erstmal abgeschnallt. Aber wie heißen die denn, die Klipsch? Die haben auch gar nicht so viele Kopfhörer. Von daher könnte man jetzt einfach auf die Webseite ganz schnell mal...
Was haben die Dinge denn gekostet?
Ja, ich glaube, das waren so 60, 70 Euro. Also jetzt auch nicht so super günstig, aber ich wollte halt welche, die gut klingen und halt irgendwie auch eine... Die haben auch so ein Kabel, so ähnlich wie die, die die Apple-Kopfhörer so verdrillungsfrei ist oder so gummiert halt irgendwie. Das ist im Prinzip wie bei den Apple-Dinger nur in Schwarz. Und die heißen Image S4, glaube ich. Genau, Image S4e in ihr Headphones. Genau, endlich mal wieder was für die affiliate Links. Oh, 99 Dollar. Aber beim amazon.de... Ich hab die günstiger bei Amazon geschoppt. Ach, das sind aber die Premiums.
Warte mal, ich guck hier nochmal neu. Also S4e soll nicht Premium sein, oder was?
Doch, guck mal da unten, die da, genau.
Ach, ein Weiß für 54.
60 Euro. Warte mal, da waren eben noch andere.
Aber das sind die, glaube ich...
Hier gibt es Zeichen für 44, 45.
Aber...
S4 und S4e. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen dem einen und dem anderen?
Na, die einen haben, glaube ich, keine Fernbedienung, oder?
Ach so, i ist die Fernbedienung?
Die wie iPhone.
Hier steht aber auch iPod.
Ja, aber steht nichts von Fernbedienung, oder?
Akustisches Erlebnis in Studioqualität.
Also diese Clipschleute haben auf jeden Fall einen ganz guten Ruf. Und wie gesagt, ich hab da so ein paar Tests gelesen und der schnitt da immer schon ganz gut ab.
Okay, wie lange hast du sie schon?
Eine ganze Weile. Also auf jeden Fall schon lange vor der letzten Mobile-Max-Sendung, wo ich dabei war, aber das war vor der Frühlingspause.
Also schon zwei, drei Monate. Weil die gehen ja immer erst nach drei Monaten hinüber.
Ich hab die seit Anfang des Jahres, ich glaub so Weihnachtszeit rum oder kurz danach hab ich mir die gekauft.
Hier steht tolles Reisezubehör im Lieferumfang enthalten.
Wahrscheinlich meinen sie hier dieses tolle... Also du kriegst halt diese Metallbox mit Schaum-Inlay zum Einpacken dazu.
Oh, sehr schick.
So, ich weiß nicht, ob das das Reisezubehör ist, aber...
Na, die gehen auf jeden Fall nicht kaputt, auch wenn sie mal ein bisschen gedrückt werden. Besser als irgendwie so eine Plaste-Dinger.
Irgendwie Schaum rausnehmen, Fisherman's Friend reintun, passt auch.
Ja, aber konnte ich jetzt mal, also nach monatelangem Testen durchaus eine Empfehlung aussprechen, wie gesagt...
Okay, also S4 ist sozusagen mit ohne Fernbedienung und die S4i ist mit Fernbedienung, verstehe. Und dann kosten die 60 Taren.
Also ich bin ja ein Gitarrenmusik-Hörer, und da gibt's ja dann auch so Schlagzeug. Und bei manchen Tracks konnte ich dann so die High-Hat, das Scheppern sozusagen, so jede einzelne Schallwelle gefühlt wahrnehmen. Das war ein Hochgenuss. Wie gesagt, ist halt ein bisschen heller abgestimmt. Also für Leute, die so richtig auf den Schlag, aufs Trommelfell stehen im Bassgebiet, ist das vielleicht nicht ganz das Richtige. Aber ansonsten ist ja wirklich sehr gut ausgewogen.
Okay, bestellen Sie jetzt. Die Leitungen sind geöffnet. Wir haben noch 28 Modelle davon.
Rufen Sie die Nummer neben Ihrer Landesflagge an.
Wenn Sie jetzt anrufen, kriegen Sie noch ein formschönes Stoffstöckchen gratis dazu. Die ersten 10 Kunden kriegen noch ein Keramikmesser, das durch Schuhe schneiden kann.
Magst du es nicht?
Bestell nicht. Eins ist für dich frei. Das Keramikmesser meine ich.
Keramikmesser kosten mehr als die Kopfhörer, glaube ich.
Wir albern rum. Das ist ja ganz gut, ne? Worüber wollen wir reden?
Playstation Network ist gehackt worden.
Das ist auch schon alt.
Das haben wir bei letztem Session schon nicht besprochen.
Aber sie hat es nochmal verkackt.
Ja, eben gerade wieder. Nein, sie ist jetzt gerade online gegangen.
Aber prompt wieder gehackt oder prompt wieder down? Es ist glaube ich so, du kannst deinen Account jetzt wieder reaktivieren mit Geburtsdatum und dein Passwort. Oder E-Mail-Adresse. Und das sind genau die Daten, die halt die Leute auch beim Hack abgefischt haben. Epischer Fehlschlag, TM.
Also Sony, ne?
Die sind draußen auch.
Die sind auch wirklich... Es geht auch irgendwie... Gibt es denn bitte noch irgendeine Firma, die es drauf hat? Wer soll denn Apple aufhalten?
Die haben noch keine Spielekontrolle.
Vorschläge irgendwie? Mir fällt echt nichts mehr ein.
Ja, die haben jetzt gerade schon wirklich derbe ge-owned. Also in jeglicher Hinsicht.
Google hat es schon voll drauf mit der Sicherheit.
Max, dein Einsatz!
Erzähl mal, ich habe das auch nur so am Rande mitbekommen.
Eigentlich ist es eine relativ harmlose Nummer. Die haben halt... Da kriegt man ja so einen Token, wenn man sich einloggt.
Wenn man sich wo wie wann verhörte.
Wenn du dich bei Google Mail oder Google Kalender einloggst, dann kriegst du einen Token zurück, pro Dienst ein, dass du sozusagen authentifiziert bist. Und irgendjemand bei Google kam jetzt auf die... Also darüber funktioniert offensichtlich auch das Kalendersyncing und das Mail-Syncing und das Adressbuch-Syncing und alle Sachen, die so bei Android gehen. Und irgendwann kam da auf die sauschlaue Idee, das nicht per HTTPS zu machen, sondern einfach nur per HTTP. Deswegen, wenn man jemanden in seinem WLAN drin hat, der ein Android-Handy hat, dann kann man mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit einfach mal so das Session übernehmen.
Also, wenn man in einem unencrypted WLAN ist.
Naja, oder es ist dein WLAN.
Ja, wenn das encrypted ist, dann kannst du auch nicht over-WLAN. Also, dein WLAN im Sinne von auch dein LAN, was dahinter ist.
Genau. Dann kann man diese Daten sozusagen abgreifen. Was ja nicht so schwer zu machen ist, das würde ja auch beim iPhone ganz hervorragend funktionieren. Soweit ich weiß, nenn das WLAN so wie eins, von dem du weißt, dass diese Person sich mit dem WLAN verbindet.
Telekom.
Nenn es haargenau so. Und dein Telefon wird sich damit verbinden, weil es sagt, das hat die selbe ID wie das, was ich kenne und dann surft es darüber. So, und dann hast du halt diesen Authentification-Token da drinnen. Und der funktioniert wohl im Fall von Picasso bis zu zwei Wochen, in den anderen nicht so lange, aber wahrscheinlich lange genug, um mal eben das komplette Adressbuch abzugreifen.
Aber das hat doch das Internet eh schon.
Naja, aber ist doch kein Problem. Da schieben die doch mal eben ein Software-Update auf alle Telefone raus und dann gibt es das Problem nicht mehr.
Ja, genau, es ist bereits gefixt. Nee, nee, 2.3.2, die ist auf vier Geräten weltweit installiert.
Meins ist gerade aus...
Vier einzelnen Geräten oder vier Typen von Geräten?
Nein, nein, das war jetzt einfach eine frei erfundene Zahl. Also ich glaube, es gibt außer dem Nexus S das offiziell noch kein Gerät. Also ich glaube nicht mal, dass Nexus One hat 232. Aber es kann auch sein, dass ich mich täusche, dass Nexus One mittlerweile 23 hat. Also es wird vermutlich...
Hier rächt sich sozusagen diese ganze Sache mit dieser Fragmentierung aufs Äußerste.
Na, das ist jetzt noch nicht so richtig das K.O.-Kriterium, aber weil da werden ja nur meine Daten irgendwie abgegriffen. Davon kriege ich am Anfang zwar nichts mit. Ich glaube, es hätte schlimmer bekommen können. Ich weiß jetzt nicht.
Und es kam schlimmer.
Also ich warte mal drauf, dass sie wirklich einen schönen Exploit haben.
Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, warum das jetzt unbedingt den Titel von Spiegel online ziehen musste.
Titel, echt? Ach so, weil es deutsche Hacker waren. Deutsche Experten haben das rausgefunden, deswegen.
Wahrscheinlich. Das war für einige Stunden auf spiegel.de so die Top-Meldung.
Wenn sie sich schon über Location geht, so lange aufregen, dann können sie doch auch ruhig mal hier für sowas...
Ja, ich hatte auch so den Eindruck, die fühlen sich jetzt so ein bisschen verpflichtet, da mal auch über was anderes zu...
Auch mal auf Google einzudreschen.
Auch mal auf Google mal wieder einzudreschen. Weil ist ja schön. Aber das eigentliche Problem, was dahinter steht, ist, dass Google nicht mal eben sicherstellen kann, dass jetzt alle Android-Handys safe sind, weil sie nicht in der Lage sind, Updates rauszuhauen.
Es gibt zwei Probleme dabei. Erstmal, warum wird sowas überhaupt unverschlüsselt gemacht? So Firecheap, spätestens Firecheap?
Na ja, Flag nicht gesetzt, nicht drum gekümmert, nicht wichtig genommen. Ja, also das... Ja, klar ist das doof. Es gibt viel zu viele Webseiten, die noch HTTP benutzen, wo es einfach nicht angemessen ist. Man sollte immer HTTPS verwenden.
Aber selbst Facebook kriegt das mittlerweile hin.
Ist aber auch nur optional.
Und Twitter auch.
Ist auch nur optional.
Ja, klar.
Die forcieren es nicht. Und das ist der eigentliche...
Und jetzt mit diesen Update-Techniken. Das ist natürlich auch ein großer Spaß. Ich glaube, das wird Google nochmal... Ich glaube, das war jetzt noch nicht das eigentliche Schlimme.
Schau dir mal vor, es hätte jetzt so ein richtiges Problem gegeben. So eine Sache mit... Du fängst, du hörst das mit auf WLAN, und dann bist du sofort auf dem Telefon und kannst da irgendwie alles rausholen.
Das wird kommen.
Ja, wird kommen. Das ist immer so, wie die Viren werden den Macintosh übernehmen. Aber es ist jetzt nicht da. Aber wenn es so wäre, was ja vorstellbar ist, nicht dass ich damit unbedingt rechne, aber es ist ja vorstellbar, dass so was entdeckt wird, und es wäre jetzt so super peinlich, dass sie einfach nackt im Internet stehen. Ja, sagen wir mal wirklich so was Dummes wie, du liest einen String mit, und mit diesem String kriegst du wirklich alles raus. Und kannst das Telefon danach auch noch töten. So was. Mit easy peasy automatisiertem Skript. Nur als wirre Idee, so auf dem Level. Sie sind nicht in der Lage, diese Telefone zu aktualisieren innerhalb irgendeiner Zeit.
Was ich glaube, womit sie es auf die Bildtitelseite schaffen werden, ist, wenn irgendwelche Premium-SMS darüber verschickt werden und irgendwelche weinenden Kinder da stehen, die eine 1000-Euro-Telefon-Rechnung deswegen haben. Das wird das Ding sein, wo es wirklich ganz weit nach voraus geschaffen werden. Auf seinem Android. Ich kaufe nicht dieses Telefon mit dem angeblichen Appel.
Wer von euch nicht weiß, was Goatsy ist, nicht googeln.
Man findet es nicht.
Nicht googeln.
Klar findet man das.
Man findet es. Ich hab es mal gesucht.
Das ist ja in der Wikipedia.
Ich hab mal nach Goatsy gegoogelt und ich hab mal nach Two Girls One Cup gegoogelt. Man findet alles Mögliche dazu. Man findet Videos von Leuten, die gerade Goatsy sich angucken. Man findet aber das eigentliche Bild. Findet man nicht.
Das ist in der Wikipedia verlinkt gewesen.
Ach, so was ist in der Wikipedia.
Man macht mal nachher auch eine Ferienlink und dann...
Dann können wir mal hier auf Google IO gehen.
Warte mal. Was denn? Hattet ihr eigentlich schon behandelt in meiner Abstinenzabwesenheit, dass Harald hier also auf Daring Fireball geschafft hat und so?
Das hab ich nicht so explizit erwähnt, aber ich hab ihm mal gesagt, aber wusste nicht, was es bedeutet.
Ja, ich war ja total irgendwie... Hat mich ja völlig unvorbereitet getroffen. Klick ich so Gruber-Feed an und dann Harald Welte says Doppelpunkt. Sein Blog muss ja da richtig ordentlich Traffic bekommen haben, der war ja auch auf Apple Insider verlinkt und so.
Ja, aber Harald meinte schon, sein Blog ist alles statischer Kontext, er hat gar nichts gemerkt.
Aber er meinte auch, er hätte jetzt, jetzt haben sie es ja released den Code, aber er meinte, das wäre wohl sehr viel Object-Code noch drin, also schon so zusammengemanntes, nicht wirklich lesbare Code.
Muss man vielleicht für unsere Zuhörer kurz erklären, was der Harald Welte so macht? Der macht nämlich die Seite gplverletzungen.de oder wie auch immer die genau heißt und kümmert sich drum, dass irgendwie, wenn irgendwelche Plastorouta schrauben, wo Linux Code drauf ist und sie den Source-Code nicht rausrücken, weil alles GPL ist, dann klagt er die mal kurz weg und kriegt irgendwelche Entschädigungen, dass sie das halt verfuscht haben. Und bei Apple hat er halt auch mal gemeint, die müssten eigentlich, da sie ja auch der Webcode unter der L-GPL steht, müssten sie auch den Code immer veröffentlichen. Und das kann halt schon mal eine Woche länger dauern, aber Apple war schon acht Wochen hinterher und deswegen hat er das mal zur Sprache gebracht.
Was dann eben verlinkt wurde und jetzt haben sie es halt released, aber wie gesagt, das ist halt irgendwie...
Harald Welte ist auch Dauergast bei Chaos Radio Express. Zu dem Thema Chaos Radio Express 17 zum Beispiel. Langes CA, 2006 schon. Und zahlreiche andere interessante CAEs. Harald hat halt Plan und irgendwie kam dieser Post dann zum Groover. Ja, interessant.
Und vermutet wird, dass Apple nicht releasen wollte, weil der Code von dem iPhone, von dem Webkit ist nicht released worden. Und da benutzen ja diese Nitro-Engine. Und da ist ja so ein kleiner Performance-Krieg mit Google-Engine irgendwie. Die haben ja auch einen eigenen JavaScript-Engine, dass sie deswegen irgendwie ein bisschen noch Zeitvorteil haben wollen. Das klingt zumindest leicht plausibel. Und wir stehen ja so ein bisschen auf die Verschwörung. Tim ja nicht so, aber mir macht es ja auch Spaß.
Hält mich jetzt nachts nie wach.
Nee, das auch nicht, aber es könnte sein, dass es damit zu tun hat, weil sonst, welche Gründe sollten wir sonst haben? Dass sie es auch verpeilt haben. Ich denke schon, dass sie da so einen automatisierten Prozess haben und ich denke nicht, dass sie es bei einer Release mal vergessen und bei den anderen klappt es immer. Ich denke, das wird immer der gleiche Prozess sein. Ich denke schon, dass es intentional ist. Die werden ja nicht so einen Studio haben und der so ja, Release ist jetzt, ach Scheiße, ich hab jetzt noch den Sausgut vergessen. So wird es da nicht laufen.
Aber wer weiß.
Mich erreicht gerade eine wunderbare Meldung. Also nicht ganz wunderbar.
Facebook ist an Microsoft verkauft.
Habt ihr dieses nur so als kleine Aufheiterung zwischendurch vielleicht noch, bevor wir uns den ernsten Themen widmen, habt ihr diese Priel-Design-Abstimmung?
Anonymous hat wieder zugeschlagen.
Wo das Priel-Design lange Zeit sehr weit vorne war. Sie haben jetzt geschrieben, dass sie das nicht großflächig in den Handel bringen, aber eine Sonderauflage produzieren werden.
Und die geht weg und wir haben ein 7 und danach dann doch großflächig.
Und was ging das?
Also Priel hat nach einem Cover gesucht für eine Sonderausgabe ihrer komischen Fläche. Priel, das ist Geschirrspülmittel.
Willst du viel, spül mit Priel.
Dann haben sie halt den Fehler gemacht, im Internet Abstimmungen von Designvorschlägen, die Leute hochladen können, zu machen. Und unter anderem gab es dann halt, welches Symbol war das? Welches Grafik war das normal? Welches Meme ist das?
Ich paste das in den Chat und du kannst draufklicken.
Hättest du Linkinus schon am Bräuchchen?
Das ist aus Super-O und allen...
Das ist ein Meme, das ist so ein klassisches Anonymous-Meme, das Teil, aber ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, wie es heißt.
Das scrollt viel durchs Internet.
Fu-Meme?
Fu? Na ja, auf jeden Fall hatten die da halt verschiedene komische Designs eingereicht und wollten auf jeden Fall eins davon durchbringen. Und na ja, dieses Priiiiil-Design hat's jetzt dann doch irgendwie zumindest, also wenn man diesem Facebook da glauben kann, in eine Sonderauflage geschaut.
Na ja, die Sonderauflage ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie zehn Stück.
Genau, das da, ja. Wenn mal sowas richtig schief läuft, sagt man Fu.
Ach so, in dem Fall, wenn der Joghurt, ja, wollen wir jetzt hier Meme erzählen?
Also, da könnt ihr im Internet auf jeden Fall euch reichliche Beispiele holen.
Bildt euch jetzt ins Internet ein.
Schade, bis eben fand ich es noch cool, als ich das Bild gesehen hab, fand ich es dann nicht mehr cool.
Ja, ich schick dir mal ein paar von Super-O. Darum schick ich es dir ja. Auf jeden Fall, was wollte ich sagen, Know Your Meme ist auf jeden Fall auch eine ganz großartige Seite, um genau so eine Frage zu beantworten. Was ist das eigentlich? Wo kommt es her?
Know Your Meme ist die, die, das ist, das ist wichtiger als Wikipedia, wenn man das verstehen will.
Also es ist...
Ja, früher war es das Johnson-Pfeil.
Das Internet darf man ja in der Wikipedia nicht erklären, weil alles, was nicht von der Heiligen Presse gesegnet wurde, ist ja nicht relevant. Kann ja nicht sein, dass irgendwas, was aus dem Internet kommt und nur vom Internet bestätigt wird, auf einmal relevant ist.
Naja, auf jeden Fall.
Sind wir schön vom Thema abgekommen. Und was hat Anonymous jetzt gemacht? Jetzt haben sie irgendwie den Krieg erklärt und jetzt hat irgendjemand in der PA-Abteilung mal einen Freund gefragt, der vom Internet was versteht und der hat gesagt, Leute, das könnt ihr nicht gewinnen. Bringt irgendwie ein paar Flaschen raus mit dem Scheißteil, dann seid ihr los.
Genau.
Und das passiert jetzt.
So steht das zumindest auf Facebook geschrieben.
Ich kauf eine.
Ja, ich auch.
Kannst du bitte den Link da auch nochmal reintun? Oder ist das hier schon dieser Facebook-Link da oben?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Die werden sich dann noch wundern, wenn die denken...
April, da ist natürlich eine... Achso, sie haben auch noch so eine blöde Werbesite da auf ihrem komischen...
Also hier, die Meldung gab's auf diesem Link. Ist das der gleiche?
Die werden sich denken, naja, da haben ja ein paar geklickt, aber die kaufen das ja alle nicht und jetzt werden sie sich dann wundern, dass sie wirklich alle diese Priel-Packung haben wollen und...
Hier nennen sie das Priel-Design.
Es steht ja ein Priel drauf.
Okay, naja, das ist doch, das ist doch, ich meine, das ist doch wirklich, das ist doch PR-Arbeit, wie man sie sich wünscht. Spät, aber es kommt. Na gut. Aber eigentlich wollte ich ja vorhin elegant, weil wir eh gerade bei dem Thema waren, weil es ja eigentlich immer ganz geil ist, wenn Leute den Podcast hören und ein Thema fügt sich in das andere und es hat immer ein bisschen was miteinander zu tun.
Du kannst es ja mit Ableton schneiden.
Und man ist in so einem Flow. Und dann kommt man auf Mobile-Max und die Jungs reden durcheinander und die Themen sind irgendwie durcheinander.
Weil du zu faul bist, das wieder in die richtige Reihenfolge zu schneiden.
Du, nächstes Mal setze ich mich hin und mache auch noch so richtig geile Sound-Übergänge. So mit so Swooshes.
Und Mosaikeffekt und so. Ach nee, das war Keynote.
So ein akustischer Mosaikeffekt.
Genau, machen wir das doch mal.
Max, was ist jetzt das nächste Thema?
Was, was, was, was?
Du hast doch bestimmt zuhause gesessen mit der Family-No in der Hand und hast ja irgendwie auf deinem Android-TV-Fernseher die Google-Io-Keynotes angeguckt.
War die langweilig.
Nee, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Aber du hast sie gesehen.
Ich hab die erste, also die Auftakt-Keynote, ging erstmal überhaupt nicht in Deutschland zu gucken. Da hab ich mir erstmal BlackVPN angeklickt. Das ging nicht in Deutsch?
Not available in your country?
Das wurde über YouTube gestreamt. Und ich hab alle Browser ausprobiert und sonst was. Und es kam Not available. Also stand nicht in your country, aber es war so der gleiche Schirm.
Because it's open.
Genau, und dann hab ich mir BlackVPN angeklickt und dann ging's spontan. Und dann, man ey, also das war wirklich sterbenslangweilig. Also sie haben halt irgendwie fancy Grafiken über Wachstum und alles viel geht total ab und krass und tolle Zahlen. Aber auch wenn der Steve Jobs Tod ist, krank und schmal und sonst was ist, aber der der delivered irgendwie mal eine Keynote, die den Namen verdient hat. Und diese jungen dynamischen Google-Jungenspunde, die standen da und dann irgendwie so nach jedem Satz so eine Pause, wo jetzt Platz für Applaus wäre, aber es kam keiner. Wo bei Apple alle so Steve, Steve, Steve on Standing Ovation zwei neue Store aufmacht oder es jetzt neue Farbe beim Bumper gibt. Da war nix, auch selbst bei den spektakulärsten Zahlen. Und irgendwann hab ich auch nach einer halben Stunde ausgemacht, weil ich irgendwie...
Wenn man Fanboy sein will eigentlich generell, bleibt eigentlich nur Apple, weil das macht nirgendwo anders Spaß.
Ich glaube, das ist halt auch der Grund, weil die Leute, die halt keinen Bock auf dieses Fanboy-Dingsbums haben, die gehen halt zu Android und Google, weil sie sich halt irgendwie dann... Also es kann ja sein, dass das so ist, aber sie ziehen halt trotzdem die Keynote, also der Gesprächspartner war irgendwie so aufgebaut, dass es so nach jedem Satz irgendwie so eine Applauspause gab, aber die Leute saßen halt da, ja, okay, skip, skip, skip. Na ja, also in der ersten halben Stunde ging es nur so um Wachstum, Wachstum und krasses Wachstum und noch mehr Activated-Geräte und wir haben jetzt so und so 4 Millionen...
Na gut, aber das ist bei Apple genauso.
Wie gesagt, aber das war halt so stermslangweilig präsentiert, dass ich danach ausgemacht hab.
Wenn ihr mich schon mit Marktzahlen nicht reißen könnt, wie wollt ihr es dann noch mit eurer Voice-Upgrade hinkriegen?
Ja, ich mein, es war ja auch von vornherein klar, was sie announcen würden. Also ich find das auch sowieso scheiße, diese Keynote so zu spoilen. Also auch nicht nur bei Apple, sondern auch bei der Google IO., selbst wenn die Show jetzt schon nicht so großartig ist, aber dann guckt man halt auch wirklich nicht mehr, ne?
Na ja, gut, also ich hatte keine Zeit mir das anzugucken. Ich hab ein bisschen gegengelesen, was so released wurde. Im Wesentlichen haben sie für meinen Dafürhalten angekündigt, dass sie ihre größten Fehler irgendwie in den Griff kriegen wollen. Also sie wollen gegen diese Fragmentation vorgehen. Das ist ja diese ominöse Allianz, die sie jetzt mit den Herstellern eingehen wollen. So nach dem Motto, wenn ihr nach unserem, wie ist das schön auf diesen geliebten E-Mails, die da in seinem Rechtsstreit raus kamen, der Kompatibilitätsclub, den Google da ausgerufen hat, irgendein Mitarbeiter meinte, ja, wir holen sie in den Club mit Kompatibilität und dann müssen sie irgendwie nach unserer Pfeife tanzen.
Du hast es mit dem Club nicht verstanden, ne?
Wieso? Das hab ich nicht verstanden.
Das Wort Club steht nicht für bei uns Club, sondern für Schläger.
Also für den Golfschläger.
Die ziehen den damit eine rüber, genau. Das ist die Waffe, damit wir sie zwingen, damit sie...
Oh, das hab ich wirklich nicht verstanden. Bist du sicher, dass das so gemeint war?
Sehr sicher.
Also hab ich auch so verstanden.
Weil da gab's ja zwei E-Mails, da war doch bei dem Gruber Google's Club, weil die gleiche Meldung gab's doch schon mal mit Microsoft. Und bei der Microsoft-Mail war's auch so. Das ist unser Club, mit dem wir die zwingen irgendwie...
Der ungepolsterte Hebel quasi. Der auch so leicht zu lösen ist und in die Hand als Schlagwerk zeugt.
Hier, DickCC, Club heißt doch...
Deine Porno Seiten immer.
Knüppeln, Knüppeln, Keulen, sich vereinigen, versammeln, einen Stock prügeln, einen Stock schlagen, mit einer Keule schlagen. Ein Club ist eine Keule, ein Knüppel, Schlagstock.
Ok, also der Google-Mitarbeiter hat sozusagen dann diese Kompatibilität als ihren Trügel, mit dem sie auch alle eintrügeln können, bezeichnet.
Ja, bei Mobemax.
Das nochmal kurz nachzuschlagen.
Na, Video-Rentals, ne? Da steht auch nicht auf der Liste drauf.
Na ja, aber jetzt nochmal zu diesen, also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, haben sie jetzt dieses Problem mit diesen OS-Updates irgendwie realisiert, dass es eins ist. Und sie wollen jetzt da Allianzen schmieden mit den Herstellern, um irgendwie sicherzustellen, dass wenn Google mal ein System-Update durchbringen will, dass es dann auch den End-User erreicht. Erstens und zweitens wollen sie auch mal so was wie eine Garantie, dass man eine anderthalb Jahr lang noch Updates bekommt, durchsetzen, was es so auch nicht gibt. Es gab ja zahlreiche Handsets, die also entweder nie ein Update gesehen haben oder nach drei Monaten schon mehr oder weniger offiziell discontinued waren.
Ich glaube, es gab nicht diverse, sondern es ist einfach der Standardfall, dass du einfach nie ein Update siehst.
Na gut, bei dem Nexus, was Google selber rausgemacht hat, da war es ja anders ein bisschen.
Und bei den Motorolas doch?
Insofern kann man...
Bei den Motorolas ist es ganz furchtbar.
Bei den Motorolas war es auch ganz furchtbar. Es ist halt generell schlimm. Und natürlich auch diese ganze Problematik mit... Diese ganze Problematik mit... Du brauchst Strom?
Gut, dass wir es jetzt schön laut gemacht haben.
Was hast du mich durcheinander gebracht? Die Update-Problematik, ja genau. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie sie es lösen wollen. Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, ob sie dazu was gesagt haben, auf diesen Keynotes, oder ob da irgendwas durchklang. Diese Problematik, dass ja auch HTC angepasste Versionen hat mit dem eigenen GUI und so weiter. Das müssen sie halt irgendwie lösen. Andererseits glaube ich nicht, dass ihnen das so schnell gelingen wird. Aber zumindest probieren sie es jetzt mal. Was sicherlich für die Android-User auch wirklich gut ist.
Du hattest die ganze Zeit übrigens das Netzteil dran ohne Strom. Das war ja abgeschaltet.
Ist gleich leer, ich brauch den Stecker wieder.
Nimm meins.
Gib mir deinen Saft.
Ich hab doch mit sieben Stunden, Jungs, sieben Stunden habe ich.
Ich seh jetzt schon wieder die Kommentare von meinem geistigen Auge. Lasst euch doch mal ausreden. Ich seh schon. Google, es ist kein Thema für uns hier eigentlich.
Doch, ich find die Chromebooks relativ okay auf so einer Art.
Dieses Enterprise-Verleih.
Ne, nicht dieses Enterprise-Verleih.
Jetzt mach ich's leer.
Ne, das sind doch so quasi Netbooks, auf denen dieses Chrome-Betriebssystem läuft, was...
Das es nicht gibt.
Ja doch, das gibt's ja.
Was, seit wann?
Na, es gibt diese Testgeräte, die sie verschickt haben, diese Prototypen quasi, und ab 15. Juni wird's das auch geben.
Also es gibt's noch nicht. Das ist das, was ich sagen will. Es gibt dieses Betriebssystem nicht.
Doch, auf den entsprechenden Testgeräten, die sie rumgeschickt haben, schon.
Es gibt Beta-Versionen von irgendwas, aber es gibt das OS ist nicht gelöst.
Bei Google gibt's doch immer noch Beta-Versionen von irgendwas.
Ja, ich mein, sie haben schon viele angekündigt. Das muss ja erstmal da sein, bevor man auch sagen kann, es ist da.
Hast du nicht jetzt angekündigt, dass irgendein Produkt Beta heißt?
Ja, dieses Musikding heißt tatsächlich Beta und wenn ich's richtig verstanden habe...
Nee, Music Beta.
Naja, Music Beta, also...
Das ist doch voll der Marketingzug, weil alle suchen, wenn sie nach Google-Software suchen, nach Beta-Software und dann landen sie automatisch bei der Musiksoftware.
Wenn du nach Beta suchst, landest du sowieso bei Google, weil er heißt eigentlich schonmal als Beta. Wie auch immer. Lass uns doch mal zumindest innerhalb eines Themas ein bisschen beim Thema bleiben.
Nein!
Ich wollte jetzt über diese Chromebook-Szene, jetzt hast du gesagt, dass du es nicht will. Ich versuche gerade auf diese Chromebook-Geschichte einzugehen.
Okay, Denis, wir lassen die jetzt mal hier machen.
Ja, also es ist ja interessant, was Google da eigentlich gerade macht. Sie pushen gerade zwei Betriebssysteme, die eine vollkommen andere Philosophie haben, gleichzeitig. ich kann nur Kommentatoren zustimmen, die das so interpretieren, dass das im Prinzip so ein Inhouse-Wettbewerb ist. Beziehungsweise, dass Google in gewisser Hinsicht zwei Fronten kämpft gerade. Das eine ist quasi der Krieg, den sie so vor allem mit Apple ausfechten, wobei es eigentlich ja gar nicht so ist, dass Google gegen Apple kämpft, sondern es ist so Google und Apple haben mit ihrem Ansatz für ein Smartphone derzeit am meisten Erfolg und sie werden jetzt zu den dominierenden Plattformen.
Sie sind Konkurrenten.
Ja, sie sind Konkurrenten, aber die eigentliche Bedrohung von Google und Apple geht gar nicht so sehr jeweils auf den anderen, weil sie beide massiv wachsen und weil sie beide eine andere Teil des Marktes adressieren. Mit Überschneidung.
Also im Tablet-Markt probiert Google an Apples Markt zu kommen.
Der iPad-Markt meinst du.
Wenn man ihn mag.
Ja, ich rede aber jetzt von Smartphones. Und diejenigen, die da wirklich zu leiden haben, sind Microsoft, sind Rim und so weiter. Gut, Rim wächst noch, aber ich glaube, ja, aber das wird bald sein Ende finden. Und Nokia hat mehr. dann gibt es halt noch diesen anderen Bereich. Den Enterprise-Markt. Den Apple zwar auch irgendwie angeht, aber ganz anders. Und wo Apple jetzt glaube ich nicht im Traum daran denken würde, so ein Produkt wie diese Chromebooks rauszubringen. Aber das ist natürlich ein sehr interessantes Ding, weil das ist nämlich dieser Markt, wo man so High-Volume-Massen-PC-Hardware verkauft, für Anwendungen, wo am Ende sowieso nur ein Web-Browser gefahren wird. Das ist das, worauf Google setzt. Warum solltest du Chrome OS brauchen? Das ist ein OS, was im Wesentlichen ein Browser ist.
Ja, das ist ein OS, was im Wesentlichen ein Browser ist. 98% der Menschheit wollen genau das. Und sonst nichts.
Das 98% der Menschheit?
Ja, einfach um mit Zeit zu sagen. Die meisten Leute wollen das Gerät, ein kleines, relativ billiges Gerät, und du gibst da deinen Google-User-Namen ein, und wenn es kaputt ist, holst du ein neues, und gibst da wieder deinen Google-User-Namen ein, und hast alles da, wie du es vorher hattest, und brauchst keine Software-Updates zu machen, und brauchst überhaupt nichts. Das ist so wie endlich da, wo das Auto ist.
Du gehörst auch zu diesen 98%?
Nee, ich gehöre nicht zu diesen 98%, aber ich hab mich immer schon gefragt bei einem Auto, Autos waren jahrzehntelang, war das immer ein totales Bastel-Ding, wo man alles dran rumschrauben musste, und man musste selber sich viel auskennen, man musste Reifen wechseln können. Und jetzt seit ein paar Jahrzehnten ist es so, dass man braucht ein Auto, man braucht sich damit nicht mehr auskennen. Man kauft sich das, da ist ein Stutzen erfüllt mit Benzin rein und dann fährt's.
Das hat ja jetzt nichts mit Web zu tun in dem Sinne.
Das Chromebook ist jetzt für den Computermarkt das, was dieses Auto ist. Das ist ein Gerät, du brauchst da keine Software-Aktualisierung, du brauchst wirklich keine Ahnung haben.
Brauchst du da keine Software-Aktualisierung?
Das bezweifle ich aber. Die wird sich irgendwie von Hintergrund über das Netz laufen und komplett automatisch und du brauchst... Außer Flashplugin brauchst du da gar nichts zu aktualisieren.
Flashplugin? Ist bei Chrome OS Frilash dabei?
Ich hör's schon.
Bei Chrome OS ist ein Flashplugin im OS... Wisst ihr, was das ist?
Mann, ich will jetzt aber nicht über Flash reden. Ich will einfach nur sagen...
Ich will auch nicht über Flash reden, ich wundere mich... Bist du sicher?
Wer nicht Tim erstmal festgebissen hat an der Wade von Max.
Ja, da ist Flash dabei. Das ist ein total praktisches Gerät für sehr viele Leute. Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich meiner Oma jetzt irgendwas hinstellen sollte, wenn die mich fragen würde, wenn meine Oma noch in dem Zustand wäre...
Würde ich ein iPad ihr geben.
Dann würde ich ja entweder ein iPad geben oder dieses Ding.
Na ja, wir warten mal bis es da ist, oder?
Aber wir reden überhaupt nicht von Endusern, die in irgendeiner Form irgendwas selber wollen, sondern der Enterprise-Markt ist von Leuten, die nicht mit zu entscheiden haben, die eine Vorstandsentage irgendwas machen. Diese Chrome-OS-Geschichte zielt meiner Meinung nach ausschließlich auf diesen Enterprise-Markt.
Das ist deine Meinung, ich hab eine andere Meinung.
Hab ich gehört. Erinnert aber jetzt auch nichts an meine Meinung. Weil das, was du da beschreibst, die Leute wollen was Einfaches haben, das ist das, was das iPhone ist. Und ich glaube, dass die Leute, denen das egal ist, ob das eine Web-Applikation ist oder eine native Applikation, die wollen das haben, was am einfachsten zu benutzen ist. Und ich glaube, dass du derzeit einfache Benutzung mit dem Web so nicht hinkriegst. Das Web hat da einfach noch viel zu viele Probleme, als dass man da wirklich einfache Benutzung hinkriegt. Trotz alledem wird es natürlich...
Das ist jetzt mal wirklich Bullshit. Das ist nicht Bullshit.
Soll ich dir ein Beispiel nennen?
Nein, sollst du nicht.
Mach mal an der Webseite Apfel A. Das versteht niemand.
Es will auch niemand Apfel A an der Webseite.
Leute drücken Apfel A. Ja, du markierst Text. Auf einmal ist die ganze Seite blau oder gelb oder was auch immer deine Highlight-Farbe ist. Das ist nicht einfache Benutzung. Das ist verwirrend.
Aber ist das, was die Leute kennen und was sie wollen?
Die Leute. Ich will mich überhaupt nicht streiten. Ich will nur versuchen, den Punkt zu machen, was ich glaube, was Google da vorhat. Weil sie haben halt zwei OS-Trails. Apple hat nur einen. Und dieses Chrome OS ist halt einfach der Enterprise-Markt. Das ist kein Konsumer-Markt. Kein Konsumer wird den Laden gehen und schreien und gröhlen und stolz seinen Chromebook vorzeigen, was er sich ab dann für 28 Dollar im Monat gemietet hat für die nächsten Jahre. Mit Wartungsvertrag am Arbeitsplatz. Das ist einfach nicht das Produkt an der Stelle. Ich sehe schon, das zieht alles überhaupt nicht. Auf jeden Fall haben sie da irgendwas vorgestellt, aber das gibt es halt immer noch nicht.
Oder?
Also im Juni soll das rauskommen.
15.
Juni.
Na, da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Und, wollt ihr das haben?
Ja, ich muss mal warten, wenn es da ist.
Ja, dann gucken wir uns das mal an.
Und wenn meine Peergroup das hat und das toll findet, dann gucke ich mir das vielleicht auch mal an.
Ich hab ja noch nicht mein iPad bis jetzt.
Ich lass mir das von meiner Peergroup herantragen. Und wenn es mich über die Peergroup nicht erreicht, dann kann es nicht gut genug gewesen sein. So funktioniert es bei mir mittlerweile.
Wo wir jetzt gerade noch bei diesen Firmen sind, diesen komischen.
Soll ich gleich wieder mit der Verschwörungsecke ankommen?
Bitte.
Na wie war das? Na also erstens, die brauchen ja Skype natürlich, um irgendwie das auf ihrem Windows 7 anzubieten und wenn sie es dann erstmal durchgesetzt hat, so in zwei, drei Jahren.
Jetzt das sehen wir erstmal aus.
Wieso?
Genau.
Um das anzubieten, das gibt's doch schon.
Ja, warte, aber dann um, also sie kaufen natürlich um die Kontrolle zu haben, dann kommt's aufs Windows 7 mit drauf oder gibt's das schon? Dann irgendwann drehen sie bei den anderen dann langsam den Hahn zu.
Welchen anderen?
Na, gibt halt kein Backclient mehr und so.
Genau.
Ah, du meinst, dann werden die Leute alle sich Windows kaufen?
Klar.
Und Skype dann nicht mehr läuft.
So gut wie Facetime funktioniert, kann ich mir das ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen.
Facetime hat noch nie funktioniert. iChat Video geht besser.
Ich glaub, die Zeiten sind vorbei, dass Microsoft über das Abdrehen von Plattform Support noch irgendeinen Blumentopf gewinnen kann. Das würde ihnen nur schaden. 8,5 Milliarden US-Dollar.
Ja, dann okay. Was deine Theorie war, warum haben sie es ausgegeben und gekauft?
Weil Steve Boimer ist out of his mind und hat jegliche Kontrolle über seinen Hirn verloren. Also dieser Typ, ich verstehe ihn schon lange nicht mehr, wohin er eigentlich will. Dieser Laden macht seit Jahren keine Fortschritte. Nein, sie haben in den letzten zehn Jahren kein einziges Business-Feld ausgebaut, wo sie irgendwie neuen Gewinn machen. Kein einziges.
Aber sie machen immer noch mehr Gewinn als...
Immer noch mit ihren selben zwei Produkten. Windows Office.
Vielleicht...
Auf einem Markt, der mittlerweile 17 Prozent pro Quartal schrumpft.
Schrumpft.
Nicht so schnell weg.
Und wir werden es nicht um 17 Prozent schrumpft.
Naja, wir wissen alle, was sie da... Ja, nichts, was auch nur in irgendeiner Form diesen riesigen Apparat Microsoft genauso gesund unterstützen könnte. Also ohne Office und ohne Windows ist Microsoft nicht...
Also es ist schon in den Umsatz- und Gewinnschatz ist so Xbox und so schon immer noch ein sehr schmaler...
Da ist also... Im besten Fall, ich hab das jetzt nicht nachgerechnet, aber im besten Fall haben sie so ihre Kosten von Anfang irgendwie wieder drin. Aber dass das jetzt so ein riesiger Gewinnbringer ist, davon sind sie doch weit entfernt.
Dafür haben die zu viel subventioniert, glaube ich auch.
Ja.
Okay, warum haben sie nun Skype gekauft?
Ja, weil ich kann mir...
Irgendeine Strategie muss er ja haben, auch wenn sie nicht plausibel klingt, aber... Ich mein, das kann doch nur so eine marktbeherrschende Stellung sein oder der Gedanke, dass irgendwie normale Telefonie von Skype abgelöst wird.
Ich hab diesen von Google verarscht worden.
Meinst du, Google hat so ein Spin gemacht, das Google so ein bisschen geboten hat? Und Microsoft hat gedacht, oh Gott, die wollen Skype kaufen, lass uns mal schnell zuvorkommen.
Genau das.
Oder Microsoft hat jetzt Angst.
Ja, aber ohne irgendwie zu wissen, was Google mit Skype eigentlich anfangen könnte. Weil damit kann Google gar nichts anfangen.
Vielleicht haben sie sie auch gekauft, weil sie Facetime gesehen haben.
Ja, aber ich bitte dich, das ist doch keine komplizierte Technologie, dieses Facetime.
Anscheinend schon.
Naja, im Gegensatz zu Facetime funktioniert Skype. Das muss man ihnen lassen.
Und alle nutzen Skype.
Ja gut, aber Skype macht damit aber auch keinen Gewinn. Das ist eine Firma, die keinen Gewinn macht. Das ist einfach kein Business-Modell. Das benutzen viele. Okay, es gibt viele Dinge, die viele Leute benutzen, die aber alle kein Geld machen. Am Ende willst du halt irgendwas haben, wo du auch Geld mitverdienen kannst. Insbesondere, wenn du 8,5 Milliarden US-Dollar dafür ausgibst.
Also die Gründer oder die, denen es gerade gehört, haben sich bestimmt den ganzen Tag da und grinsen. Die brauchen ja keine Drogen mehr nehmen. Die haben ja so eine normale Endorphinausschüttung.
Die können gar nicht so viel Sperma produzieren, wie sie wegwachsen könnten bei diesen ganzen Deals, die sie da irgendwie mit Skype machen.
Ja, und Ibel freut sich auch, weil wenn wir ein paar Prozent behalten, dann wurde das ja auch vergeudet. Zehn Prozent haben sie, glaube ich, behalten.
Ja, also ich wüsste überhaupt nicht, welche Strategie... Ich meine, Skype ist eh da auf Windows.
Ja, sie könnten jetzt halt anfangen, das in Xbox Live aufs Windows-Phone und überall halt direkt zu integrieren, auf den Desktops und was sie noch so machen.
Ja, und dann?
Ja, dann haben sie 8,5 Milliarden Dollar Value in ihre Products geadded. Vielleicht. Ich weiß es auch nicht, dass es für uns als Außenstehende...
Vielleicht ist es ja auch so Next Big Thing und wir wissen es noch nicht.
Tja, also ich schüttel nur noch den Kopf. Ich kann da überhaupt nicht erkennen, was das soll.
Also ich hasse Skype genauso wie der andere auch, aber ich glaube diese Telefonietechnik, die dahinter steckt, die ist schon ein bisschen Geld wert. Die ist sicherlich keine 8,5 Milliarden wert.
Aber ich meine, es müsste doch Microsoft auch hinkriegen. Jetzt mal ehrlich, die haben doch auch Engineers. Die sind doch nicht doof da. Die könnten doch mal eine Videotelefonie kriegen.
Ich meine, es kriegt ja sonst keiner hin. Und ich glaube, das braucht einfach Zeit.
Ja gut, das Skype funktioniert und so weiter geschenkt. Das ist aber nicht meine Frage. Die Frage ist ja, oder was ist nicht die Frage? Die Frage ist, welchen Wert hat die Akquise von Skype insbesondere eine solch teure für Microsoft als Ganzes? Was erlaubt der Besitz von Skype, ihnen zu tun, was sie sonst nicht auch hätten tun können?
Was erlauben es drunter?
Spielen wie einmal leer.
Und ich habe eine Theorie, eine vage Theorie gelesen, wo ich mir dachte, okay, das könnte vielleicht in irgendeine Richtung weisen. Das habe ich aber noch nicht so richtig zu Ende gedacht. Nämlich, es wird diese ganze Frage der Disruption der Telekommunikationsinfrastruktur und der Telekommunikationsunternehmen. Man sieht ja in diesem Smartphone-Markt wunderbar, gerade bei dem Fight von Google, was die Computerkonzerne und Softwarehersteller für Probleme haben mit diesen großen Firmen, weil die so eine Macht haben. Dadurch, dass sie eben diese Netze erhoben haben, haben die einfach eine riesige Macht. Da kann man mal nicht so eben an denen vorbei. Und Apple ist eigentlich die erste Firma, die mit dem iPhone es geschafft hat, da zumindest ein bisschen Disruption reinzubringen. Aber wir sehen alle täglich an den Tarifen, da ist einfach noch viel Protektion am Start. Das ist einfach so ein weltweites Oligopol. Und das irgendwie zu übernehmen und aufzulösen, da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass sich Microsoft denkt, dass Skype da ein Tool ist. Sozusagen so diese Frage mit, wie telefonieren wir alle miteinander? Und wer hat quasi die Macht über die Netze, dass sie da in irgendeiner Form für sich eine Chance sehen? Aber ich trau einfach auch Microsoft an der Stelle überhaupt nichts mehr zu. Wenn man sich anschaut, wie sie diese ganzen Smartphone-Trends von vorne bis hinten komplett verschlafen haben, also Herr Bäumer vor allem, der am Anfang ja noch meinte, das iPhone wird sich nie durchsetzen.
Und für 500 Dollar schon gar nicht.
Das kriegt ja keinen nennenswerten Marktanteil und heute verdient das iPhone alleine 55 Prozent des Geldes, was insgesamt für Telefone auf diesem Planeten ausgegeben wird.
Das ist absurd. Meinst du, dass er wirklich damals geglaubt hat? Also, ich bin der festen Überzeugung, der wusste genau, was die da haben, aber er wollte jetzt nicht irgendwie die Hose runterlassen. Wollte nicht die Hose runterlassen.
Also ich glaube ja, dass der irgendwie so...
Aber Steve Ballmer, gerade der hat kein Problem, glaube ich, damit die Hose runterzulassen.
Zuzugeben, dass er den Markt verpempert, ich glaube, damit hat er ein theoretisches Problem.
Ja, aber ich meine, was hat denn Microsoft und das Steve Ballmer ein großartiges Neues rausgebracht? Microsoft hat heute noch genau dasselbe Portfolio. Jetzt macht man so Details ab, sieht, wie dieser knickt, was auch nur eingekauft war. Was hat denn diese Firma im Angebot, was sie vor zehn Jahren nicht auch schon im Angebot hatten?
Sohn, ach nee, warte.
Nichts.
Das ist vielleicht gerade...
Das ist immer noch das selbe Geschäftsmodell. Das basiert einfach nur auf dieser überragenden marktbeherrschenden Stellung im Enterprise-Markt.
Das ist schon krass, ne?
Und im Consumer-Markt, da haben wir auch schon ein paar Mal drüber geredet. Post PC hin, Post PC her, ob das ein guter Begriff ist oder nicht. Tatsache ist, dieser PC-Markt ist im Wandel. Und der Trend geht nach unten.
Werden wir ja sehen demnächst, wir können ja... machst du dir auch so Future... Claim Powder? Oder wie heißt das immer genannt?
Chowder.
Chowder. Und dann holen wir es in einem Jahr noch mal raus. Erlaube Skype. Und dann gucken wir mal.
Ich überlasse das anderen.
Aber was ich ja sehr schön fand, dass Skype prompt irgendwie drei Tage nachdem sie von Microsoft aufgekauft waren, irgendwie eine massive Sicherheitslücke auf dem Mac hatten.
Ja, das war auch scary.
Und sich dann erstmal...
Also das war auch scary für OS X eigentlich. Also wenn du über eine Drittanbieter-Applikation Root Shell kriegst, dann...
Hast du eine Root Shell gekriegt?
Hast du da irgendeine Payload in dem Voice-Protokoll geschickt und hattest eine Root Shell.
Passt da nicht gut zu Microsoft.
Ja, aber ich mein, also was sagt das über die OS X Security, wenn da so eine App daherkommt und dir mal eine Root Shell machen kann.
Das ist auch hart.
Das ist eigentlich unter aller Sau.
Ich dachte, das wäre einfach nur irgendeine Shell.
Ist das eigentlich irgendwie dokumentiert? Was da der...
Also ich hätte ja so eine Vermutung, dass es irgendwie dann über das Audio-Core-Audio oder irgendwo sonst wo in irgendeinem Bereich landet, wo es nicht rein sollte, aber...
Aber ist jetzt gar nicht dokumentiert worden, was eigentlich das Loch ist, was sie da genutzt haben?
Habe ich zugegebenerweise mich nicht so richtig ausführlich mit beschäftigt. Weiß nicht, ob es da vielleicht ein Advisory sogar gibt. Das alte Skype nicht.
War ich von 2008?
Nee, das ist das, was das nicht hat. Nur die neue Version.
Jetzt ist der mit einmal schon leer.
Genau, ich kann sie dir noch von mir kopieren. Ich habe nämlich auch noch nicht geupgraded. Fühlt unsicher. So, diese komischen anderen Songs, die öden mich aber thematisch ganz schön an.
Ja, mich auch. Bleiben wir bei Apple. Hat jemand diese Line-Preview 3 gesehen?
Nee, ist ja verboten.
Ich habe nur davon gelesen, aber ich finde es schon mal sehr sympathisch, dass sie diese komischen Schiebetaps wieder korrigiert haben.
Aber es ist immer noch nicht so cool wie vorher, also so gut zu erkennen.
Ich finde die Wesen nicht besser zu erkennen als die aktuellen.
Okay, dann habe ich vielleicht den neuen noch nicht richtig gesehen. Weil die alten waren richtig scheiße.
Ja, die neuen sind okay, aber diese, die sie in Preview 1 hatten, diese komischen Schiebeschnupsis, die waren wirklich sehr verwirrend.
Was ich an denen mit dem Schieben ganz okay fand, ich habe irgendwann mal vor Jahren mal einen Artikel über das Apple, über den Aqua gelesen. Und da war in Bezug auf diese Tabs, wenn du davon zwei hast, du weißt nicht intuitiv, also wenn du das vorher noch nie gesehen hast, weißt du nicht, welcher ist der aktive und welcher ist der inaktive. Und bei diesen Schieben-Nupsis war das mal sehr eindeutig, dass mit dem Kästchen drunter ist das aktiver. Also ich glaube, da gibt es dann wirklich nicht mehr viele Zweifel dran.
Naja, wenn man nur zwei sieht, und man ist halt noch so ein bisschen iPhone gewohnt, da ist es ja auch irgendwie der, wo das Schnupsi nicht ist, sondern der, wo es so blau ist, das ist der aktive. Deswegen kommen ja gerade alle durcheinander. Und ich glaube, da wollten sie ja hin, dass sie Leinen mehr so iOS anlehnen, aber bei zweien weiß man es halt eben nicht genau, welcher nun welcher ist.
Sie haben halt den Kontrast halt umgedreht oder nicht?
Irgendwie so, ja. Und sie haben ja auch nochmal nachgerigiert.
Ich finde es gar nicht gut, dass sie auf dieses Blau verzichten. Ich fand dieses Blau als Highlight-Color fand ich geil. Ich auch. Jetzt wird alles grau und man weiß überhaupt nicht mehr, was Sache ist. Also das damit auch, dass sie die ganzen Icons, die Farben rausnehmen, das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht. Was soll denn das, dieser ganze Monochrom?
Weil die rausnehmen, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Die Farbe ist schon noch da, das Blaue. Auch so ein Aquabar ist ja schon noch blau.
Guck dir mal Mehl ab an, das ist überhaupt nicht mehr benutzbar. Das erste Mal, dass ich mir da runter lade, ist irgendwie so ein Plugin, wo diese Farb-Icons wieder kommen.
Also gerade Mehl finde ich, Mehl wird plötzlich wieder benutzbar.
Mit dem Lion-Mehl?
Ja.
Ich kann diese ganzen Dinger nicht mehr auseinanderhalten.
Für mich ist die Farbe so wichtig. Die Eichen sind mir... Über die Icons habe ich mir nicht so genau angeguckt, aber ich finde dieses Lion-Mehl, dass es nicht mehr dreispaltig ist, also dieses Ordner, optional nicht mehr dreispaltig, Ordner, Mehl-Liste, Mehl-View, sondern dieses, wir machen zwei Spalten, nämlich eine für die Mails und dann oben drüber so eine Tab-Leiste mit ein paar ausgewählten Ordnern drinnen, finde ich ganz großartig.
Die heilige Dreispaltigkeit.
Die heilige Dreispaltigkeit. Ich finde, Lion, bisher, ich habe mir diese Preview 3 angeguckt, ich finde die sehr, sehr schick. Ich war ernsthaft am Überlegen, ob ich das nicht jetzt mal direkt draufschieben soll.
Ja, da war ich auch schon ein paar Mal am Überlegen, weil es wirklich auch nicht hocht.
Und gerade so, ich finde diese Steuerung mit vier Fingern, ich könnte mir das erstmal vorstellen, Spaces zu verwenden, weil das wirklich so geil intuitiv ist.
Ja, auch bei diesen Fullscreen-Apps ist das ja dann spontan sinnvoll. Im Safari auch.
Nee, da geht's noch nicht. Aber was ich bei den Fullscreen-Apps sehr, sehr enttäuschend finde, oder gerade zu schrecklich, ist die Tatsache, dass, und zwar ich finde das ja auf dem iPad so extrem nervig, dass wenn du gerade eine Mail schreibst und dann willst du mal rasch was in einer anderen Mail nachgucken, dann kannst du das nicht einfach. Sondern musst du abbrechen, klicken, musst sagen als Entwurf speichern, dann musst du dir die Mail angucken, so und dann willst du wieder zurück zur anderen Mail, musst dann deine Entwürfe gehen, Entwurf wieder aufmachen, weiter tippen. Also sehr, sehr umständlich. Und dann nicht so einfach mal Fenster wechseln. Und darum hab ich mir angeguckt, na mal gucken, wie haben sie es denn unterline gemacht, da werden sie ja wohl eine schöne Lösung dafür haben. Und es ist unterline exakt genau die gleiche Scheiße wie auf dem iPad. Wenn du im Fullscreen-Modus Mail startest und eine neue Mail aufmachst, dann hast du der ganze Bildschirm ist deine Mail, dann geht in der Mitte so ein schmaler Streifen auf mit deinem neuen Mailfenster und du siehst die anderen Mails da hinten ausgegraut, du kannst aber nicht reinklicken. Und das finde ich echt mal schlecht. Also so, ich meine, das ist auf Fullscreen alles schön und gut, tolle Sache. Aber so, alle Vorteile, die eine Mail jemals hatte, so knallhart rauszuschmeißen, finde ich echt doof.
Also man macht das ein bisschen Angst.
Der Löwe macht dir Angst? Also du musst ja nicht Fullscreen-Apps benutzen.
Noch nicht.
Also für Xcode ist Fullscreen voll toll.
Du kannst ja auch Windows 7 kaufen.
Also ich muss sagen, so die Line-Version klickt sich schon sehr fluffig. Also ich benutze jetzt auch nicht alle Features von. Die dritte noch nicht getestet, nee.
Der Chat meint, man könne sich ja ein neues Fenster aufmachen. Dann hätte man das Problem nicht mehr.
Man könnte sich ein neues Fenster aufmachen? Wenn ich Mail-Fullscreen aufhabe und den neue Mail-Button drücke, dann geht da kein Fenster auf.
Hier in diesem Fullscreen-Ausbruch.
Da gibt es keine Fenster.
Da gibt es nur noch Screens.
Ja, man kann auch irgendwo den Fullscreen-Modus...
Kannst du den zweiten Bildschirm anschließen vielleicht dann? Deswegen hat der neue iMac jetzt auch zwei Ausgänge, dass man drei Fenster gleichzeitig aufhaben kann, aber halt jeweils einen eigenen Screen dafür braucht.
Man kann Mails lesen und schreiben.
Für jedes Programm einen eigenen Bildschirm.
Und mein Problem mit diesem eine mehr lesen, die andere schreiben, kann man auch entspannt lösen, indem man sich einfach zwei bis drei weitere iPads kauft.
Du sollst auch gar nicht multitasking. Du sollst dich konzentrieren.
Und jetzt sind gerade ungefähr 98 Prozent und... Schon wieder 98. Jetzt sind gerade drei Hörer im Steuer eingeschlafen und fahren gerade gegen Baum. Du bist schuld.
Wollt ihr mal wieder hochscrollen? Würd ich mich hier auch mal ein bisschen mehr... Ach so, was haltet ihr denn von diesen lustigen Gerüchten, dass es demnächst MacBooks mit ARM-Prozessoren gibt?
Da steht Mac OS X auf ARM, da würde ich jetzt die Antwort sagen, gibt's doch schon.
Ich rede ja von Mac.
Ja, ich glaub, also...
Ist aber nicht dasselbe.
Fast.
Ich hab nicht gesagt, dass es möglich ist, das zu compilen, das weiß ich, dass das geht. Das ist nicht das Ding, aber ob sie sowas wie ein Mac... Also ob es generell noch mal denkbar ist, dass es eine Prozessortransition gibt.
Hatten wir schon mal in der Sendung, wir sind alle zum Ergebnis gekommen, dass es gerade bei Apple mit ihrer Tradition die CPU zu switchen, wenn das wer kann, dann können die das.
Also ich würde ja glauben, wenn sie halt ihr persönliches Chrome OS rausbringen, also iOS für so hier MacBook Air quasi, dann bestimmt.
Also so sehr ich das jetzt sehe, dass das iOS mit seinen vielen guten und vielleicht ein paar auch weniger guten neuen Erfindungen zurück auf den Mac kommt, so wenig sehe ich, dass wir dieses Prinzip des vollblauen Macintosh, der alles kann, anytime soon einbüßen werden. Also diese Terminals werden uns erhalten bleiben, diese Power-User-Terminals. Dafür gibt es einfach viel zu viele Use-Cases dafür, die sich in den letzten 30 Jahren entwickelt haben. Unter anderem das. Aber es gibt ja noch so sehr viel mehr. Und so sehr ich das iPhone hilfreich finde, so wenig kann ich mit dem iPad wirklich was anfangen.
Ja, ich sag ja auch nicht, dass sie das nur noch machen.
Du meinst, dass hier so eine Art MacBook Air Mini mit einem ARM-Prozessor irgendwann mal rauskommt? So die billige Version?
Ich sage nicht, dass das kommt. Ich sage nur, dass es diese Gerüchteküche gab. Und so wenig ich hier Lust habe, jetzt groß die Gerüchteküche zu machen, ist das natürlich so eine generelle Frage, ob es vorstellbar ist, dass diese ARM-Architektur sich dahingehend entwickelt, dass sie genug Power hat. Ich meine, dieser A5 ist jetzt irgendwie Dual-Core. Stromsparen ist auf jeden Fall eine wichtige Geschichte. Und es macht halt immer so den Eindruck als ab ARM, dass es irgendwie besser raus hat. Auf der anderen Seite sind sie aber performancemäßig überhaupt nicht da, wo Intel ist. Und in dem Moment, wo sie da von der Performance her anschließen können, würden sie vielleicht genauso viel Strom verbrauchen wie Intel zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie das aussehen würde, das Verhältnis zwischen einem OS, was auf einem ARM läuft und einem, was auf einem Atom läuft. Also ich glaube, die Atoms sind schon auch noch reichlich schneller, aber verbrauchen wahrscheinlich auch wieder noch ein Stückchen mehr. Man kann sich halt sozusagen seinen Bereich aussuchen, wie schnell man es haben möchte und wie viel Strom man dabei spart.
Ja genau, aber ich meine, würden sie jetzt nächstes Jahr was auf ARM machen, dann wäre es auf jeden Fall deutlich langsamer. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es da für einen Markt gäbe. Dass es einen Markt gäbe für ein MacBook Air, Super Air, MacBook Helium, was irgendwie...
Superfly!
Was, ähm... Wo die Leute mit noch weniger Performance auskommen würden.
Vielleicht kommt ja irgendwann, äh... ein iPad mit so einem Dual-Modus raus. Du kannst inzwischen iOS und Mac OS X so switchen mit Mausen-Tastatur.
Bestimmt, bestimmt!
Klar!
Klar, dass man da die Programme auch noch hier von...
Also mir ist das ehrlich gesagt zu neblig.
Ja, und bin nur sieben drauf, also das ist dreifach gut. Garantiert.
Ist mir zu neblig.
So.
Und noch System 7 drauf, auch noch mit 68.000 Emulator.
Ja, mir gehen jetzt die guten Themen aus. Alles andere, was ich jetzt hier stehen habe, will ich gar nicht mehr wirklich ansprechen.
Ich hab mir jetzt mal ein E-Book gekauft. So mit Kindle-App auf dem iPad, über das ich viel Gutes gehört habe, über dieses Kindle-App.
Du hast die Kindle-Applikation auf deinem iPad gekauft.
Nee, die gibt es kostenlos. Ich hab mir ein Buch dafür gekauft und lese jetzt quasi mal ein Buch mit dem Kindle-App. Weil es das für iBooks nicht gab. Und es hat eine Menge Schönes, aber es hat auch eine Menge ganz Furchtbares. Also die schönen Sachen sind, man kauft das Buch, man kauft es bei Amazon. Und es ist quasi sofort dann auf dem iPad, auf dem iPhone und auf dem Mac vorhanden und auf allen Geräten, die dieses Kindle-Zeug können. Das ist ja schon eine ganze Menge. Und es wird sogar, es synchronisiert die Stelle, an der man ist. Also wenn man anfängt, ich lese gerne mal auf dem iPad ein bisschen und dann lese ich wieder ein bisschen was auf dem Mac weiter. Weil das ist Fachliteratur. Weil ich jetzt so ein bisschen Objective-C lerne und so. Und da kann man halt die Beispiele schön am Mac nachbauen, indem man die Mac-Kindle-App aufmacht. Und man kann auf dem iPad lesen, wenn da mal ein paar Kapitel sind, die...
Sünkt der eigentlich auch so diesen Lesezustand, wo man sich gerade befindet, von Gerät zu Gerät?
Den sünkt er. Und ich hab mich gefragt, wie machen sie das? Ja, das ist auf die bekloppteste Art, die man sich vorstellen kann. Er fragt an, nämlich beim Start mit einem modalen Dialog. Auf dem iPad warst du jetzt gerade an Positionen, das sind ja keine Seiten, das sind ja Positionen. An Position 1478. Soll ich jetzt auch auf Position 1478 gehen? Dann sagst du entweder ja oder sagst nein. Das war eine Technologie, die WhisperSync heißt. Ja, und also die Software an sich ist wirklich furchtbar. Ich verstehs auch teilweise nicht. Die hat Grafik-Bugs, diese Kindle-Software auf dem iPad. Auf dem iPad ist es schon schlecht, auf dem Mac ist es noch ein Zacken schlechter. Also man hat zum Beispiel, wenn man hier irgendwie Text anklickt, dann wird irgendwie der ganze Text plötzlich so grau hinterlegt. Ich hab keine Ahnung warum. Und dann erscheint sowas wie so ein, wie heißt das, diese gelben Fensterchen, die früher unter Windows oder die jetzt auch auf dem Mac kommen, wenn man mit der Maus irgendwo drüber geht, diese Tooltips. Er erscheint irgendwie so ein Tooltip, und dann muss man nochmal auf den Bildschirm draufklicken beim iPad, damit die wieder weggehen, und dann bleibt aber die Fläche dahinter so, als ob sie noch geheiligetet wäre. Also wirklich wie so ein Grafikfehler. Es ist, wenn man auf den Bildschirmrand tippt, dann geht er zur nächsten Seite oder zur vorherigen, was theoretisch ganz praktisch sein mag, wenn man praktisch theoretisch wäre. Wenn man praktisch theoretisch wäre, wenn man nicht manchmal so einfach mit dem Handballen oder irgendwie mit dem Daumen doch drauf kommen würde und er sofort zur nächsten Seite springen würde. Ich habe Rendering-Probleme gehabt, also das Code-Beispiel, die drinnen standen, plötzlich wie Fleece-Text formatiert waren und umgekehrt. Dann musste man eine Seite zurückgehen, dann konnte man wieder zur nächsten Seite gehen, dann stimmte alles wieder.
Es gibt so wenig Sachen, die sich wirklich wie 21. Jahrhundert anfühlen, das ist echt erschreckend.
Und ich verstehe so langsam, warum sich dieser E-Book-Markt nicht entwickelt, weil das totale Scheiße ist bisher. Und zwar nicht nur in dem Sinne, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so ein Kindle-Problem, das ist bei E-Books garantiert auch nicht besser. Also was ich zum Beispiel furchtbar finde, gerade wenn man so Fachliteratur hat, man hat ja manchmal dieses, man hat auf einer Seite eine Tabelle, und dann hat man zehn Seiten, die sich nur auf diese Tabelle beziehen. Ja, guck doch mal da in Spalte 48, da steht ja das und das, und dann musst du im Buch wieder zurückblättern. Und, ah ja, dann hast du die Tabelle und kannst den Text dazu lesen, dann vergleichst du und so, dieses so hin und her springen. Wenn du das auf dem iPad machst, dann kannst du jedes Mal drei Seiten zurückspringen, drei Seiten vorspringen, drei Seiten zurückspringen.
Das nervt mich auch total.
Furchtbar.
Aber die Dinger sind doch zum Romane lesen gedacht und nicht für irgendwelche Referenzwerke.
Die sind zum Bücher lesen gedacht.
Ja, aber nicht für alle Bücher.
Was heißt, wofür sie gedacht sind? Sie taugen derzeit nur zum Romane lesen.
Vielleicht, ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen, dass sie für Romane Probleme haben. Ich finde es furchtbar, dass man da nicht mal eben Absatz kopieren kann. Warum? Warum kann ich hier nicht einfach Text auswählen und den kopieren?
Bei Kindle.
Bei Kindle, bei iBooks geht es auch nicht. Also bei iBooks geht es, bei einigen geht es, und bei anderen geht es nicht.
Weil du dafür hast du Lizenz nicht gekauft.
Du hast Lizenz zum Lesen und nicht zum Kopieren. Ich habe nicht die Lizenz, den Text zu kopieren und ihn mal rasch in den Übersetzer zu schmeißen, weil ich irgendein Wort nicht kenne. Ich habe nicht die Lizenz, mir mal ein paar Codebeispiele daraus zu kopieren.
Du hast die Lizenz, das Buch wieder zu löschen.
Ich glaube nicht mal, habe ich die Lizenz? Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die Lizenz habe oder ob das virtuelle Buchverbrennung wäre. Und irgendwie so richtig weit ist es noch nicht. Aber es taugt so weit, man kann mit lesen, und ich will mich jetzt auch gar nicht zu sehr beschweren, weil auf der anderen Seite nicht mehr dieses Buch mit sich rumschleppen zu müssen, sondern es wirklich immer da zu haben und auch in einer...
Bei PDF-Büchern kann man hier wunderbar kopieren, pasten, also ich habe mir ein Buch hier so PDF einfach in Allbooks...
Das hängt sehr von dem... Also ich habe auch offizielle Allbook-Bücher, bei einigen geht es und bei anderen nicht.
Im Hip-Hop kann ich auch problemlos kopieren.
Wie gesagt, bei einigen geht es, bei anderen nicht.
Vielleicht bei denen, die nicht DRM'd sind.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, welche es sind, aber ich habe auch...
Hast du welche über den iBook-Store gekauft?
Jaja, habe ich. Also ich habe so diese Beispiele, was dabei ist. Ich habe ein bisschen Apple-Dokumentation. Ich habe neulich gesehen, dass es ein offizielles iPad-Handbuch im iBook-Store gibt von Apple. Da kann man draus kopieren. Also es scheint mal so, mal so zu sein, aber irgendwie... Ich meine... Na ja, was ist das für eine Denke bei diesen Leuten, die diese... Oh mein Gott, wenn wir die Möglichkeit geben, in einem iPad-App Text zu kopieren, dann werden die Leute sich hinsetzen und komplette Bücher per Copy-and-Paste kopieren. Ich meine, wer macht so was? Ich hab 30 Euro für dieses scheiß Buch ausgegeben. Ich kann nicht mal einen Absatz kopieren.
Wie viel hätte das richtige Buch gekostet?
Das richtige Buch hätte 40 oder so. Das ist 27 gewesen sein, aber es war kein billiges Buch.
Aber hättest du jetzt das PDF auch zu sagen bei O'Reilly oder was auch immer direkt gekauft, dann hättest du das gekonnt.
Es ist kein O'Reilly Buch. Wenn ich es bei O'Reilly hätte kaufen können, wär es wahrscheinlich... Ist jetzt hier The Big Nerd Branch. Das ist hier immer so ein Kindle...
Ich meine, wenn du jetzt bei iBook...
Ich kauf dieses, was... Ich drücke auf den Kaufen-Button. Ich hab mir noch nie Gedanken darum... Also, das ist kein PDF. Weil es hat diese Blätter im Effekt und so was. Das haben ja PDFs alle nicht. Hier, dieses ganz normale... Ich geh in iBooks, geh da in den Bookstore und kauf da ein Buch.
In zehn Minuten. Sie fahren in den iBookstore ein. Wenn sie einfahren, sind sie praktisch... Also in zehn Minuten haben sie das Buch quasi schon am Flughafen. Kennst du nicht diese Edmunds-Show? Ich kauf da einfach so ein Buch. Ich kauf immer nur Bücher bei O'Reilly als PDF.
Also ich wollte bewusst keinen PDF haben, weil PDF kann man auf dem Display halt nicht schlecht lesen.
Ich hab wirklich ähnliche Erfahrungen gemacht wie du, weil ich ja auch eher Fachbücher lesen möchte. Ich bin jetzt auch tatsächlich bei dem Buch, was ich hier gerade lese, sehr versucht, mir tatsächlich noch Pepper-Versionen zu kaufen, weil man da einfach so schön reingreifen kann. Manchmal willst du wirklich das eine mit dem anderen vergleichen und hast einfach so einen Stoßzeiten in der Hand und switchst einfach vor und zurück. Wie war denn das nochmal? Und das ist etwas, was einfach wirklich mit diesen E-Book-Rädern nicht geht. Also so wirklich mal so zwei Punkte zu setzen, wo du immer hin und her bist oder auch so ein Split-View zu haben, das wäre extrem wünschenswert. Kann man allerdings durchaus vorstellen, dass sich das noch bessert. Aber auch diese Qualität der E-Pubs ist ein Problem. Also auch diese File-Formate selber, die Auszeichnung dessen. Also ich hab ganz häufig Fehler. Ich hatte das hier bei dem Buch zum Beispiel, dass sie den Zeilenumbruch verkackt haben in den Code-Beispielen. Das war dann nur in der E-Pub-Version so. Das hab ich dann moniert. Das wurde dann irgendwie korrigiert, woraufhin dann die Mobi-Version, die Kindle-Version, allerdings zusätzliche Linefeeds bekommen hat. Das hab ich auch moniert, das haben sie ja nicht gefixt. Wahrscheinlich haben sie sich gedacht, zumindest ist das nicht alles mehr in einer Zeile und das kriegen wir jetzt nicht einfacher hin. Das war so ein bisschen krank. Ich war aber scharf auf die Mobi-Version, weil es kein E-Pub-Kleid gibt für Mac OS X. Diese Kindle-App ist ja die einzige Möglichkeit, E-Books zu lesen auf dem Mac. Also wahrscheinlich gibt es irgendwas, aber ich hab nichts gefunden, was irgendwie taugt. So. Formatierungsmäßig sind halt die PDFs immer ganz vorne, weil da sieht es halt wirklich so aus, wie es im Buch aussieht mit all den Formatierungen, insbesondere bei so sophisticated Tabellen. Und bei dem E-Pub hast du halt häufig Einschränkungen, dass es einfach nicht so gut aussieht, dass die Tabelle merkwürdig formatiert ist, oder dass einfach da so ein bisschen Visual Feedback fehlt, wie graue Hinterlegungen etc., die einfach wichtig sind, um die Tabelle schnell richtig zu interpretieren. Bis hin zu so absurden Situationen, dass offensichtlich dieses iBooks, also dieses Leseprogramm auf dem iPad, nicht alle Unicode-Zeichen anzeigen kann. Also so eine Ist-Teilmenge von so ein mathematisches Zeichen zum Beispiel, was da halt in so einer Erklärung auftauchte. Ist ja nicht ganz von der Hand zu weisen, dass man sowas mal verwendet in einem informatischen Buch. Zeigt da einfach nicht an. Ich hab's dann gecheckt auf das E-Pop, also im Browser aufgemacht, das ist ja eigentlich nur HTML, also kannst du ja dann schon auch angucken auf dem Mac, aber ist halt nicht so ein schicker Reader. Und da stand das halt korrekt drin. Das war halt Unicode-Zeichen in der Datei und es zeigte dann auf dem Safari auch an, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat dieses WebKit-basierte Tool, dieses iBook, das halt nicht angezeigt. Das ist wirklich krank, so dass man immer wieder zwischen diesen hin und her wandeln muss, je nachdem, wo man es gerade lesen will oder wie wichtig gerade die Formatierung ist. Und PDF hat natürlich dann wieder den Nachteil, da ist die Seite feste, in einer festen Größe und du kannst halt nicht mal eben den Font vergrößern, was ich halt gerne mache, weil ich will auch nicht so viel Text auf einer Seite haben, sondern ich will da wie schnell vorwärts kommen und das gut lesen können auch auf einen großen Abstand halten.
Also das finde ich sehr angenehm an diesem Format, dass es auf einem iPad, also es ist auf allen Geräten gut lesbar, man kann es auch wirklich gut auf dem iPhone lesen. Ich wollte meinem Vater da was zeigen, hatte das iPad nicht dabei, also konnte ich mal rasch das eben auf dem iPhone, hier guck, so sieht das aus. Und das ist natürlich super, aber ansonsten, da kann sich echt noch viel entwickeln.
Da muss man sich aber wie so einen Adobe Blob installieren.
Also ich hab noch, ich hab mir dieses, wie heißt das? Ich wollte dieses Datenfresser, dieses Buch von Kanz Tanze Kurz und Frank Rieger, wollte ich unbedingt als E-Book haben und hab mir das dann, wo hab ich mir das gekauft? In irgendeinem DRM-Laden von, wo man das dann, wo es mit diesem Adobe DRM-System geschützt ist?
Da kannst du dann auch nicht Copy und Paste machen, weil da der Text immer nur als Bild wieder rauskommt.
Also ich hab's, ich hab mir jetzt auf dem iPad diesen Blue Fire Reader, mit dem geht das, mit dem funktioniert das auch soweit ganz okay. Am Mac hab ich's gar nicht erst probiert. Also, hatte ich jetzt gedacht für so ein Buch wie Datenfässer, das will man auch nicht am Mac lesen. Ich hab's jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch noch nicht mal auf dem iPad gelesen. Also ich hab's bisher noch gar nicht gelesen. Es ist halt, das ist natürlich so typisch, man kriegt irgendeine Datei zugeschickt. Also das finde ich bei Amazon eigentlich ganz cool. Du kriegst, du gehst in den Store, kaufst das und dann ist es da. Und dann brauchst du dir keine Gedanken machen. Und dann kriegt man da irgendwie so eine SCM-Datei zugeschickt und die muss man dann irgendwie auf das Gerät wieder drauf kriegen. Das hab ich mir dann selber mit. Und die lädt sich dann irgendwie...
ACSM meinst du?
Oder ACSM, ich hab keine Ahnung. Irgendwie war das so eine 16 Kilo Byte-Datei, wo ich dann so, hä, was soll ich jetzt mit der machen?
Na, da ist nur die Description drin, wo du jetzt die eigentliche Datei herkriegst.
Ja, wie bekloppt! Sollen sie einen Link reinpacken, oder weißt du, was der Teufel ist?
Also irgendwie ist ja alles total krass. Also ich kaufe ja echt nur Bücher, entweder bei PreqProq, Manneken oder O'Reilly. Und da ist es ja dann so, wenn du dir eins dieser Bücher gekauft hast, dann kannst du dir auch später noch das in allen möglichen anderen Formaten runterladen. Das klingt ja irgendwie wie diese ganze andere Welt. Klingt ja total hanebüchen.
Also bei Amazon, das finde ich okay. Ich will da keine dämlichen Dateien runterladen. Ich will da keine Formate. Ich möchte, ich hätte gern, also der Reader muss noch viel, viel besser werden. Der ist im Augenblick so wie er ist, ziemlich scheiße.
Aber ja, wir haben jetzt auf jeden Fall ein Bild wie Scheiße. Also es ist ja wirklich total upturnend. Es ist ja fast noch schlimmer als Musikindustrie.
Wenn man Adobe Digital Edition so runterladen will, muss man Flash installiert haben. Also nur fürs runterladen.
Und dann muss er erstmal Flex installieren und Adobe Air hinterher.
Diese Webseite bietet mir den Download-Link nicht ohne Flash an. Ich kann das echt jedem nur empfehlen, Flash komplett zu entfernen. Das ist wirklich eine interessante Experience. Das ist auch wirklich, man hat gerade so das Gefühl, das Web taucht neu auf. Heutet sich. Ja, aber es füllt sich auch langsam. Also jede Woche geht so die Prozentzahl, wo es dann doch geht, hoch. Also ich merke halt jetzt sofort, wo das Audio spielt, das Video spielt, wer irgendwie seine Embats richtig gesetzt hat und wer nicht. Und es wird langsam wirklich besser. Aber es ist schon noch ein steiniger Weg. Ich muss trotzdem immer noch den, also ohne den Google Flash Player würde das jetzt nicht so schmerzfrei gehen. Insofern ist es eigentlich ganz gut, dass Google diesen Flash Player rausgebracht hat. Haben wir's?
Es ist 22.43 Uhr.
So über drei Stunden. Aber hat ja keiner mal gute Vorschläge, oder?
Die Liste ist doch noch voll. Lass uns doch mal kurz verschnaufen, kurz innehalten.
Du meinst, wir spielen etwas leise Musik?
Vielleicht noch eine rauchen gehen und dann...
Ich weiß nicht, guck dir diese Themen an, die ich hier habe, das ist alles irgendwie so... Alles so... Da können wir genauso nur so uninformiert drüber reden. Wie sonst auch? Ich mach hier mal eine Linie rein.
Letztens ist hier meine Freundin, die hat ja gerade den Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy komplett das erste Mal konsumiert. Und hat dann ja mal den Film gesehen, und ich hab ja schon vorher gesagt, der Film, der Film, der Film ist nicht so cool. Und dann hat sie ihn gesehen und meinte, auch der Film ist wirklich ganz schlimm. Und das fand ich ja auch jetzt so mal im Nachhinein, so als Kulturbeitrag vielleicht noch, so am Ende, ja, eine Schande, was sie mit diesem Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy Film gemacht haben. Oder? Du fandest den auch bestimmt auch total furchtbar. Furchtbar.
Hat jemand von euch diesen Fortschirmartikel gelesen?
Über Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy? Nee, ah, ja, das stimmt, diesen Artikel, den man nur für 499...
Nee, mittlerweile kriegt man billiger für... Man kann ja sich für ein Kindle kaufen, den Artikel separat, ich glaube für ein Euro.
Oh, was geht's Jungs?
So ein Forbes-Typ hier hat doch so einen Inside Apple, wo irgendwie eine Woche lang alle möglichen Leute daraus zitiert haben, aber immer nur die gleichen Passagen, so wie das so bei Apple alles läuft, so Inside Apple Scoop und das gab's halt bei Forbes. Und die hatten halt eine App, wo du da in diesem Artikel für 4,99 Euro shoppen konntest. Hätte ja nicht 4,99 gekostet, vielleicht einen Dollar oder so hätte ich es ja fast gemacht.
Nee, man konnte sich ja das ganze Heft kaufen. Ich hab mir das gekauft, ich hab mir... Ich war ja ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen beeindruckt davon, dass das funktioniert. Also erstmal war ich total überrascht. Ah, jetzt gibt's das da bei Fortune, das kann man sich doch bestimmt im deutschen App Store nicht runterladen. Ging absolut problemlos. Dann stand da irgendwie drin, dass das am 23. das Heft vom 23. Mai werden soll. Wo ich dann so, äh, jetzt machen die bestimmt anfeaturen für irgendwas, was man sich erst in drei Wochen kaufen kann. Nee, man konnte sich sogar das Heft kaufen und sogar von Deutschland aus und schwupp war ich 3, 4, 99 Dollar los oder...
Daran hat sich's gelohnt?
Na ja, es ist schon...
Was stand da jetzt nun genau drin?
Na der hat Interviews mit diversen Leuten bei Apple geführt.
Also sehr vielen Mitarbeitern, ehemalige Aktuelle und hat sich sozusagen versucht, so ein Bild zu machen, wie Apple so intern denn so funktioniert.
Hat zitiert aus der Rede, die damals Steve Jobs wohl gehalten haben soll, nach dem Mobile-Me-Desaster, als Mobile-Me gestartet ist und wir erinnern uns alle...
Ja, das war ja auch ein geiles Zitat auf jeden Fall. Es hat auf jeden Fall Lust gemacht auf diesen Artikel.
Also er hat wohl noch vor, also in Anwesenheit, er hat dieses Team total zusammengefaltet, hat euch gesagt, ihr solltet euch gegenseitig hassen dafür, dass ihr euch gegenseitig im Stich gelassen habt. Und hat dann vor versammelter Mannschaft den Chef der entsprechenden Abteilung ausgewechselt. Was ich ja schon mal echt hart finde. Und was war denn noch so? Dann ist wohl so ein kleinen Spruch, den Steve Jobs jedem Vice-Präsident, also wenn man irgendwie aufsteigt in Richtung Vice-Präsident bei Apple, kriegt man den kleinen Vortrag darüber gehalten, was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem Vice-Präsident und einer Reinigungskraft. Das ist so, erzählt er immer relativ ausführlich, dass wenn man eine Reinigungskraft, wenn man die fragt, wieso hast du nur seit drei Wochen den Müll nicht mehr aus meinem Büro weggebracht? Und dieser Mensch sagt einem, ja, naja, da hat jemand das Schloss ausgewechselt und ich hatte keinen Schlüssel dafür und darum bin ich nicht reingekommen und darum musste hier der Müll liegen bleiben. Dann ist das für jemand, der den Müll wegräumt, eine okaye Antwort. Der darf Gründe nennen, dagegen spätestens irgendwo zwischen Reinigungskraft und Vice President, was jetzt nicht Vizepräsident heißt, verschwindet.
Der Vice President hat halt den Schlüssel, um alle Leute rauszuschmeißen, also den Mülls entfernen.
Der muss jedes Problem, er darf keine Gründe nennen.
Keine Ausreden mehr haben.
Er muss einfach, er muss das Problem lösen. Das war auch so ein Punkt, der da drin stand. Und ansonsten war das aber auch nicht so wahnsinnig, für was da drin stand.
Da waren schon die besten Sachen, wie bei den Teasern von schlechten Filmen, wo im Teaser schon die besten zweieinhalb Minuten zusammengeschnitten werden.
Ist so ein bisschen wie bei einem Spiegelartikel, wo sie jetzt unbedingt irgendwas auf 19 Seiten aufblasen müssen. Was ich ganz cool fand, die Strategie, wie Apple offensichtlich aufgebaut ist, also dass das wirklich eine relativ, also es gibt wohl für jeden, für alles, was bei Apple abläuft, gibt es immer einen Zuständigen. Sofort, immer von Anfang an. Also es gibt nicht, es gibt, wenn intern irgendwelche Projekte besprochen werden, stehen immer sofort einen Namen dahinter. Es gibt für jeden Geschäftsbereich, gibt es genau eine Person, die dafür zuständig ist und die dafür Ansprechpartner ist. Es ist wohl so, dass bei den Apple Stores ist der eine für das äußere Geschäft zuständig, weil der Retail Chef ist, und der andere ist dafür zuständig. Also es ist, die dürfen sich da auch nicht gegenseitig reinreden. Und die oberste Schicht reportet komplett direkt zu Steve Jobs. Und der ist der einzige, der da die Entscheidungen trifft. Und wenn ich das so erlebe, wie das auch in kleineren Firmen ist, wo dann gerne mal schon bei 40-50 Mitarbeitern, da vorne zwei Leute sind, die gemeinsam probieren, die Entscheidungen zu treffen und sich dann immer zusammensetzen. Und da ist ein Unternehmen mit 50.000 Mitarbeitern oder so was in dem Dreh. Und das spitzt sich tatsächlich auf eine Person zu.
Genau, die anderen. Oder CTOs, keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall zu viele.
Und sie arbeiten wohl dran bei Apple? Das ist, dass dieses Prinzip, dass das auch, also dass Apple, so wie es jetzt funktioniert, auch ohne Steve Jobs funktioniert. Also es ist Steve Jobs arbeitet, lässt eine Strategie erarbeiten oder probiert, eine Strategie zu entwickeln. Wie Apple dieses Prinzip, was sie jetzt haben, auch wenn er mal nicht mehr da ist, aufrecht erhalten kann. Also sozusagen...
Die Strategie ist schon erarbeitet. Das ist diese Apple University. Das ist ja auch nichts brandneues. Der hat sich halt irgendwie so einen ehemaligen Professor geholt, glaube ich, von seiner ehemaligen Uni. Und der hat sozusagen die Aufgabe, den Aufsteigern bei Apple zu erklären, wie das aktuelle Management Apple selbst sieht, das zu vermitteln. Also sie wollen sozusagen das, was derzeit in der Firma ist und was vielleicht so ihr Firmware technisch nur in Steve Jobs Hirn abgespeichert ist, das wollen sie sozusagen vermitteln. Beziehungsweise sie schaffen sich einen Mechanismus dieser Vermittlung. Es geht nicht nur darum, es einmal zu erklären, sondern es geht darum, das aufrechtzuerhalten. Sodass wenn du bei Apple ein hohes Tier wirst, also wenn du sozusagen jenseits des reinen Ingenieur-Tums bist und maßgeblich daran mitgestaltest, diesen Laden zu führen, zumindest in Teilen, dass du einfach verstehst, warum Apple so tickt, wie es tickt. Nicht nur wie es tickt, sondern auch warum es so tickt. Es gibt ja so viele Dinge, wo Apple so grundlegend anders ist als andere Unternehmen. Nicht nur jetzt in ihrem Endergebnis, sondern eben auch in der Vorgehensweise. Also allein dieses Ding mit, dass sie, zumindest nur mit extrem wenig Ausnahmen, nie Beraterunternehmen engagieren. Apple hat keine Berater, sondern sie machen alles aus sich selbst heraus. Machen keine Marktforschung mit wenig Ausnahmen.
Was wohl ein wichtiger, ganz wichtig, sie probieren nicht, irgendwelche Geschäftsmodelle zu haben und dafür Produkte zu entwickeln, sondern der Ansatz ist... Ach, das fand ich auch ganz spannend. Es gibt genau eine Person bei Apple, die sozusagen für Finanzen zuständig ist. Und während es ja bei vielen anderen Firmen so ist, du bist jetzt auch, das ist jetzt Zeichen einer gewissen Qualifikation, du hast jetzt eine gewisse Hierarchie erreicht, du bist jetzt auch für Geld zuständig, du musst jetzt auch Ausgaben und Einnahmen im Blick halten und so was. Bei Apple gibt es das nicht, sondern bei Apple ist, egal in welcher Position du bist, für dich dreht sich, zumindest laut dieser Aussage, dreht es sich nie um Geld, sondern dafür ist dann nur genau dieser eine Financial Vice President zuständig und das ist eben sein Job, mit der Kohle umzugehen.
Aber da musst du ja noch ein paar andere geben, die auch irgendwie aufs Geld gucken. Das kann ja nicht olle Tim Cook alleine machen, für jede kleine Scheißausgabe. Die Job muss man ja schon noch so ein bisschen aufsplitten.
Ich nehme an, die werden Budget haben, aber die sind nicht dafür verantwortlich, wie viel Kohle ihre Abteilung macht. Das ist jetzt so meine Interpretation.
So, meine Luft ist raus. Du kannst noch, Max?
Ich kann ja noch alleine. Geh doch schon mal nach Hause.
Genau, wir gehen einfach mal. Du machst den Epilog.
Genau.
Ich lasse ja einfach den Stream an. Aber ich muss Licht schon ausmachen.
Ich hoffe, es stimmt nicht. Dann kommt er doch erst richtig in Stimmung.
Also ich muss ja auch Strom sparen. Ich schalte die Rechner schon mal aus, aber du kannst ja noch weiter streamen.
Strömen auf Akku.
Genau, auf Akku. Einfach mit der eigenen Energie die Leitung leuchten lassen.
Breit?
Nein, ist Quatsch. Wir machen jetzt hier ein Ende, bevor das hier noch eine langweilige Sendung wird. Oder?
Man soll ja aufhören, wenn es am schönsten ist.
Wir haben irgendwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen. Aber das holen wir dann nächstes Mal ab, wenn wir wieder total pünktlich an den Start gehen. Und zwar voraussichtlich wieder genau in zwei Wochen. Denis, bist du da auch dabei?
Was ist denn für ein Datum?
Juni?
Am nächsten Tag fahre ich auf Motorradtour. Da muss ich früh ins Wetter, morgens um 9 Uhr raus. Kommst du mit?
Ich muss auch morgen um 9 Uhr raus.
Juni, da ist es nämlich frei.
Wo, weiß ich nicht.
Macht voll Spaß.
Ja.
Wo hast du denn den Fortschreiter?
Geht zu tun.
Hat jemand den Amazon-Ning?
Gerade die Konferenz vorbei. Und am ersten ist der erste Arbeitstag.
Sonst können wir es vielleicht noch einen Tag nach vorne ziehen. Das werden wir dann bekannt geben.
Nee, bloß nicht. Ich hab da Konferenz und bin auch mal froh. Ja, das ist ja ein 29. und dann so ein paar Tage.
Achso, du machst ja noch deine Euroku... Euru... Euruko ist aber echt ein Zungenbrecher.
Ja, das kriegt keiner auf Anhieb richtig hin.
Euroku?
Das ist eine Ruby-Konferenz und die ist ausverkauft. Von da macht es wenig Sinn, darüber überhaupt noch zu reden. Aber du hast halt jetzt auch mal gespürt, wie es ist, eine Konferenz zu organisieren und es ist anstrengend. Achso, wie wäre es denn nochmal mit so ein bisschen Konferenzwegweisertum? Gibt es noch irgendwelche interessanten Veranstaltungen, auf die wir so ausblicken könnten?
Das Camp gibt es im Sommer.
Richtig. Das Chaos-Communication-Camp findet statt vom 10.
August.
Hab ich vergessen, 6.
Steht im Internet. Ich glaub, da steht noch nicht viel, oder? bis 14.
Ich hab ja vor kurzem dieses lennyrd.com entdeckt. Und das finde ich ja ganz praktisch, zum so auf dem Laufenden halten, was so an Konferenzen in der Stadt oder zu irgendeinem Thema anstehen.
Hilft das wirklich?
Ich hab jetzt für Berlin den RSS-Feed abonniert und krieg jetzt sozusagen immer mit, was in Berlin an Konferenzen so geplant wird. Und wenn dich halt irgendein Thema interessiert, kannst du halt auch sagen, ich will jetzt hier zum Thema Ruby einfach alle Veranstaltungen an einem Feed haben. Und das wird halt auch ganz gut benutzt. Zum Beispiel hier letztens nach Erlangen gesucht. Dann sind halt hier die Erlangen-Veranstaltungen aufgelistet überall. Gleich mit Slides und Videos verlinkt. Und wer da war. Und also lenyert.com find ich echt ganz cool.
Gibt hier auch in Berlin demnächst noch ein paar interessante Veranstaltungen.
Das kann man gleich mal auf lenyert.com gucken.
Ja, und zwar relativ bald. Und da ist glaube ich auch noch nicht ausverkauft. Vom 6. also am 6. und am 7. Juni.
Ja, das ist ganz viel. Jetzt demnächst. Also schon alleine am Wochenende von der Juro-Kurse ist ja noch das Juro-Camp, also irgendwie so eine Ruby-Camp.
Ja, lass mich doch mal erzählen, was da ist und nicht nur wann es ist. Und zwar die Berlin Buzzwords.
Genau, die auch noch, ja.
Das ist eine ganz interessante Konferenz, die sich nämlich um diesen ganzen NoSQL-Bereich dreht.
Ja, aber auch so generell alles, was gerade brennt an Technologie, oder?
Also die sind nicht nur darauf festgelegt.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, geht es da auch um... Also Node.js hatten sie da glaube ich auch.
Also The Conference of High Scalability ist hier so das Thema. Da geht es so um Hadoop und diesen ganzen Kram. Zumindest kommt das auch aus dieser Hadoop-Szene. Die trägt das so ein bisschen. Also so suchen, speichern, schon so die Anforderungen von Großdevelopment. Aber da werden halt einfach so die Architekturen besprochen, die derzeit so trending sind. Und zwar nicht nur, weil es jetzt Buzzwords sind, mit denen man so rumwirft, sondern es handelt sich ja auch wirklich um Technik, die da zum Einsatz kommt. Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr interessant hier in der Urania.
Genau, und dann gibt es halt, wie gesagt, an dem Wochenende von der Juroko, gibt es noch das Jurocamp als Alternativveranstaltung für die...
Das ist auch schon ausverkauft....
Ruby Huxer. Ja, aber ich glaube, die sind noch ein bisschen lockerer, wenn es dann darum geht, da wirklich noch Leute reinzulassen. Dann gibt es die RailswayCon. Allerdings ist das so eine eher business-orientierte Sendung, wollte ich schon sagen, Konferenz. Dann gibt es den Music Hack Day. Was hast du da gerade gesagt? Jurocamp und RailswayCon. Die ist im BCC, glaube ich.
Ist mittlerweile so ein Schönheitswettbewerb um den Namen, der am schwierigsten ausgesprochen ist. Ich würde generell einfach Vokale schon mal weglassen. Sonst kriegt man die Domänen ja eh nicht.
Genau. Dann gibt es halt den Music Hack Day und den Movie Hack Day. Der Music Hack Day ist von Soundcloud, glaube ich, gefeatured und der Movie Hack Day von MoviePilot. Und da geht es wohl irgendwie auch so um Treffen und thematisch irgendwie rumhacken. Aber die machen auf jeden Fall auch gerade so ein bisschen Wirbel. Und die sind auch in dieser... Also der Movie Hack Day ist am 4. Juni und der Music Hack Day ist tatsächlich auch am Samstag, wo auch die Yuruku ist und die Verbinale ist am 30. Mai, was auch immer die Verbinale 2011 ist.
Dann gestern noch den Tipp bekommen. Es gibt echt viel, vor allem so viel in Berlin. Am 15. Juni eine Konferenz, die heißt Crowd Convention. Da geht es um dieses ganze Crowdsourcing-Thema vor allem. Aber auch Crowdfunding und überhaupt viel Crowd, aber vor allem auch so Crowdsourcing scheint da... Deswegen treffen sie sich vielleicht in Deutschland. Weltweit als Experten für Crowd.
Ja, also in Berlin geht wirklich total viel. Also hier auch die Random Hacks of Kindness ist auch so eine ganz nette Veranstaltung. Oder der hundertste deutsche Bibliothek K-Tag. Was? Guckt einfach auf lanyard. Da gibt es dann auch Konferenzen in eurer Nähe, falls ihr nicht aus Berlin kommen solltet, unwahrscheinlicherweise. Das ist wirklich eine coole Seite, um mal zu gucken. Also alle, die du jetzt genannt hast, die standen auch auf lanyard.com.
Ja gut, ich meine nicht alles, was da steht, ist jetzt vielleicht auch interessant oder relevant. Das ist ja so das Ding.
Aber du kannst halt sagen, ich will Berlin, und dann gibt es halt Filter bei Topic, und dann kannst du noch sagen, ich will jetzt nur Web oder so. Also es ist schon ganz cool. Du bist doch da auch, oder? Du hast doch da dich auch letztens bei der R-Launch.
Ja, ich hab mir da mal so einen Account geklickt, das ist übliche Standard-Web-Zwein und Interesse, aber das ist jetzt nicht so die Zeit gewesen, die mich gleich so total umgeworfen hat. Die haben ja eine ganze Appearance.
Naja, du musst ja nicht mal deinen Account anlegen, den kannst du einfach mit Twitter ein-signen.
Das mach ich prinzipiell nicht. Ich sign mich nirgendswo mit Facebook oder Twitter ein. Ich benutze keinen Single-Sign-On. Ich mach mir überall einen eigenen Account mit eigenem Passwort, damit ich weiß, was ich wegwerfen kann.
Wo der Hase im Teil verlegt.
Ja, ich will nicht so viel an einem Account hängen lassen. Das ist nicht so mein Style. Dafür hab ich One Password.
Ja, dafür ist es da.
So.
Jetzt haben wir den letzten Drops gelutscht.
Um welche einwende? Nee, der Rest startet eh nur noch total apathisch.
Paralyseert.
So Leute, das war's.
Das war's für heute.
Danke fürs Zuschauen und bis bald!